GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO GET STARTED WITH THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
THIS IS THE COMMITTEE'S FIRST
HEARING THE SESSION NOW WOULD
YOU AUDIT REQUEST WILL BE HEARD
THIS IS ALSO OUR FIRST HEARING
FOR OUR NEW- COMMITTEE
SECRETARY KATIE GOT THREE I
WOULD LIKE TO CONGRATULATE OUR
PREVIOUS SECTORS- MISTER
SECRETARY- MARTIN ON HIS. IN
HIS NEW ROLE IN HIS NEW
ENDEAVORS SO LOOK FORWARD TO A
PRODUCTIVE HEARING TODAY. I
NOTE THAT WE ARE REQUIRING
MASKS TO BE WORN IN THE HEARING
ROOM THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
AMASSED ONE CAN BE PROVIDED TO
YOU. ON THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION I WANT TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW THAT IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM. WITNESSES A
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN MAKE
USE OF OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY.
STATION LOCATED ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL. FOR
DIALING IN AND WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR WITNESSES FOR THE
PUBLIC. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ONCE AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN THAT'S. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE TO PROVIDE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE. REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. BECAUSE OF
TIME CONSTRAINTS PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE
EACH AND WILL HAVE A TOTAL TIME
OF FIFTEEN MINUTES ALLOWED ON
EACH OTHER QUEST FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PTIENCE. NOW MOVING ON TO
TODAY'S HEARING WE HAVE A VERY
AMBITIOUS CALENDAR TODAY I'M
APPRECIATIVE TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO BE HERE FOR A LAKE HEARING
WAS SUCH A LARGE CALENDAR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO OVERSIGHT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AT THE SAME TIME I
AM. ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS. HOW
SORRY I AM THAT WE CANNOT HEAR
ALL OF THE REQUEST. THIS YEAR
WE HAD MORE THAN THIRTY AUDIT
REQUESTS AND TODAY'S AGENDA. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE EIGHTEEN ITEMS.
BUT WE'VE RECEIVED OVER THIRTY
AND I KNOW SOME MORE. WHERE
BACKLOG BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
FROM LAST YEAR AS WELL. AT THIS
TIME I KNOW THE. LET ME ASK MY
VICE SURE TO SEE IF HE HAS ANY
OPENING REMARKS BEFORE MOVING
ON- MISTER LET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
AND JUST. FOLLOWING ON TO YOUR
STATEMENT- WE HAD BASICALLY
TWICE AS MANY AUDITS AS COULD
BE HEARD IN ONE HEARING. AND SO
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER HAD TO BE
BONTA AUGUST I KNOW THAT CAUSED
CONSTERNATION WITH A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HAD ORDERED STEP
WERE BUMPED TO AUGUST. AND I
THINK THAT THE ONE THING AND
THERE'S ONE ARTIST IN
PARTICULAR. OUR OUR SENATOR
GLAZERS THAT IS TIME SENSITIVE
IN SOME WAYS AND SO I THINK
THAT WE HAVE THE OPTION
PROVIDED THERE'S VERGE TO DO
THE AUDIT. OF EXPEDITING IT
WHEN WE CONSIDERED IN AUGUST
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. TO
JUST TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE WITH THE
FACT THAT THERE WERE SO MANY
MORE PRODUCTS THAN THERE WERE
ABILITY TO PROCESS AT THIS
MEETING SO I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. CALL OUT THAT
ONE CASE AND- APPRECIATE THAT
EVERYBODY'S WILLING TO WORK ON
THIS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THE BILL BE TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS AND I. ALSO HERE WERE
THREE HEARINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON AT ONCE SO I'M GONNA HAVE TO
LEAVE AT SOME POINT TO VOTER
ROLLS BUT I'LL BE BACK THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE AND WITH HAT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND CALL QUORUM SINCE WE
HAVE FOR HIM AT THIS TIME MADAM
SECRETARY CLUB CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS PRESENT.
BOERNER HORVATH KILEY.
PATTERSON RUBIO. VOEPEL. ONE
SENATE EARLIER HERE. BACKER FOR
JUST. GLAZER HERTZBERG. LEYVA
NIELSEN THIS WALKING RIGHT IN
BILLS OF. HERE. ROLL ROLL CALL.
OKAY WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
ON WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO TODAY'S AGENDA TODAY'S
AGENDA WE WILL BEGIN- WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE THAT IS A STATUS
REPORT AND WORK IN PROGRESS AND
THAT'S PRESENTATION FROM OUR
MADAM STATE AUDITOR BENEFIT
UNDER A BELIEVE YOU WERE WITH
US REMOTELY CAN YOU HEAR US.
YES MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I NEED
TO CALL ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ON HERE WITH ME IN THIS IN OUR
EXECUTIVE- CONFERENCE ROOM HERE
IN THE OFFICE MY CHILDREN IS A
DEPUTY STATE AUDITOR WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE AT A LOCAL HIGH
RISK WORK THAT WE DO. SO HE'LL
BE ABLE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THOSE REQUESTS ARE
DEFINITELY REMEMBERS RIDGEWAY
IS MY CHIEF COUNSEL SO SHE WILL
BE ABLE TO ASSIST IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS RELATED TO. OP
LEGAL ISSUES ACCESS ISSUES
ETCETERA BUT QUICKLY- STATUS
REPORT WE CURRENTLY HAVE SEVEN
AUDITS- THAT WERE APPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE OR OR STATUTORY
AUDITS WE ONLY HAVE ONE AUDIT
THAT WAS APPROVED BY THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
THAT IS STILL. ONGOING AND
THAT'S OF COURSE BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN ABLE TO MEET
FOR MANY MONTHS SO- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE. TO GET ALL OF THE WORK
THAT THE COMMITTEE ASKED US TO
DO ALL LAST YEAR- THAT
CERTAINLY THE PANDEMIC SLOW
THINGS DOWN. BUT WE GOT THE
EMERGENCY AUDIT NON. EIGHTY
EIGHT AND ANY OTHER WORK SO
WE'VE COME A LOT OF WATER IT'S
WE SIX STAFF. AUDITS UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW PRIMARILY ARE
FINANCIAL LOGIC GROUP- BUT WE
DO AVE A COUPLE OF OTHER
STATUTORY AUDITS THAT WERE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON. AS A
MEMBER AND THE CHAIRMAN AND
VICE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED THERE
ARE A LOT OF REQUESTS TO BE
CONSIDERED AT THE HEARING
TODAY. THERE ARE FIFTEEN MEMBER
REQUESTS AND THREE REQUESTS
FROM MY OFFICE RELATED TO LOCAL
FLAVOURS FOREGROUND. WHAT I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS WAY OUR
LOCAL HIGH RISK PROGRAM WORKS.
IS THOSE ARE THE LOWEST
PRIORITY OF ANYTHING THAT WERE
REQUIRED TO DO STATUTORY
WORKFORCE COMES FIRST. ANY
REQUESTED OR APPROVED THAT OUR
MEMBER REQUESTS ARE THE NEXT
PRIORITY AND THEN OUR LOCAL
HIGH RISK TO THE EXTENT WE'VE
MET OUR STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE
LEGISLATURE INCIDENT MEMBERS
THEN WE WOULD COMMENCE THESE
LOCALS I RESPONDED SO. WELL IT
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY I'D SKIP.
TODAY AND THAT SUBSEQUENT
HEARING. ALL THESE LOCAL HAVE
RESPONDED TO NOT GOING TO TAKE
PLACE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE RESERVE
THE TEAMS AS WE SHOULD FOR. ALL
OF THE REQUESTS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE SO. I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE I POINTED THAT OUT.
WITH RESPECT TO SELL WE- ENOUGH
COULD. TO START YOU KNOW WHAT
IT'S- AS YOU CAN SEE THE STAT
REPORT. NOW AND CLOSE TO THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR- THAT
WILL BE STAGGERED WE ACTUALLY
HAVE SEVEN TEAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. TO HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING IN JULY WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY NEXT WEEK. ARE WE
ALSO CAN START TO MORE AUDITS
IN AUGUST. FIVE MORE IN
SEPTEMBER AND THEN AN
ADDITIONAL AUDIT IN OCTOBER AND
AGAIN IF WE ARE ABLE TO FREE UP
ANY ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL
BE THAT. WHAT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT WILL
ANYTHING THAT GETS APPROVED
TODAY THAT YOU BELIEVE IS HIGH
PRIORITY. ALL WE CAN GET THAT
STARTED IN JULY BUT WE WILL
HAVE A RESOURCE TO SPRING UP IN
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER. OF TWO A
ADDRESS ANYTHING THAT'S
APPROVED TODAY OR IF THERE'S A
I'M NOT IT A SUBSEQUENT AUDIT
AS VICE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED.
THAT MAY BE A HIGHER PRIORITY
WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
ASSIGN A TEAM TO THAT WATER.
WHEN IT'S APPROVED EITHER IN
AUGUST OR SEPTEMBER DEPENDING
ON WHEN THE COMMITTEE NOT MAKES
THAT DECISION SO I WANTED TO.
LET RESPECTED MEMBERS OF THE ON
THE AUDIT COMMITTEE. NO ABOUT
THAT. WE ALSO HAVE TWO
ADDITIONAL STATUTORY AUDITS
THAT WE WILL BE COMMENCING THIS
FALL WE'VE ALREADY ACCOUNTED
FOR THOSE WE HAVE STAFF
AVAILABLE TO DO THAT ALSO THOSE
DO NOT AFFECT. THE FIFTEEN THAT
I WAS REFERRING TO AS FAR AS
THE NUMBER WE CAN START BETWEEN
NOW AND THE END OF THE YEAR.
THE TWO STATUTORY. OUTS THAT
WOULD HAPPEN MINUTES. OUR
REALLY TO YOU TOBACCO. PRO
THIRTY SIX WE HAVE DO THAT I A
BY ANY BASIS- WE NEED GET THAT.
LATER THIS FALL. AND THEN- WE
HAVE AN AUDIT THAT WE DO OF
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THEIR
PROCUREMENT PRACTICES. AGAIN
THAT ALL IT DOES HAVE A
STATUTORY DEADLINE OF JANUARY
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO START THAT
ARE LATER THIS FALL BUT WE
ALREADY HAVE. INDIVIDUALS READY
TO GO ON THOSE PARTICULAR
AUDITS ALSO BACK TO THE NUMBER
FIFTEEN WE CAN START FIFTEEN
AUDITS- BETWEEN YOU KNOW NEXT
WEEK AND- TOWARDS THE END OF
THIS YEAR. WITH THAT MISTER
GERALD. DO YOU. THANK YOU MADAM.
THIS TIME LET'S GO TO AND- TURN
IT TO. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ON THE STATUS REPORT OF THE
STATE HONOR. OKAY HEARING AND
SAYING NONE- WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON BUT AT THIS
TIME SINCE WE BEFORE WE LOSE A
MEMBER SO OTHER COMMITTEES TO
GO VOTE. I'D LIKE TO SEE IF WE
CAN MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BUT BEFORE WE MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE TO SUSPEND J.
LACK RULES. NUMBER THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN SO IF I COULD GET A
MOTION TO SUSPEND THE ROOF.
RIGHT MOVE BY SENATOR LEYVA
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO- BETTER SECURE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO SUSPEND
J. LACK RULES THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN TO VOTE ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS- RIGHT BEFORE WE
WILL WE DO THAT- TWENTY. OKAY.
TO BE CLEAR AND I JUST FOR
TRANSPARENCY PURPOSES ON. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE VOTING ON THE RULES
TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHEN WE
MOVED TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE PUBLICLY
THAT ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. AT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH EIGHT OH
SIX LOCAL HIGH RISK ASSESSMENT
CITY OF RICHMOND AS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AND WITH THAT- MADAM
SECRETARY GOOD IN A CONTINUAL.
THE MOTIONS TO SUSPEND J. LIKE
ROSS THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS
I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I KILEY.
PATTERSON RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL I WOULD. WOOD I
SENATOR LAYERED FOR LAYERED I
BACKER. BAKER I FOR JUST.
GLAZIER GLAZER AYE HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I RIGHT. THANK YOU THAT
MOTION CARRIES WILL HOLD ON FOR
JUST ONE MEMBERS THAT ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS THERE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR WITH
THE SUBTRACTION OF ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE THE FOR THE CITY OF
RICHMOND FROM THE PROPOSED
CONTRACT CAL SO MOVED BY
SENATOR LEYVA SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS. I REQUEST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH
ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGES K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. I REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH TWO
INDIAN GAMING SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND BY SOMEONE
MEMBER EACH ARSIA. I REQUEST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OF
EIGHT BELLFLOWER UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER C.
GARCIA. I REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE TWELVE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CHILD
ABUSE CENTRAL INDEX BY SOMEONE
MEMBER LACKEY. I REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE THIRTEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BATTERER
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. AUTO
REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ELECTRICAL
SYSTEM SAFETY OVERSIGHT BY
SOMEONE MEMBER SALAS. I REQUEST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE
EIGHTEEN STEP STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD SAFE
DRINKING WATER BY SOMEONE
MEMBER SALAS. I REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE TWENTY
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IN HOME RESPITE
PROGRAM BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA. I REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE TWENTY THREE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE SERVICES
HOSPICE LICENSURE AND OVERSIGHT
BY SENATOR ALAN. I REQUEST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH EIGHT OH
TWO LOCAL HIGH RISK ASSESSMENT
THE CITY OF COMPTON BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. I
REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
EIGHT OH FIVE LOCAL HIGH RISK
ASSESSMENT CITY OF CALEXICO BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI. SALAS
I. PRINTER FOR ABOUT.
BOERNER HORVATH I KILEY.
PATTERSON RUBIO. RUBIO I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WORD. WOOD I SENATOR
LAYER FIVE LAYER I BACKER.
BAKER I LARGEST. GLAZIER GLAZER
AYE HERTZBERG. LEYVA LEYVA AYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI. OKAY THE
MOTION CARRIES WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO
ADD ON A WITH THAT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO OUR REGULAR
CALENDAR WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH
FOUR METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
YOU SEE MISTER GIBSON IS IN THE
CHAMBER WITH US MISTER GIBSON
WHEN YOU ARE READY TO PROCEED
PLEASE PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS JOINT LET'S
HEAD OF AUDIT COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT. AT THIS
BILL OUR STUDENTS. WITH THIS
AUDIT REQUEST. OF THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT. AN
AUDIT. OF ALL PERSONAL
PERSONNEL POLICIES AND
PRACTICES OF THE METROPOLITAN.
WATER BOARD. IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY. AND
PROVIDE STATE OVERSIGHT. A
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY AS
WELL AS PREVENT. WORK PLACE
DISCRIMINATION. INCLUDING
HARASSMENT BULLYING AND
RETALIATION AND RELATED ISSUES
IN LIGHT OF RECENT REPORTS
RISING RAISING SERIOUS CONCERNS
OVER METROPOLITANS HUMAN
RESOURCE PRACTICES. ON FEBRUARY
THE TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE. TWENTY CURRENT AND FORMER
STAFFERS HAVE COME FORWARD
EXPOSING. A PATTERN OF
COMPLAINTS ALLEGING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND BULLYING OF
WOMEN WHO ENROLLED IN THE
APPRENTICE PROGRAM AND
METROPOLITAN METROPOLITAN
WORKERS NEED A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF THESE MATTERS. WHICH
IS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
PREVENT. OF THESE THINGS FROM
TAKING PLACE. THE DAY IN
JUSTICE IN IT WE FOUND BASED ON
PEOPLE'S REPORTS IS THAT WOMEN
AND LGBTQ PLUS INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS AND METROPOLITAN HAVE
BEEN HARASSED. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN WOMEN WORKING
IN TRADE POSITIONS FOR THE
DISTRICT AND SIX OF THEM FILED
FORMAL COMPLAINTS. AFTER THEIR
COMPLAINTS. THE WOMEN SAID THAT
THEY WERE IGNORED. DISMISSED BY
AGENCY OFFICIALS AS THEY
COMPLAINED AND PLEADED FOR HELP.
THREE SAID THAT THEY WERE
PRESSURED TO CONTINUE WORKING
AROUND MEN THAT MEN THAT THEY
ACCUSED OF ABUSING OF ABUSIVE
BEHAVIOR OR TO SEEKING LOW
PAYING OTHER POSITIONS. ONE
WOMAN WAS EVEN TRANSFERRED TO A
FACILITY MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
MILES FROM HER HOME A MOVE THAT
SPLIT HER FAMILY. APART. ON
OCTOBER TWENTY SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION WAS IITIATED BY
THE METROPOLITAN PERSONNEL AND
TECHNOLOGY COMMITTEE. BUT THERE
IS CONCERNS THAT INVESTIGATION
WILL BE ADEQUATE TO. THE SCOPE
OF THE PROBLEM AND FOCUS TOO
NARROWLY. RATHER THAN TAKE A
BROADER LOOK AT THE EMPLOYEES
EXPERIENCE AND METROPOLITAN IN
ORDER TO CREATE THE
INSTITUTIONAL CHANGES NECESSARY
TO ENSURE WORKPLACE FREE FROM
BULLYING DISCRIMINATION
HARASSMENT RETALIATION AND
OTHER ABUSE ON THE JOB. MEMBERS
WE MUST DO AND AT AND OF
SUPPORT THIS RECOMMENDATION FOR
AN AUDIENCE WE BELIEVE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AS THE FORMER
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
THE STATE AUDITOR CAN GO IN AND
DO A VERY COMPREHENSIVE AND
FORENSIC LOOK- THAT WAS SHARED
SIGNIFICANT BUT A VERY VITAL
IMPORTANT LIGHT ON WHAT'S GOING
ON AT THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHAT I VOTE- AUTHORIZING
SUCH OUGHT TO BE DONE. THANK
YOU MISTER GIBSON AT THIS TIME
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. IF WE
CAN HAVE THEM- GET ON THE LINE.
AND LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
MISTER ALAN SHANAHAN EXECUTIVE
PRESIDENT OF ASPEN LOCAL.
NINETEEN OH TWO AND MISS ELLEN
MCKAY CHAIR OF ASKING LOCAL
BANK YOU KNOW TO- WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. SO WE ASK OUR OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN- PLEASE QUEUE UP THE
WITNESSES. BUT IF THERE'S A
LIGHTER OPEN. PLEASE PROCEED.
MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS ELLEN
MACKEY AS CHAIR OF THE ALBANY
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND A THIRTY
YEAR DISTRICT EMPLOYEES I'VE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE RAMPANT
ABUSE FACING WORKERS
PARTICULARLY WOMEN AND LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND THE EXTENT TO WHICH
IT'S BEEN DISMISSED ACCEPTED OR
DOWNRIGHT PROMOTED BY
MANAGEMENT. TO QUOTE IT'S NOT
SAFE TO BE A WOMAN IN THE
DESERT AT M. W. D. A JARRING
STATEMENT PARTIALLY EXPRESSED
BY A TRANSITIONING NON BINARY
PERSON WHO WAS PUBLICLY
REPRIMANDED FOR HAVING A
PROFITABLE IN THEIR EMAIL
SIGNATURE BROUGHT BLOCK DURING
PRIDE MONTH. ANOTHER JOKING
EXAMPLE DISTRICT MANAGEMENT HIT
A DESERT EMPLOYED BY FROM THE
M. W. D. BOARD UNTIL AN LA
TIMES ARTICLE EXPECTED.
EVERYBODY WORKERS ACROSS
DECADES HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
DAMAGED BY THE UNFAIR TREATMENT
INCLUDING SAFETY VIOLATIONS
ADMINISTERED BY TO GET DISTRICT
MANAGEMENT RULES ARE UNEVENLY
APPLIED DEPENDING. ON WHETHER
YOU ARE IN GROUP OR A GROUP.
THIS LEGACY ABOUT NEED END THE
PUBLIC IS WATCHING AND TO ME
THAT AUDIT NOW THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO MR
SHANAHAN PLEASE. THANK YOU YOUR
SALAS UNKNOWN MENTIONED LEADERS
ON THE MEDIA NOT RUN THE AGENCY
IN A MANNER WHICH SERVICE THE
INTERESTS OF THE PUBLIC.
EFFORTS TO LIMIT OVERSIGHT
RESTRICTING THE SCOPE OF THE
ETHICS DEPARTMENT SUPPORTING
CRONYISM JUST TO NAME A FEW HAS
CREATED A CULTURE OF
RETALIATION FAVORITISM AND
FEAR. THE BOYS ARE AFRAID TO
FILE COMPLAINTS OR GRIEVANCES
THAT IT'LL BE HELD AGAINST THEM
AND EFFECTIVE CAREERS DOZENS OF
EMPLOYEES ARE REQUIRED TO FILE
NDAS WHICH PAPERS OVER THE
ABUSES AND WASTE PUBLIC MONEY
DUE TO EVER INCREASING LEGAL
COSTS AND SOMEONE SAID- NOT
DISCLOSED TO THE BOARD. THE
STATE AUDIT WOULD BE FAR MORE
COMPREHENSIVE TRANSPARENT
COMPLEMENT THE SHOW
INVESTIGATION WHICH IS LIMITED
TO FOUR ISSUES AND ONLY LOOKED
AT OTHER MATTERS IF THEY ARE
BROUGHT TO LIGHT BY EMPLOYEES.
M. W. D. WAS PREVIOUSLY AUTUMN
TWO THOUSAND THREE BUT
LEADERSHIP FAILED TO IMPLEMENT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
COMMITMENTS THEY MADE TO THE
PUBLIC AND LEGISLATURE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH AND
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE NEW GM
WAS COMMITTED TO FIXING ISSUES
AT END OF THE DAY BUT
COMPREHENSIVE STATE AUDIT INTO
THESE MATTERS ALONG WITH THE
SHAH REPORT WILL ONLY SERVE TO
PROVIDE THE NEW GM. FORD AND
REPRESENTATIVES WITH THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
EFFECTUATE CHANGE AT NWT. ALL
EMPLOYEES ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
PUBLIC SERVICE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO WORK FOR AN AGENCY THAT
EXEMPLIFIES DIVERSITY FAIRNESS
EQUITY AND INCLUSION. FREE FROM
RETALIATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS I'M NOT A REQUEST THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
TEST. AT THE TIME WE'RE GOOD GO
TO MOVE TO THE STATE ON. REPORT
ON. ITEM TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE OF FOUR METAMODEL FOR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
INDICATED I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE AUTO INJECTORS AT A
FAIRLY HIGH LEVEL- THERE ARE A
LOT OF OBJECTIVES BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I SHARE WITH YOU TE
KEY. AREAS THAT- MISTER GIBSON
AND OTHERS HAVE ACCESS TO LOOK
AT FIRST OF ALL LOOKING AT HOW
M. W. D. INSURERS PEOPLE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS BOTH IN RECRUITING.
FOR PREPARATION OF THEIR
EXAMINATIONS PROMOTION
DECISIONS TRANSFER DECISIONS AT
CETERA. WHAT KIND OF
COMMUNICATION AND- TRANSPARENCY
DOES M. W. T. HAVE AS FAR AS
NOTIFYING EMPLOYEES AND
CERTAINLY UNION REPRESENTATIVES
REGARDING CHANGES TO ANY OF
THOSE. PERSONNEL PROBLEMS SEIZE
OUR PERSONNEL PRACTICES. IN THE
ARMY DID MANY YEARS AGO WE
ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR
THEY WERE CHANGING. OUR
PRACTICES AND AGING BECAUSE FOR
JOB DESCRIPTIONS AND THAT WAS
NOT COMMUNICATED WELCOME PLACE
OR THE UNION REP SO MISTER
GIBSON AND OTHERS ARE ASKING US
TO LOOK AT THAT. ALSO WITH
RESPECT TO SOME OF THE SAME
ISSUES WHAT KIND OF TRAINING IS
M. W. D. PROVIDING TO.
EMPLOYEES ABOUT THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BULLYING SAFETY IN
THE WORKPLACE- PARTICULARLY
RELATED TO THEIR HAZARDOUS
WASTE- MERGES YOU RESPONSE
PROGRAM. ALSO ASKING US TO LOOK
AT THE POLICIES AND PRACTICES
THAT M. W. D. AND BRACES ARE
USE IT FOR HAVE A LANKY-
COMPLAINTS WOULD LOOK AT THAT
PROCESS AND ASSESS IT. AND THEN
WITH RESPECT TO THAT. LOOKING
AT NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS THE
USE OF THOSE AGREEMENTS.
INVOLVING NEEDED ME OR
COMPLAINTS SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS OF WORKPLACE
BULLYING COMPLAINTS HOW IS THAT
PROCESS- HOW DOES THAT PROCESS
WORK AND HOW DO THEY DECIDE TO
USE. THAT PROCESS AS FAR AS
ENTERING INTO A NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENT ONE OF THE CONCERNS
WE IDENTIFIED IN THE REPORT
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR.
SOME EMPLOYEES WERE SIGNING
THOSE AGREEMENTS NOT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT
PRECLUDED THEM FROM LITIGATION
IN THE FUTURE SO WE REALLY NEED
TO LOOK AT THAT PROCESS. ALSO.
HOW MUCH INFORMATION IS
REPORTED TO THE BOARD I
SPECIFICALLY. TO SETTLE MY
AGREEMENT- REGARDING AND- CA.
ALSO WE WOULD LOOK AT THAT.
EVALUATING THE SAY PROGRAM- AND
SPECIFIC ITEM THAT MISTER
GIBSON AND OTHERS ARE
INTERESTED IN IT. OUR OUR
INCIDENTS REPORTED- WHAT'S THE
ROLE OF SAFETY REPRESENTATIVES
WHO WHO ARE IN THE WORKPLACE DO
THEY HAVE. THREE OPPORTUNITY
TO. REPORT SOMETHING AND THEN
HOW IS THAT REPORT ARE HANDLED.
THEIR SAFETY EQUIPMENT PROVIDED
FOR EMPLOYEES AND ASKING US TO
LOOK AT A SELECTION OF
COMPLAINTS TO DETERMINE HOW
WELL THOSE COMPLAINTS WERE
HANDLED- WITH RESPECT TO A
REPORT OF AN UNSAFE CONDITION
WASN'T PROPERLY ADDRESSED. AND
WHAT WERE THE THEY ARE
PRACTICES THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE AFTER THAT- COMPLAINT WAS
INVESTIGATED AND THEN
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT
THERE ARE ADEQUATE PRACTICES TO
PREVENT RETALIATION AGAINST AN
EMPLOYEE OR ONE OF THESE
WORKPLACE SAFETY
REPRESENTATIVES WHO REPLACED
REPORT UNSAFE CONDITIONS. THE
LAST TWO AREAS RELATED TO THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE OPERATIONS
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PROGRAM
MISTER GIBSON AND OTHERS REALLY
WANT. THAT'S THAT PROGRAM HOW
EFFECTIVE IS IT AND MAKING SURE
THAT EMPLOYEES ARE PROTECTED
AND THAT PROGRAM OPERATES
EFFECTIVELY AND THEN THE LAST
AREAS REALLY LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE OBLIGATIONS THAT- AND WD
HAS AS A LANDMARK FOR ITS
EMPLOYEES IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE REAP THE
MEMBER A LETTER FROM THE
MEMBERS MISTER NIXON. EMPLOYEES
ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT- ON.
CONDITIONS OF SOME OF THE
CONDITIONS IN THE HOMES THAT
THEY LIVE IN OR THE THEY'VE
DISABILITIES THAT THEY RESIDE
IN- ARE HAVE HALF HABITABILITY
ISSUES ARE SO WE WOULD LOOK AT
THAT LIVING CONDITIONS WE WOULD
LOOK AT LANDLORD TENANT.
RELATIONSHIPS SO A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT THINGS RELATED TO
INTERVIEW THE SERVING AS A
LANDLORD FOR A SUBSECTION OF
ITS EMPLOYEES. I WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR- THE BUDGET ON
THIS IS ABOUT TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED HOURS A TEAM WOULD TAKE.
ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS TO CONDUCT
THAT WORK. I'LL HEAD BACK YOU
KNOW CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
WATER THE REPORT- AT THIS TIME
LET'S GO AHEAD TO AFFECTED AGE
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE WITH US
ON THE PHONE- MISS KATHY VIE
TELE EXECUTIVE LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE- WITH THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE CAN
MOVE TO THE PHONES PLACE. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR LETTER TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A FEW
REMARKS TODAY. METROPOLITAN
STANDS READY TO COOPERATE FULLY
SAID THE COMMITTEE DECIDED ON
FORWARD WITH AN AUDIT OR BOARD
LED BY CHAIRMAN GLORIA GRAY AND
MANAGEMENT CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT
THE EMPLOYEE CONCERNS REGARDING
SYSTEMIC DISCRIMINATION
HARASSMENT AND RETALIATION OF
METROPOLITAN. I WANT THIS
NUMBER THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
COMMISSIONED AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW TO LOOK INTO THEIR
CONCERNS AND OUR EEO POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES THE SCHALL LAW
GROUP IS SCHEDULED TO FULLY
BRIEFED THE BOARD ON THEIR
FINDINGS IN LATE JULY. AND A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND HAND
THE BOARD WILL BE FULLY
PREPARED TO TAKE APPROPRIATE
ACTION TO AFFECT POSITIVE
CHANGE IN OUR WORKPLACE. AND IN
ADDITION EARLIER THIS MONTH OUR
BOARD SELECTED THE NEW GENERAL
MANAGER IDEOLOGICALLY ALSO TO
REPLACE THE RETIRING GENERAL
MANAGER JEFFREY KIGHTLINGER.
MISTER HOW TO KHALIL HAS
PLEDGED TO PARTNER WITH THE
LABOR UNIONS AND CHART A
COLLABORATIVE AND RESPECTFUL
CULTURE METROPOLITAN WHERE
EVERY VOICE IS HEARD. PROMOTING
AND ADVANCING AN INCLUSIVE WORK
ENVIRONMENT ANCHORED IN MUTUAL
RESPECT EQUITY AND FAIRNESS AS
ONE OF HIS STATED PRIMARY
MISSION. IN CLOSING I WANT TO
REITERATE OUR DESIRE TO ASSIST
WITH THE STATE AUDIT AND ANYWAY
YOU CAN METROPOLITAN IS EAGER
AND OPEN TO LEARN FROM THE PAST
SO WE CAN BE THE BEST
METROPOLITAN. POSSIBLE IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU YOUR TEST. THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVED- PUBLIC COMMENT AND AFTER
THAT THEY WILL COME BACK TO
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS. SO
PUBLIC PROMENADE BY THE PUBLIC
TO COMMENT ASK THEM SAY THEIR
NAME POSIION AND TO BE BRIEF
REMINDS. AND- PLEASE. LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS AS WE ONLY HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES ON EACH
REQUEST. I DO WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE THE CHAMBER WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF THIS ITEM. OKAY
I SEE ONE. AND THE CHAMBER
PLEASE PROCEED TO GET BEGIN
WITH YOUR NAME AND THE POSITION
OR WHERE YOU RESIDE RIGHT I'M
JAMIE PRITCHARD AND I ASK THAT
YOU DO NOT APPROVE THIS AUDIT
WITHOUT ADDRESSING REPORTS OF
IMPROPER GOVERNMENT ACTIVITIES
WITHIN CSA THE KINDS OF
BEHAVIORS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON DESCRIBE CHARACTERIZED
CSA'S WORKPLACE CULTURE. IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY MANY
EMPLOYEES EMAIL G. LACK
DETAILING ACCOUNTS OF
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION
ABUSE AND HARASSMENT ALL
PRACTICES WHICH CULMINATE IN A
FEAR BASED CULTURE AND HIGH
TURNOVER. FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY. 49% OF
EMPLOYEES SEPARATED FROM CSA
SIMULTANEOUSLY ITS BUDGET
INCREASE 41% WELL THE NUMBER OF
REPORTS HAVE DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY. HOW ARE THESE
TRENDS RELATED THAT'S WHAT I
AND AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR FORMER
AND CURRENT AUDITOR IS THE
INTERNET AND YOU TO FIND OUT
EXCUSE ME MA'AM IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO WERE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
ON THE JOB ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH
FOUR. LEAVE A COMMENT YOU'RE
SPEAKING TO DO NOT ADDRESS THIS
AUDIT. IF YOU CAN LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO THIS AUDIT WE'D
APPRECIATE IT. YES THE STATE
AUDITOR CANNOT EFFECTIVELY
COMPLETE THE AUDIT BECAUSE IT
ITSELF DOES NOT HAVE A DIVERSE
EQUITABLE OR INCLUSIVE
WORKPLACE. AS A FORMER MEMBER
BUT SHE DID PLANNING TEAM I CAN
TELL YOU THAT BLACK BROWN AND
DISABLED EMPLOYEES SEPARATE AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER
RATES. THEY CANNOT EFFECTIVELY
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF RETALIATION
OR ABUSE WHEN YOU TALK TO THEIR
GOING ON WITHIN ITS OWN AGENCY.
THAT IS WHY WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
NOT APPROVE THE THOUGHT IT. AND
TO. PUBLICLY ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS AND COMMIT TO TAKING
ACTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE IS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO ITEM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE OH FOUR. BUT I DO
HEAR YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE. I DO
WANNA LET THE PUBLIC KNOW AT
ANY TIME IF. SOMEBODY HAS A
COMPLAINT ABOUT THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE THAT THEY-
THAT WE DO HAVE A PROCESS FOR
THAT AND THAT'S- CONTACTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
EMPLOYMENT AND ADMINISTRATIVE-
MANDATE SECTION THEIR PHONE
NUMBER I WILL GIVE IT TO YOU IS
SIX ONE NINE. SEVEN THREE EIGHT
NINE FIVE TWO FIVE AGAIN THAT
NINE FIVE TWO FIVE- WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH FOR- DO
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL. PUBLIC
COMMENT AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION
IN THE CHAMBER HEARING AND
SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. ON THIS FILE ITEM
FROM OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS. OKAY HEARING AND
SEEING NINE WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND I'LL CHECK WITH OUR
OPERATOR TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONES. WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE OH FOR- OPERATOR. CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. THE PHONES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU. IF YOUIF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THE FACT WANTED
THEIR- AT THIS TIME WE WILL GO
TO MY NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FIVE
THE THOUGHT HAD. PLEASE PROCEED
PLEASE BEGIN WITH STATING YOUR
NAME. NECTAR THE LINE NUMBER
THREE ZERO FIVE IF I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S JEFF CABLE
AND I WORKED AT METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS WITH THE FIRST TEN AS AN
INVESTIGATOR IN THE ETHICS
OFFICE OF EXPERIENCED OR
WITNESSED RETALIATION
DISCRIMINATION SAFETY
VIOLATIONS HARASSMENT AND
BULLYING ON THE JOB AT
METROPOLITAN BUT STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THE END OF
THE STATE AUDIT REQUEST. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE NUMBER UP TO NINE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CHRISTOPHER RICHARDS I'M AN
ELEVEN YEAR EMPLOYEE OF M. W.
D. AND I'VE EXPERIENCED
BULLYING RETALIATION. AND
WORKPLACE INJURY FOR FILING
ANY- COMPLAINT OF RACIAL
HARASSMENT WHICH WAS DIRECTED
AGAINST A LIVE NEXT CO WORKER
IN THE WORKPLACE ADAM W. D. I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THE M. W. D. STATE AUDIT
REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER THREE ZERO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KEVIN MELVIN I AM- THE
FIFTEEN YEAR EMPLOYEE OF M. W.
D. I HAVE EXPERIENCED BULLYING
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION. AT METROPOLITAN
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THE END OF THE STATE
AUDIT REQUEST. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT TESTIMONY PLEASE.
THANK YOU CAN SOMEONE TO- SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS NICOLE THEN HERE ARE
REPRESENTING LA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR JANICE HAHN'S OFFICE
AND WE WANT TO STATE THAT
SUPERVISOR HAHN IS IN SUPPORT
OF THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT- STATE AUDIT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. IS FINE THREE ZERO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. COOL
QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALL IN
SUPPORT OF OTHER REQUESTS WHEN
TWENTY ONE DASH FOUR OH FOUR
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU.
SURE LINE TO OUR. THREE TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
KIND CROWD TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THESE WORKERS
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
ARTICLE CLASS. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BY NUMBER THREE UP
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TINA
MONTFORT ON A RETIRE READ
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT AND
WHILE ON THE JOB AT M. W. D. I
WITNESSED AND EXPERIENCED
CRONYISM BULLYING
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION AND
OFTENTIMES TOXIC WORK
ENVIRONMENTS. I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THE M. W. D.
STATE AUDIT REQUEST THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER.
THREE TWENTY FOUR. HELLO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MY NAME
IS DANIEL RODRIGUEZ I AM A TWO
YEAR EMPLOYEE OF METROPOLITAN
AND A COMBAT VETERAN HAVE
EXPERIENCED BULLYING HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND RECENTLY
RETALIATION TO COPE WITH
CONCERNS AT METROPOLITAN I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THE AT THE END OF THE STATE
AUDIT. JUST BECAUSE I FEEL THAT
NO ONE ELSE SHOULD GO THROUGH
WHAT I'VE GONE THROUGH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT WITH THIS
PLEASE. I NUMBER THREE ZERO
SEVEN IF I HAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS GONZALO PONTO HA I'VE WORKED
FOR METROPOLITAN FOR OVER
THIRTEEN YEARS NOW AND DURING
THAT TIME I PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCE AND ALSO BEEN A
PARTY TO BULLYING HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION ABUSE OF
WORKPLACE AND ALSO RETALIATION
FOR UNION INVOLVEMENT WHILE ON
THE JOB AT METROPOLITAN. I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THE NWT ST AUGUST REGRET
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WHY NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE- THIS IS
DREXEL HEARD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY I REQUEST THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE AN AUDIT
OF THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT. OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY PROVIDES
STATE OVERSIGHT OF WORKPLACE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
PREVENTION OF WORKPLACE ALL
PERSONNEL POLICIES AND
PRACTICES OF DISCRIMINATION
INCLUDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
BULLYING AND RETALIATION WE
BELIEVE THE STATE AUDIT OF ANY
ONGOING CULTURE OF ABUSE WILL
NOT BE TOLERATED THAT'S WHAT
STATE YOU'RE CALLING FOR AN
OUTSIDE INDEPENDENT AUDIT BY
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. TO
INVESTIGATE ANY WRONGDOING
WITHIN OR BY THE AGENCY TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
FURTHER ACTION IF NECESSARY AND
I ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU- NEXT
WITH THIS PLEASE. EIGHT THREE
ZERO SIX IF I HAD. YEAH HI- IF
MICHAEL GIVE- THEN- PLAYER
METROPOLITAN FOR OVER FOURTEEN
YEARS I WENT THERE PRINCIPAUX
GRAHAM AS WELL- CANNOT I HAVE
EXPERIENCED BULLYING HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND RETALIATION
COOPER BEING INVOLVED WITH THE
UNION AND ON TOP OF THAT BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST FOR
TAKING HOPE IT DO YOU- I
CONTRACT RIGHT BUT I HAVE NOT
CONTACTED A LITTLE BIT. AND HOW
ARE YOU STRONG WITH VOTE YET
FROM THE PRODUCT I THINK YOU TO
CHANGE YOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU- NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
EVERYONE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
MIGHT HAVE A FUN MUTE. OKAY
EXLINE WILL BE TWO SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SELVI BALANCE ON THE
RETIRED AND THE MEDIA FORTY AND
THE FORMER NWT NWT DIRECTOR WHO
ALONG WITH THREE OTHER
DIRECTORS PROPOSED AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION. OF
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT ISSUE AT
THE END OF THE DAY BEING
CONDUCTED BY THE SCHALL LAW
GROUP. SOME OF THE WOMAN WHO
BROUGHT THE CHARGES THE WHITE
HAVE HAD TO TAKE LEAVE FROM
THEIR PROVISIONS AND AT LEAST
ONE ONE OR IF THE SUBJECT OF A
DEFECTIVE METALLIC TORY
MANAGEMENT INVESTIGATION THAT
IS NOW SUBJECT TO REVIEW BY THE
CHARLOTTESVILLE MA'AM ARE YOU
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE-
AUDITORY YOU POSE. YEAH WELL I
SUPPORTER PLEASE VOTE YES THANK
YOU PRECIADO- NEXT. WITH THIS
PLEASE. THANK YOU. THIRTY FOUR.
TWO THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF TWO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ON THAT BUT HE SAID YOU KNOW
AND I AM CO PRESIDENT OF UNITE
HERE LOCAL ELEVEN AS WELL AS
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND
BOTH OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES- WE WANT
TO STAND WITH THE COURAGEOUS-
WORKERS WHO ARE HELPING US. FIX
OUR SOCIETAL ILLS PLEASE BE
SUPPORTIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WILL BE
LINE IT TOO IT SEVENTY THREE
YEAR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO PLEASE PROCEED. HI THIS
IS A LISA THE MIND WITH YOUR
SENATE LEADER FEDERATION-
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SUPPORT
OF THIS ITEM AND THE AUDIT WE
COMPLETELY STAND WITH OUR
PROCEDURES IF FACING CORPORATE
SITUATIONS AND WE ENCOURAGE-
AND- AND STICK. SPORTS SIDE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WITH
THIS PLEASE AND- THE LAST LINE
THAT WE HAVE IN QUEUE IS TWO
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER TWO THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE PROCEED.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES ARE YOU
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF. THIS MEASURE AND
REPORT. HI MY NAME IS SHERRY
BARNES I'M A CURRENT EMPLOYEE
AT METROPOLITAN WATER I'VE BEEN
AN EMPLOYEE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS I
AM SUPPORT OF THIS M. WG THANK
AUDIT OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS I'VE WITNESSED AND
EXPERIENCED BULLYING GENDER
BIAS DISCRIMINATION TOXIC WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND RETALIATION WE
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE STAND WITH
US TO HELP INITIATE CHANGE AT
THE CULTUREAT THE END OF THE
DAY THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
BELIEVE- MADAM OPERATOR YOU
SAID THAT WAS THE LAST. HELLO
WE DO HAVE ONE THAT JUST QUEUED
UP AND THAT'S ONE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE. OKAY PLEASE PROCEED.
CHANGE YOU'RE GONNA REMIND
TYPICALLY GO. HONORABLE FOR THE
PHONE COMPANY WATERSHED
ALLIANCE- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE AUTOMATIC OF WATER DISTRICT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY AND FOR OUR NEXT
REGULAR CALENDAR ITEMS I DO
WANNA LET THE WITNESSES KNOW
THAT YOU CAN EITHER CALL IN OR
YOU CAN ALSO EVEN CALL THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON ANY
OF THESE MEASURES AS WELL. THE
COMMITTEE PHONE NUMBERS. NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE
THREE ZERO ZERO- WITH THAT WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND- BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO MEMBERS IN THE
CHAMBER WHEN WE ASK IF THERE
ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE CHAMBER
THAT HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR LEYVA PLEASE PROCEED.
THE MYSTERY CARE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANNA THINK
ALSO THE AUTHOR ON FOR REQUEST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIVES AN FOR.
ASKING FOR THIS AUDIT WHEN I
FIRST HEARD OF THESE REPORTS
HAPPENING IN FEBRUARY- I KNEW
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO DO AN
AUDIT AS SOMEONE WHO. HAS
WORKED ON HARASSMENT ASSAULT
AND DISCRIMINATION. ISSUE SINCE
I WAS FIRST ELECTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE FIRST
THING WE MUST DO IS MAKE SURE
OUR WORKPLACES ARE SAFE. THE
SECOND THING WE SHOULD DO IS
MAKE SURE IF IT HAD OF
DISCRIMINATION URSULE HAS
HAPPENED THAT IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN. SO I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE
ISSUE TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
LET ME ASK THERE'S ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
CHAMBER- SENATOR LLOYD PLEASE
THANK YOU IT AND I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH US AND HER LATEST
COMMENTS. I JUST HAD. ONE
QUESTION AND WE HAD TALKED
ABOUT IT. THERE IS AN ORDER.
AND BY AN INDEPENDENT THIRD
PARTY. THAT HAS BEEN HIRED BY
THE DISTRICT. HOW DO. YOU THINK
THAT RELATES TO THIS AUDIT.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO COME IN AND
FOR SIX WEEKS. I THINK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR FOR YOUR
QUESTION- AS I INDICATED BEFORE
WITH YOU I THINK THAT- ONE THE
STATE AUDITOR HAS A MUCH
BROADER PERSPECTIVE AND WE HAVE
AND CERTAINLY BELIEVE- AND HER
ABILITY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
SOME OF THE ALLEGATIONS- AND
THE AUDIT THAT I UNDERSTAND
TOOK PLACE WAS VERY NARROW IT
WAS VERY NARROW. IN SCOPE AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S TO THE REAL
ROOT OF SOME OF THE ALLEGATIONS
IS BEING MADE IF YOU HEARD FROM
IF YOU HURT LIKE I HEARD OF
SOME OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS OF
TESTIFIED OF IT GOES A LITTLE
BIT DEEPER A LOT DEEPER. AND SO
IS MY BELIEF MY STRONG BELIEF
THAT THE STATE AUDITOR HER
CAPABILITIES OF BEEN DOING THIS
FOR THE STATE CAN GO IN AND
REALLY- ON COVER AND ALSO
PROVIDE INFORMATION THAT CAN BE
VERY HELPFUL FOR THIS AGENCY TO
WRITE A NEW NARRATIVE MOVING
FORWARD BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THE
PORGY'S WHO'S MAKING THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE FURTHER
EMPLOYEES- DON'T HAVE TO- HARD
MADE WHOLE. AND ALSO OUR- I
HAVE AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
CONDUCIVE TO WORK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
RESPONSE. THANK SAID LAYERED-
WILL BE ASKED THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS IN THE
CHAMBER. HERE AGAIN SAYING NONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS OUT
FORWARD I THINK THIS INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT AND
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES. YOU'VE IDENTIFIED A LOT
OF THE ISSUES- PREVENTING
FUTURE WORKPLACE DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT. I DID TO HAVE
THE SAME QUESTION A CENTRAL
AIRED ABOUT THE SCHALL LAW
GROUP OF MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE'S NOTHING BINDING. TO THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
THAT MAKES THE FINDINGS OF THAT
REPORT PUBLIC. OBVIOUSLY THE
AUDITORS FINDINGS WILL BE
PUBLIC AND SO APPRECIATE THAT
AND THAT HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM. FROM THE
CHAIR SO WITH THAT LET'S GO DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON. SO MOVED
BY SENATOR LEYVA TO HAVE A
SECOND BY. THIS BOERNER HORVATH
KIND OF SECTOR CALL. THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE AUDIT REQUEST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OF
FOUR METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS
I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I KILEY KILEY I
PATTERSON. RUBIO. VOEPEL. THANK
YOU VOEPEL I WOULD. THANK YOU
WOULD AYE SENATOR LAYERED I
THINK LAYERED I. BAKER. FORGES
GLAZIER THANK YOU GLAZIER I
HERTZBERG. LEYVA LEYVA AYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN THANK YOU BYE.
THE MOTION CARRIES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THAT I THINK YOU'RE
MISSING GIPSON THIS TIME I'M
GONNA MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE OH FIVE PEACE
OFFICERS HE GROUP AFFILIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN MISTER
NAZARIAN PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND- I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU. AS WELL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
ADDED TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AND FOR YOUR- CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTIONS AND GUIDANCE YOU
ALONG WITH YOUR STAFF I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- YOU JUST A QUICK
PREAMBLE BEFORE BEFORE I BEGIN
WE INITIALLY BEGAN WORKING ON
THIS REQUEST JUST SO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES KNOW. BACK IN SUMMER
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN- AT
THAT TIME GIVEN ALL THE
DIFFERENT SHOOTINGS AND CASES
WE WERE HEARING ABOUT I WANTED
TO KIND OF FIGURE OUT. WHAT
SOME OF THE DEEPER LINING
ISSUES ARE AND SO WE CONTACTED
THE- AUDITOR AND WE STARTED
WORKING WITH HER ON FIGURING
OUT WHAT THE LANGUAGE SHOULD
BE. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO BEST
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE BEST OUTCOMES ARE
GOING TO BE FROM A STUDY. FROM
AN AUDIT AND SO SUMMER OF
NINETEEN WE WORKED ON IT IT WAS
A LITTLE TOO LATE WE WERE ABLE
TO- GET IT. PREPARED ENOUGH TO
BE HEARD IN IN IN- THE AUGUST
HEARING SO WE INTRODUCED IT IN
TWENTY TWENTY. BECAUSE OF IT
AND THEN EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
HAPPENED HERE WE ARE TODAY SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS AUDIT IS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERVICES THAT ARE FREE FROM
BIAS AND PREJUDICE. WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE BIASED ACTIONS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FOR
YEARS THE TRAGIC KILLING TWELVE
GEORGE FLOYD. IN MINNEAPOLIS IN
TWENTY TWENTY DREW HOW MUCH
NEEDED ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE.
AND THAT UNFORTUNATE EVENT LED
TO THIS ESSENTIAL LONG OVERDUE
AUDIT. WITH OF GREATER EVEN
GREATER CONVICTION. OUR AUDIT
IS SPECIFICALLY REQUESTING
INFORMATION RELATED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND PRISON
GUARDS AFFILIATION. WITH
SUBVERSIVE VIOLENT AND OR HE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. EVEN
THOUGH. THERE IS NO CURRENT
DEFINITION FOR HATE GROUPS WE.
KNOW THAT THE TERM HATE AND
CRIME. BUT LAW- DOES NOT MEAN
RAGE ANGER OR GENERAL DISLIKE
IT MEANS BIAS AGAINST PEOPLE OR
GROUPS. WITH SPECIFIC
CHARACTERISTICS THAT ARE
DEFINED BY THE LAW. WE CAN
DEDUCE THAT HATE GROUPS ARE
THOSE THAT THREATEN TO PROMOTE
ANIMOSITY BIAS OR MALICE ON THE
BASIS OF THE VICTIMS PERCEIVED
OR ACTUAL RACE COLOR RELIGION
NATIONAL ORIGIN SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER GENDER
IDENTITY OR DISABILITY.
OFFICIALS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS OVER
TATTOOED GANGS OF DEPUTIES IN
THE LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WHICH DATES AS FAR
BACK AS THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
THERE'S BEEN SUBSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE THAT THE EAST VALLEY
SHERIFF'S STATION'S GANG
INVOLVEMENT HAS RESULTED IN
FAVORITISM SEXISM RACISM AND
EVEN VIOLENCE. I'VE BEEN
APPROACHED ABOUT CONCERNS
REGARDING FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS. USING THE LA SHERIFF'S
AS AN EXAMPLE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS HAVE SAID
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT
PREVENTS THEM FROM ORDERING
DEPUTIES TO EXPOSE THEIR
TATTOOS. HOWEVER ACCORDING TO
LAURIE LEVENSON A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR WHO TEACHES
CRIMINAL LAW AT LOYOLA LAW
SCHOOL THOSE CONCERNS WOULD NOT
APPLY IF THE TATTOOS ARE
EVIDENCE OF INVOLVEMENT IN A
GROUP THAT ENGAGES IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. I HAVE BEEN IN CLOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE AS STATED
BEFORE WHO HELPED US DRAFT IS
REQUEST AND ARE WE SURE THAT
OUR REQUEST GIVES THEM ENOUGH.
DISCRETION AND JUDGMENT TO
PROPERLY CONDUCT THIS AUDIT
WITHOUT THREATENING ANY
INDIVIDUALS FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS WITH THAT SAID I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE WILL BE ABLE TO CONDUCT
AN APPROPRIATE AUDIT THAT WILL
PRODUCE INFORMATION. THAT HAS
BEEN LONG OVERDUE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS AUDITS- ON THIS
REQUEST TODAY. AND WITH ME I
HAVE ARTIST AND MUSICIAN ALOE
BLACC REPRESENTING MUSIC
ARTISTS COALITION WHO WILL
PROVIDE WITNESS TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF OUR AUDIT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE I BELIEVE HE IS
ON THE PHONE LINES IF WE COULD
MOVE TO MISTER ALOE BLACC
PLEASE. AN AMERICAN MUSICIAN
WITH THE MUSIC ARTIST COALITION.
WE CAN MOVE TO THE PHONES
PLEASE MADAM OPERATOR. HELLO
YES THIS IS- MY NAME IS ARGHA
BLACK HELLO PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDALLION AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO A
MEMBER MUSIC ARTS COMMISSION IN
ADDITION TO OUR. ACT ON THE
CORN CONTRACT. MOST INFLUENTIAL
SHE RECOGNIZED THAT THE
MEDICAID THANK. ALSO USE YOUR
VOICE TO PROTECT RIGHT WE ALL
DESERVE THE RIGHT TO BE SIR BY
LAW FORTY ABOUT YOU CAN BIAS
STATE FARM FOR SYSTEM
INDIVIDUAL LONG OFFICERS
PREVENT MEMBERS REYES. FOR
RELATIONSHIPS PILOT AND OR HATE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR ANY
GROUP THAT MAINTAIN. DEVICE FOR
ANY REASON MORE TIRED HEARING
ABOUT THE- HOW ARE YOU CHILE
FEDERAL WEATHER THEY GAVE. THIS
WILL HAVE A ACCORDING TO
SWANSON OF LOOKS OF. MOTOR THE
CALL ARTIFICIALLY TWELVE BY.
POLICE GETTING CALLED THE
EXECUTION. DEPART AND WHAT PART
OF WHY VIDEO ABOUT THE CLEARLY
BY THE- RIGHT BOB KING OSCAR
GRANT CAN BROSTROM A TWENTY
TWENTY RECORD BY LOWER LAW
SCHOOL I THAT WOULD SEVENTEEN
GANGS L. A. COUNTY SHERIFF'S TO
HELLO. LIKE THAT SINCE THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOUND
ENGAGED IN ON CALL DISCO
AGAINST AKRON AMERICANS TO SET.
NOW THERE ARE PROBLEMS TO IT
WITHIN NOT FORCED FROM.
COMMITTEE ESTABLISHING FUTURE
PROCESS BY. WITH THE RESULTS
THE STATE OF ON HAYKAL WITHIN
ON FORCED WE CAN STEPS TO
READING THE. AND DEPARTMENTS OF
THE PROBLEM OF RACES CUTS IN BY.
WITHIN THE RANKS WHICH IS A
STEP TOWARD A BETTER
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. I
WANTED TO COMMITTEE AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
PRESENTATION- METAMODEL. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- AS
MISTER NAZARIAN OTHERS ARE
REQUESTING THE FIRST THING WE
WOULD DO IS- IDENTIFY THE STATE
AGENCIES AND IN PARTICULAR THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AS
WELL AS PARTNER JUSTICE. TO
DETERMINE WHAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION THEY COLLECT AND
MAINTAIN ABOUT HATE GROUPS AND
THE MEMBERSHIP IN THOSE HATE
GROUPS. OUT WE WOULD ALSO LOOK
AT THAT PROCESS IS THAT THOSE
AGENCIES PARTICULARLY- YES IN
THE O. J. USED TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH EITHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AT
THE STATE LEVEL. OR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PURPOSES-
IN ADDITION WE WOULD LOOK AT A
PEACE OFFICER. STANDARDS AND
TRAINING AND WHAT KIND OF
GUIDANCE THIS POST PROVIDE TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT THE NCC
ARE RELATED TO. SCREENING
INDIVIDUALS DURING THE
RECRUITING PROCESS THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CERTAINLY DURING
ONGOING EMPLOYMENT. IN ADDITION
MISTER NAZARIAN AND OTHERS ARE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING ARE THERE
ANY LEGAL IMPEDIMENTS. THAT
WOULD LIMIT OR PREVENT YOU SEE
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
USING THIS INFORMATION WHEN
MAKING EMPLOYMENT DECISIONS.
ARE SO THAT IS A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT WE WOULD DO AT THE
STATE LEVEL. THEN MISTER
NAZARIAN AND OTHERS ABOUT
SYSTEM SELECT. FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND DO A
VARIETY OF THINGS LOOKING AT
PROCESSES. EVALUATE THE PROCESS
FOR SCREENING APPLICANTS
COLLECTING INFORMATION MAKING
HIRING DECISIONS MONITORING
INDIVIDUALS AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
HIRED AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY
DEVELOP ASSOCIATIONS WITH HATE
GROUPS. AND THEN WHATEVER YOU
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES-
ENGAGING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE HIRING PEACE OFFICERS
ARE THAT REFLECT THE AGENCIES
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITY DO THEY
HAVE A DIVERSE WORK FORCE. IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE COMMUNITY
ACCESS. YOU KNOW THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEVEL. AND THEN IT
GOES SAY FOR INSTANCE THAT WE
THOSE FOR LOW AND FORCE AGENTS.
WHAT KIND OF PRICE. SUCH AS
TRAINING FOR PEACE OFFICER-
EMPLOYING THE TYPES OF TRAINING
EDUCATING OFFICERS ABOUT BIAS
AND PREJUDICE PREJUDICIAL
STATEMENTS QUIETEST. ACTIONS
AND WHAT DO THEY DO TO PROMOTE
A DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE
WORKFORCE AT THEIR RESPECTIVE
AGENCY. AND THEN THE LAST ISSUE
IS REALLY LOOKING AT. AGAIN THE
FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IN THE EXTENT WE
CAN POSSIBLY DO THIS TO
IDENTIFY FINANCED OR
PREJUDICIAL STATEMENTS POSTINGS
ACTIONS BY POLICE OFFICERS
EMPLOYEES OF THOSE AGENCIES.
PARTICULARLY LOOKING AT IF
THEY'RE OPEN COMPLAINTS. FILED
AGAINST THOSE SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUALS AND I LOOK AT
TRYING TO IDENTIFY PASSED THE
CURRENT MEMBERSHIP. IN
ASSOCIATIONS OF DISSIPATION AND
KNOWN HATE GROUP TO THE EXTENT
WE WILL DO THAT TO THE EXTENT
WE POSSIBLY CAN- BUT CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT A LOT OF THE
PROCESSES RELATED TO COLLECTING
INFORMATION. USING THAT
INFORMATION TO MAKE HIRING
DECISIONS AND CERTAINLY HAVING
AN ONGOING PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE AWARE OF THOSE
AGENCIES ARE AWARE. IF IN THE
EVENT INDIVIDUAL ASSOCIATES
THEMSELVES WITH A HATE GROUP
THAT THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IS AWARE OF THAT-
RELATIVELY. LARGE OUT OF THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED HOURS THE REASON
FOR THAT IS WE'VE GOT TO GO TO.
A COUPLE AT LEAST TWO OR THREE
STATE AGENCIES WE'VE GOT TO GO
TO THE FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES-
TRADITIONAL AUDIT TEAM THAT
WOULD TAKE US ABOUT EIGHT
MONTHS BUT THIS IS ONE THAT I
BELIEVE WE CAN. LEVERAGE OUR
RESOURCES AND ESSENTIALLY HAVE
A COUPLE OF WHAT IT USED TO
REDUCE THE CHRONOLOGICAL TIME
IT WOULD TAKE US TO CONDUCT THE
AUDIT SO FOR EXAMPLE. WE WOULD
HAVE THE TEAM GO OUT TOGETHER
TO PERHAPS ONE OR TWO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND THEN
FOR THE SUBSEQUENT TO SPLIT UP
AND GET THOSE TWO GONE DURING
THE SAME WEEK SO. WE WERE ABLE
TO REDUCE THE- THE
CHRONOLOGICAL TIME TO BE ABLE
TO GET THIS AUDIT. DONE AND GET
THE INFORMATION TIME REALLY
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WITHOUT MISTER CHAIR ALTERNATE
BACK HERE. THANK YOU OUT OF ALL
OF THE TIME WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND TO THE EFFECT
AGENCIES AND AS A Q. THEM UP-
LET ME ASK A PLEASE PER SE. IN
THEIR COMMENTS AS WE HAVE A
LONG AGENDA BEFORE US- WITH
THAT LET'S MOVE TO THE OPERATOR
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE- SEVERAL
FOLKS AFFECTED AGENCIES FROM
CDC ARE POSTED PART ONE OF
JUSTICE NO YES ON THE LINE WITH
US SO LET'S GO TO BEGIN WITH
THIS SARAH LARSON FROM CDC ARE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES PLEASE
PROCEED. GREAT THANK YOU AND
THEIR LIFE AND I'M THE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION I'LL KEEP IT
QUICK THANKS FOR GIVING ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO OUR OPERATION- ACT
AS A HUSBAND DISCUSS OUR
COUNTRY STOPPER HELD TO POSTING
PEOPLE STANDARDS. WE HAVE AN
EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS WHICH INCLUDES A REVIEW
OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND- ASSOCIATE
WITH DRUG TESTING PSYCHOLOGICAL
EVALUATIONS AMONG MANY OTHER
FACTORS AND A LOOK INTO WHETHER
THERE IS ANY GANG MEMBERSHIP OR
AFFILIATION OR MEMBERSHIP IN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ADVOCATE
VIOLENCE- BASED ON RACE
RELIGION POLITICAL AFFILIATION
ETHNIC ORIGIN NATIONAL
NATIONALITY. GENDER SEXUAL
PREFERENCE DISABILITY- OUR
SOCIAL MEDIA INVESTIGATIONS
ALSO REVIEW ANY SHARING HOSTING
PARTICIPATING ARE PROMOTING OF
ANY VIOLENCE. CANADA BUT WE
FIND TO BE UNSUITABLE- ARE
WITHHELD FROM CONSIDERATION BY
THE DEPARTMENT- IF THEY'RE
FOUND. TO HAVE UNACCEPTABLE
BEHAVIOR BY A- THAT RESPONSE
FOR SERIOUSLY AND SHOULD THIS
ARTICLE APPROVED WILL OF COURSE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION OR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED. I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU LET'S GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED WITH MR MANY
ALVAREZ WITH THE WITH POST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS MANNY ALVAREZ ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF POST-
KIND OF GET A FOCUS MY REMARKS
TO THE BY DISCRETE THE CURRENT
BY SCREENING PROCESSES. PEACE
OFFICER CANDIDATES THAT FALL
UNDER THE POST PROGRAM FIRST BY
THE DRAFT IN THE PEACE OFFICER
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION
COMMISSION REGULATION REQUIRES
THAT IN ADDITION TO GOOD MORAL
CHARACTER THE BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS VERIFIED THAT
THE CANDIDATE IS. ABSENT OF
PAST BEHAVIOR INDICATIVE OF
UNSUITABILITY. TO PERFORM THE
DUTIES OF A PEACE OFFICER. TO
ASSIST WITH ADDRESSING THESE
BEHAVIORS A SEPARATE SET OF
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION
DIMENSIONS MUST BE ASSESSED
DURING THE BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATION. TEN DIMENSIONS
INCLUDE INTEGRITY. IMPULSE
CONTROL ATTENTION TO SAFETY
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ANOTHER RISK
TAKING BEHAVIOR STRUCTURE
TOLERANCE CONFRONTING AND
OVERCOMING PROBLEMS OBSTACLES
AND ADVERSITY. CONSCIENTIOUS
NESS INTERPERSONAL SKILLS
DECISION MAKING JUDGMENT
LEARNING ABILITY AND
COMMUNICATION SKILLS THESE
DIMENSIONS FOCUS ON PAST
BEHAVIORS INCLUDE DESCRIPTIONS
POSITIVE CHARACTERISTICS AND
INDICATORS. IN OTHER WORDS
NEGATIVE PAST BEHAVIORS THAT
MAY INHIBIT DETOX REPLACEMENT.
SMALL EXAMPLE OF INDICATORS
THAT ADDRESS BIAS INCLUDE LACK
OF TACT IMPARTIALITY IN
TREATING ALL MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
MAKING HASTY BIASED JUDGMENTS
BASED ON PHYSICAL APPEARANCE
RACE GENDER OR OTHER GROUP
MEMBERSHIP CHARACTERISTICS. AND
AN INABILITY TO RECOGNIZE HOW
ONE'S OWN EMOTIONAL BEHAVIOR
AFFECT SITUATION AND OTHERS.
AND HAVING BEEN DISCIPLINED BY
EMPLOYER FOR ACTS CONSTITUTING
RACIAL ETHNIC OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION.
SECONDLY BIASES ADDRESS THREE
COMPREHENSIVE PSYCHOLOGICAL
EXAMINATION WHICH ALSO INCLUDES
A SIMILAR SET OF PSYCHOLOGICAL
SCREENING DIMENSIONS TO BE USED
BY OTHER PRACTITIONERS THE WAY
WE GRAPPLE THE DIMENSION FOR
SOCIAL COMPETENCE INCLUDE
SCREENING FOR WHETHER THE
PERSON CAN PERFORM DUTIES WITH
TACT IMPARTIALITY IN TREATING
ALL MEMBERS OF SOCIETY. THE
PRACTITIONER MUST ALSO IDENTIFY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. BEHAVIORS
INCLUDING FOR INSTANCE. MAKING
INAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS TO OR
ABOUT OTHERS REGARDING PERSONAL
CHARACTERISTICS AS WELL AS
DEROGATORY COMMENTS ABOUT.
SPECIFIC GROUPS MAKING HASTY
BIASED JUDGMENTS BASED ON
PHYSICAL APPEARANCE WASTE
GENDER OR OTHER GROUP
MEMBERSHIP CHARACTERISTICS.
BLACKLEY POSTED IN THE PROCESS
OF IMPLEMENTING AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX WHICH MODIFIES THE
GOVERNMENT CODE. TO INCLUDE THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION OF
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL CONDITION.
INCLUDES THAT PEACE OFFICERS BE
FOUND QUOTE FREE FROM ANY
PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL OR MENTAL
CONDITION INCLUDING BIAS
AGAINST RACE OR ETHNICITY
GENDER NATIONALITY RELIGION
DISABILITY OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION THAT MIGHT
ADVERSELY AFFECT THE EXERCISE.
OF THE POWERS OF A PEACE
OFFICER CLOSE QUOTE. WE ARE
CONTRACTED WITH HIGHLY REGARDED
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TO HELP WITH THIS
PROJECT THE PROGRESS ON THIS
IMPORTANT PROJECT INCLUDING THE
BIOS FOR THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS WITH DISTRIBUTED IN THE
POST BULLETIN ON MAY TWENTY
SEVENTH. THE BOSTON BULLETIN
NUMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
TWENTY TWO CAN BE FOUND ON THE
POST WEBSITE I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION DURING YOUR HEARING
AND I'M HAPPY TO ASSIST WITH
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S GO
TO PROCEED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE I BELIEVE WE HAVE
EITHER. MRS DOMINGUEZ ARE
MISTER NEWMAN. YEAH AFTERNOON
SHARE SALAS VICE CHAIR LAYERED
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY. MY
NAME IS CRISTIAN OF THE MAN
GETS ON THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS WITH ME
TODAY IS MICHAEL NEWMAN SENIOR
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
HEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S CIVIL RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT SECTION. AND I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO MICHAEL NOW FOR
SOME COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THANK
YOU PLEASE PROCEED IF YOU CAN
BE CONCISE WE'D APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. PLEASE PROCEED. IF
YOU'RE ONLINE YOU'RE FLYING IT
OPEN. I DO NOT BE A MICHAEL AS
CONNECTED THANK YOU HAS DROPPED
OFF. OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED TO. THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SORRY ALSO APPEARED.
GO TO PROCEED TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES I BELIEVE WE
HAVE MISTER OSBORNE- MISTER
SALVADOR. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
TOM OSBORNE CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY GREAT
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK TO YOU TODAY. MY NAME
IS TOM OSBORNE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF HOMELAND SECURITY
WITHIN THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES- OTHER START OFF BY
SAYING THAT UNDER THE HOME
MINISTRY DIVISION THERE IS A
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT CENTER
OR FOR TWO AS THE STACK. AND
THE STAFF DOES NOT TRACK ANY
INDIVIDUALS NOR THEIR
AFFILIATION WITH ANY HATE OR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXTREMIST
GROUP WILL DUTIES AS MERE
AFFILIATION- OTHER HATE GROUPS
OR WITH VERY SPECIES IS NOT A
CRIME UNTIL. AN ACT OF VIOLENCE
HAS OCCURRED. SO WE'RE VERY
MINDFUL OF PROTECTING FREEDOM
OF SPEECH AND OTHER CIVIL
LIBERTIES- UP SO S. R. TO DO
NOT TRACK INDIVIDUALS NOR THEIR
AFFILIATIONS- ARE LOW OUR GOAL.
IS LARGELY TO TRACK HATE CRIMES
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN COMMITTED
AND PRODUCE INTELLIGENCE
PRODUCTS TO OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS- SO I
WILL PAUSE THERE AND BE WILLING
AND ABLE TO ANSWER ANY FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. WE.
ASKED MR SALVADOR'S ON THE LINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR AND-
VICE CHAIR WHERE DO REDUCE-
JUST THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY-
TOM'S COMMENTS THE WITHOUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
OKAY AT THIS TIME WITH BACK 
SEE IF MISTER NEWMAN IS BACK ON
THE LINE. OKAY WE WILL GO IN
FOR SEASONAL USE MRS-
DOMINGUEZ'S COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- WITH
THAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND- MAKE
YOUR- IT. INNING IF I CAN
CONTINUE WITH THE COMMENT THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH MICHAEL
KLEIN I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'VE
PUT IN THE- PUBLIC COMMENT.
MAYBE ACCIDENTALLY HE CALLED ON
THE CORRECT LINE BUT I CAN MAKE
A COUPLE STATEMENTS ABOUT- OKAY
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THE
WHILE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IS NOT CURRENTLY TASKED WITH
PROVIDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES OF GUIDANCE THEIR
DATA. AND HE THOUGHT THAT THEIR
HATE GROUP AFFILIATIONS WE
SHARE A FAMILY MEMBER TO DARIAN
AND FELLOW SIGNATORIES CONCERNS
REGARDING HATE GROUP
INFILTRATION OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IS AT THE READY TO
COOPERATE WITH THE AUDITOR. TO
ENSURE THAT YOU HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO COMPLETE
THE AUDIT IF APPROVED AND WE
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY HAVE AND-
HOPEFULLY IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
WILL BE ABLE TO FIND MR NINE AS
WELL IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
PUBLICCOMMENTS- LET ME ASK IF
THERE IS ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF THIS
MEASURE IN THE CHAMBER. YES
MA'AM PLEASE PROCEED. HI JAMIE
PRITCHARD. I'M GONNA SAY THAT
WE CANNOT BEGIN TO UNPACK
SYSTEMIC RACISM IN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITHOUT
FIRST BOLDLY LOOKING INWARD
STARTING WITH THE STATE'S
LEADING ACCOUNTABILITY AGENCY
TRUTHFULLY WE ARE RECEIVING A
MERE FRACTION OF THE VALUE WE
CAN OTHERWISE RECEIVE ON AUDIT
SUCH AS THIS UNLESS THE AGENCY
PRIORITIZES A DIVERSE EQUITABLE
AND INCLUSIVE WORKPLACE. PLEASE
VISIT W. W. W. DOT IMPROVE THE
CSA DOT COM TO LEARN MORE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ALTERNATIVE WHISTLEBLOWER
HOTLINE YOUPREVIOUSLY ALLUDED
TO DOES NOT HAVE PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISMS BUILT
IN WHICH IS WHY. OVER TWENTY
YOU RECEIVED OF EMAILS FROM
CONCERNED CALIFORNIANS ACROSS
THE STATE ASK YOU TO TAKE
ACTION SO PLEASE DO NOT APPROVE
THIS AUDIT. OR ANY OTHER ON THE
AGENDA WITHOUT COMMITTING TO
TAKING ACTION THANK YOU THANK
YOU LET ME ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL COMMENT IN THE
CHAMBER. HEARING AND SEEING
NINE LET'S MOVE TO OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS DO WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO OUR
PHONE OPERATOR- MEMORY- CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. THAT LINE IN EITHER
FAVOR IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF THIS MEASURE. THIS AGAIN IS
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH FIVE-
MADAM OPERATIVE PLEASE PROCEED.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ONE OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
SEND THEIR- AT THIS TIME. AND
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
HERE SO TO BE JUST A MOMENT
WHEN THEY GET THERE MY NUMBER.
AND AS THEY QUEUE UP LET ME
REMIND FOLKS THAT YOU CAN ALSO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITH THE COMMITTEE.
AND THAT PHONE NUMBER IS. NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE
THREE ZERO ZERO AS WELL AS
ANOTHER OPTION. AB PLEASE
PROCEED. WE DO HAVE THE FIRST
ONE COMING FROM THE LINE OF THE
Q. SIXTY FIFTH AHEAD. THANK YOU
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT MUTE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW. PLEASE PROCEED YES
MY NAME IS DAVID MYERS SAN
DIEGO SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
COMMANDER RETIRED THIRTY FIVE
YEARS I WOULD ASK THAT THE
AUDITOR AND THE SENATOR ALSO
LOOK INTO THE BOARD THE
COMMUNITY. BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
CORRECTIONS WOULD SET THE
STANDARDS FOR CORRECTIONS
DEPUTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SIMILAR TO WHAT
POSTCARDS FOR PEACE OFFICERS
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
PRODUCT THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NEXT WITH THIS PLEASE IF YOU
COULD STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. IT'S
FROM LINE NUMBER THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAURIE
CALDERON YA I'M A RETIRED
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
REPRESENTED SAN DIEGO IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SIX YEARS
ALLEN. I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
FATHER TO GO FORWARD AND
INCLUDES- NOT JUST ASSOCIATIONS
WITH HATE GROUPS BUT THE FACT
THAT LOCAL HATE GROUPS SAN
DIEGO ACTUALLY USE THAT LOCAL
SHERIFF DROP IN SOCIAL MEDIA AS
THEIR OWN THEY'VE ALSO I HAVE
FILED COMPLAINTS WITH THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE ALONG WITH
OTHERS. OVER SHARE A SEPARATE
MISSILES ON HEARING TO RESPOND.
IF I MAY- RIGHT NOW WE'RE ON A
JOB SITE NUMBER FOUR AND I YOUR
CALL IN ON A CHEN DIED A NUMBER
SIC. WITH SANDY COUNTY LAW. WE
DO APPRECIATE HERE NOW FORMER
MEMBER ON THE LINE BUT I DO
WANT TO LET YOU DOES I BELIEVE
YOU'RE CALLING ABOUT A-
DIFFERENT- ITEM NUMBER. NO
ACTUALLY NO I WAS GOING TO ASK.
AUDIT PUN AFFILIATIONS WITH
HATE GROUPS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD BE EXPANDED. TO INCLUDE
FAILURE TO ACT AGAINST MEMBERS
WHETHER YOU'RE FILIATION IS
THERE OR NOT WE HAVE HAD AMPLE
TIME TO ENSURE DEPUTIES HAVE
ALLOWED PROUD BOYS SHOULD WITH
SALT AND PERHAPS PEOPLE WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCE. SO PLEASE GO
FORWARD WITH THE AUDIT AND
CONSIDER THAT AS WELL THANK YOU
FANTASTIC THANK YOU WE ALWAYS
APPRECIATE HEARING FROM FORMER
MEMBERS- OPERATOR PLEASE
PROCEED. WE HAVE A LINE AT TWO
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS USE THAT MILLER FROM
THE NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN
DOUBLE ACP THE NORTH COUNTY-
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION
ENACT THE PORT THIS AUDIT.
THANK YOU- NEXT WITH THIS
PLEASE. AND MISTER KERR WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY OF ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU PRECIADO
LET ME O AHEAD AND TURN THIS
ITEM BACK OVER TO MEMBERS OF
THE CHAMBER LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS. OR COMMENTS
FOR MEMBERS OF THE CHAMBER. ALL
RIGHT HEARING AND SEEING NINE.
WELL MR VOEPEL PLEASE PROCEED.
SO THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL ARE
NOT BILL BUT REQUEST. IS A VERY
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE BUT I MUST.
RISE IN OPPOSITION AND
RECOMMEND THAT WE NOT DO THIS
AUDIT AND I HAVE. FOUR AND A
HALF MAIN REASONS NUMBER ONE.
IS HATE GROUPS ARE NOT DEFINED
AND HATE GROUPS IN MY
EXPERIENCE IN MY OPINION ARE
VERY TRICKY LET ME START OUT
WITH BLACK LIVES MATTERS. I
BELIEVE THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
CORE GROUP. ARE GOOD CITIZENS
THAT ARE. DEFENDED AFRICAN
AMERICANS OKAY BUT- THEY HAVE
FRINGE GROUPS THAT HAVE ENGAGED
IN VIOLENCE AND ALL SORTS OF
THINGS AS PERCEIVED BY MAY.
SOME SOUL BLM BASICALLY GOOD
HAS BAD PEOPLE AFFILIATED NOW
LET ME GO ON THE OTHER SIDE. TO
PROMISE KEEPERS M. AS KEEPERS
STARTED OUT AS A CHRISTIAN
GROUP OF MAINLY MEN THAT WERE
KEEPING THEIR PROMISES TO THEIR
WIVES CHILDREN TO CHURCH EXCEPT
FOR NOW OF COURSE PROMISE
KEEPERS HAVE THEIR FRINGE GROUP.
SO HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY DEFINE A
HATE GROUP. THE REAL TRICKY
PART OF THIS REQUEST. ALSO IT
INCLUDES SPEECH AS WELL AS HATE
GROUP AFFILIATIONS. SO. THE WAY
I READ THIS. IF I SAID
SOMETHING THIRTY YEARS AGO ON A
TAX OR AN EMAIL OR WAS RECORDED
OR WHATEVER IT COULD BE HELD
AGAINST ME. EVEN IF I WAS
DRUNKARD'S STUPID. YOU NEVER
KNOW SOMETIMES PEOPLE GET
ONLINE DRUNKEN STUPID AND SAY
DUMB THINGS. CAN THAT BE HELD
AGAINST THEM. MAYBE MAYBE NOT.
HEY GROUP AFFILIATION- WHAT IF
YOU WERE AFFILIATED WITH A HATE
GROUP AND THEN LEFT THE HATE
GROUP WHO. SO THAT GOES ON YOUR
RECORD SEE. TODAY WITH OUR
TECHNOLOGY. ANYTHING YOU DO IS
RECORDED. EVERYTHING YOU SAY
ANY EMAIL AND A TEXT CAN BE
DREDGED UP I MEAN IF SOMEBODY
GETS A DIVORCE THE FIRST PLACE.
THE DIVORCE ATTORNEYS GO TO IS
FACEBOOK. WELL PEOPLE ARE DRUNK
AND STUPID ON FACEBOOK. M.
TATTOOS SO WHAT IF I'M IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND I GET A HATE TED TO.
AND THEN CHANGE MY MIND. NO
LONGER A HATER. DOES THAT COUNT
AGAINST YOU FOREVER DON'T KNOW.
IN WHAT BOTHERS ME HERE ALSO IS.
CAN ONLY POLITICALLY THAT TO.
POLICE OFFICERS APPLY FOR A JOB
OR CONTINUE TO SERVE. IF
THEY'RE NOT CONVICTED CORRECTLY
AND WHO DOES THE VETTING. NOW I
GREATLY TRUST OUR CALIFORNIA'S
STATE AUDITOR TRUST ME. SHE IS
THE BEST AND HER WHOLE GROUP
HER WHOLE CREW. I HAVE ABSOLUTE
FAITH IN SO I'M NOT WORRIED
ABOUT THAT PART OF IT BUT- WHAT
I AM WORRIED ABOUT IS THE
CRITERIA FOR THE AUDIT. AND
THEN THE LAST THING THAT I'LL
THROW IN. IS SIMPLY FORGIVENESS.
DOES AN AUDIT LIKE THIS FORGIVE
PAST BEHAVIOR AND HOW IS THAT
FIGURES OUT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN POLITICS.
THANK YOU MR VOEPEL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND LET ME FIRST BEGIN
BY THANKING MISTER NAZARIAN WHO
WORKED WITH US ON THE
DEFINITION OF HATE- WHICH WE'VE
NARROWED TO IT WERE A HATE
GROUP SAP WE USE THE F. B. I.'S
DEFINITION THE FEDERAL BUREAU
OF INVESTIGATION WHICH STATES I
HATE GROUPS PRIMARY PURPOSE IS
TO PROMOTE ANIMOSITY HOSTILITY
AND MALICE AGAINST PERSONS.
BELONGING TO A RACE RELIGION
DISABILITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OR ETHNICITY NATIONAL ORIGIN
WHICH DIFFERS FROM THAT OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE ORGANIZATION AND
WHAT THAT ARE GOING TO TURN
INTO MISTER NAZARIAN TO ADDRESS
ANY OF THE OTHER POINTS OF MR
VOEPEL BROTHER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR HAPPY TOO AND YOU
YOU TOOK THE WORDS OUT OF MY
MOUTH THAT WAS GONNA BE MY
FIRST RESPONSE OF FIRST OF ALL%
THE FEELINGS ARE MUTUAL MISTER
VOEPEL I VERY MUCH RESPECT AND
APPRECIATE YOU. I ALWAYS COUNT
ON YOUR ADVICE AS MY VICE CHAIR
IN AGING SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THESE POINTS AS WELL.
IN FACT I WAS GOING TO PUT IT
INTO THREE CATEGORIES THE FIRST
ONE MISTER CHARITY ANSWERED SO
I'M NOT GOING TO REPEAT THAT.
THE NEXT THREE QUESTIONS-
THINGS FROM PAST CAN BE USED
AGAINST YOU WHAT IF THE IN TWO
WHAT IF THE INDIVIDUAL LEFT THE
GROUP. THAT THEY HAD JOINT OKAY
AND THEN THREE TATTOOS WHAT IF
IT WAS DONE IN THE YOUTH I'M
PARAPHRASING BUT I THINK I
CAPTURE THE ESSENCE OF IT. I'LL
BE VERY CANDID WITH YOU- I AND
I GUESS THE SPEAKS TO THE ISSUE
OF FORGIVENESS. MY GOAL. ISN'T
AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE OF US
WHO. ARE WANTING TO LOOK INTO.
THE THIS BIT THE UNDERLYING
ISSUE NOT JUST THE SYMPTOMS BUT
THE UNDERLYING ISSUE OF WHAT'S
WRONG. ARE NOT GOING TO WORRY
ABOUT THESE ISOLATED INCIDENTS
MY GOAL IS. WHEN CERTAIN ISSUES
ARE NOT ADDRESSED. THEY START
FOSTERING A CULTURE OF THEIR
OWN. WHEN WE HAVE A CULTURE
WITHIN A DEPARTMENT THAT'S
DANGEROUS THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO
BE ROOTED OUT BECAUSE THAT'S A
CANCER. WE DON'T WANT THAT
CANCER TO BE MALIGNANT AND
SPREAD AND CONTINUED TO
DEVASTATE OTHER FUNCTIONS. I
CAN SHARE WITH YOU MY OWN
EXPERIENCE I'VE BEEN A VERY
LONG TIME RESIDENT OF LA CITY.
HAVE HARDLY GOTTEN PULLED OVER
IN THE CITY OF LA BUT WHEN I GO
TO A NEIGHBORING CITY. I KEPT I
KEPT ON GETTING PULLED OVER I
EVEN GOT PULLED OVER AS A
STAFFER WITH EMPTY PLATE. THERE
IS BIAS. AND I'VE EXPERIENCED
THAT MYSELF BY THE WAY THAT
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IS
NOT PART OF THIS AUDIT BECAUSE
I'M NOT A **** FOR TAT GUY I'M
NOT TRYING TO GO AFTER SOMEONE
FROM MY PAST THAT'S DONE
SOMETHING MY GOAL. IS TO ROOT
OUT. THE CANCER THAT TAKES HOLD
AND BECOMES A CULTURE ONCE AND
WE'VE HAD THAT HAPPEN SO OFTEN
AND IT'S GONE ON UNCHECKED FOR
SO LONG THAT NOW WE'RE SEEING
MORE AND MORE INCIDENTS AND
THEN UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAPPENS
IS. INCIDENTS THAT RIGHTFULLY
TAKE PLACE CAUGHT ON CAMERA GET
BLURRED WITH INCIDENTS THAT
SHOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN PLACE AND
IT BECOMES. A VERY DIFFICULT
ISSUE TO DISTINGUISH AND YOU
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO LOOK
BACK AND SEE WHAT THE CONTEXT
OF IT WAS TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHY IT PRECIPITATED INTO WHAT
IT BECAME. SO THIS IS NOT ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL ISSUES THIS IS ABOUT
A CULTURE THAT TAKES HOLD OF A
DEPARTMENT AND IS FOSTERED AND
IT GOES GENERATION FROM
GENERATION AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
HAPPEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT A MAN OF YOUR
ABILITY YOUR NUMBER OF YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AND PUBLIC SECTOR
YOU PROBABLY HAVE SEEN THIS
YOURSELF SO. I DO HOPE THAT I'M
SAYING SOMETHING THAT ALSO
RAISES A CONCERN WITH YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION. I
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WE ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL COME SENATOR
LEYVA PLEASE. PICTURE I DON'T
HAVE A QUESTION I JUST WANNA
SAY THAT I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS AUDIT AND AS A
SOCIETY WE ARE SUPPOSED TO GET
BETTER AND TO MY COLLEAGUES.
POINT IF YOU DID GET A TATTOO
OF SOMETHING THAT WAS HATEFUL
OR IT WAS. A **** SWASTIKA AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU HAD A FIFTY
NEED TO REALIZE THAT YOU WERE
PART OF A HATE GROUP YOU CAN
HAVE THAT TATTOO REMOVED AND IF
YOU DO THINGS THAT ARE DUMB
WHEN YOU'RE DONE OR YOU'RE
DRUNK. I'M SORRY BUT THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES TO YOUR ACTIONS
UNTIL WE AS A SOCIETY TRY TO
ROOT OUT THESE ACTIONS AND
ROUTE THIS OUT FROM EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR LIVES WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET BETTER AS A
SOCIETY. SO I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- FOR TO VOTING HI.
THANK YOU WILL BE ASKING
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS HEARING AND SEEING
NONE- THIS IS AREA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS OUT OF
FORWARD THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE DEFINITIONS I
THINK. HAVING THE INFORMATION
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND START
HAVING SOME OF THESE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS. LOTS OF THE THINGS
MR VOEPEL SENATOR LEYVA JUST
TOUCHED ON. I WILL BE IN THE
FUTURE WE NEED TO HAVE. THE
INFORMATION AND BE INFORMED. ON
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN OUR
SYSTEMS APPRECIATE THAT AS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM- THE
CHAIR AND LET ME ASK MADAM
SECRETARY CALDERON. I'M SORRY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO- CLOSE AT I
CAN'T DO ANYTHING IN CLOSER I
WAS GONNA SAY THANK YOU AGAIN I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU.
WORKING WITH ME EARLY ON AND
WANTING TO PROVIDE TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE PARAMETERS FOR THIS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WE ASK
IF THERE IS A MOTION. FOR THE
SOLDER REQUEST. WILL BY CENTER
LEYVA SECOND BY SENATOR BACKER.
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE OF FIVE PEACE OFFICERS HATE
GROUP AFFILIATIONS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS I.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I KILEY. KILEY NONVOTING
PATTERSON. RUBIO. VOEPEL COOL
VOEPEL NO. ONE WOOD I CENTER
LAYERED-LAYERED I BAKER. BAKER
I FORGES. GLAZIER. HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I. DESIGNS AND- OKAY
THE SIDE OF HIS ON CALL WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK OU MISTER
NAZARIAN WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO. AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASH ONE OF SEVEN THE PARDON OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
OVERSIGHT OF REGIONAL CYBER.
REGIONAL CENTERS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE AND I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
HARD WORKING STAFF MISTER CHAIR
VICE CHAIR. THROUGH MY WORK IS
CHAIR OF THE- ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I'VE HEARD FROM CALIFORNIANS
AROUND THE STATE ABOUT VARIOUS
AREAS OF CONCERN. INVOLVING THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE LITTLE
SERVICE. AND REGIONAL CENTERS.
TO DATE I'VE HELD EIGHT SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARINGS ACROSS THE
STATE. SAN DIEGO COACHELLA
FRESNO. CONCORD EUREKA
SACRAMENTO RIVERSIDE AND READY.
ADDITIONALLY HAVE MADE AN
ONLINE SURVEY AVAILABLE ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WITH
THE PRIMARY GOAL. OF ASSESSING
CLIENT AND CAREGIVER PARENT.
EXPERIENCES WITH PROVIDERS AS
WELL AS REGIONAL CENTERS.
NEARLY SIX HUNDRED CONSUMERS
HAVE COMPLETED THEM SELECT
COMMITTEES ONLINE SURVEY
DESCRIBING THEIR INTERACTIONS
WITH THE DS IN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS. I FOUND THAT THERE OF
ARE THERE NOT OF NOT SERVICE
PROVIDERS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO HANDLE EXISTING
CASELOADS AND REPEATED PROBLEMS
A FULL TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN
SERVICE COORDINATORS. AND THE
CONSUMERS ON AVAILABLE SERVICES
EITHER PROVIDED JUST TO NAME A
FEW. I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
ONE INDIVIDUAL THAT I HAD.
OCCURRENCE WITH WHO CAME TO ME
SINGLE MOM WITH SEVERELY
AUTISTIC YOUNG BOY. WHO WAS
TOLD BY A SERVICE COORDINATOR
THAT THEY COULD NOT. HAVE
SERVICES PROVIDED BECAUSE SHE
WAS SHE MADE TOO MUCH MONEY.
SHE WAS DENIED SERVICES FOR
FIVE YEARS BECAUSE OF THAT
SERVICE COORDINATOR HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SYSTEM AND
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT. THEY WERE
DOING BASICALLY. BUT YET THAT
THE YOUNG BOY LOST FIVE YEARS
OF HIS LIFE OF HELP. THE MOTHER
COULD NOT TAKE A SHOWER IN THE
MORNING FOR FEAR THAT THE BOY
WOULD HAVE DAMAGE HIMSELF OR
THE- HOUSE. COULD NOT DRIVE TO
SCHOOL WITHOUT BEING PUMMELED
BY THAT YOUNG BOY. AT RISK OF
OTHER DRIVERS TO. BECAUSE THE
SERVICE COORDINATOR WAS A
TRAINED WELL. AND AGAIN I'M NOT
TRYING TO DISPOSE OF SERVICE
CORNER BUT THERE IS A DESPERATE
NEED. TO HAVE A LOOK AT HOW
WE'RE DELIVERING SERVICES TO
THIS COMMUNITY. THE REGIONAL
CENTERS WERE DEVELOPED AND
STARTED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
WE HAVE TWENTY ONE REGIONAL
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS HAVE ID D.
IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU JUST DO
THE MATH AND YOU DO A QUESTIONS
OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND.
INDIVIDUALS PER REGIONAL
CENTER. WE KNOW THERE'S A
DESPERATE NEED. FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE'VE SAID THAT. ALSO
IN DESPERATE NEED FOR EMPLOYEES
OF THOSE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE THE DIRECT SUPPORT. TO
THE CONSUMER. WHAT I'M ASKING
FOR AND YOU KNOW ALL THROUGH MY
ROLE IN THE LAST NINE AND A
HALF YEARS THAT AS BEING A
CHAIRED IN DIFFERENT COMMITTEES
I'VE HAD EXCEPTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR IN MY ROLE OF OVERSIGHT
TO BE ABLE TO FOR MY JOB. WHEN
I KNOW THAT WE CAN HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS IS NOT TO
DISPARAGE REGIONAL CENTERS OR
DDS. WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE HOW WE ARE PROVIDING TO
THE CONSUMER FROM THE CONSUMER
BACK TO THE REGIONAL SERVICE
HOW CAN WE DO A BETTER. WHAT
ARE WE MISSING. WHAT ARE WE
DOING RIGHT. BUT THAT'S NEVER
BEEN DONE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE AND I WOULD LOVE
FOR US ALL TO COMBINE OUR OUR-
OUR EFFORTS TO YOU KNOW WE JUST
AS IT DID HISTORICALLY. FUNDING
FOR THE IDT POPULATION THIS
BUDGET. HISTORIC BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT PLEASE OMIT THAT BROUGHT
US UP TO. WHERE WE SHOULD BE.
AS OF THREE YEARS AGO. THAT'S
WHEN THE RACE STUDY WAS
ACTUALLY COMPLETED. THIS ALSO
GIVE US A WHAT KIND OF VALUE WE
CAN GET FOR OUR MONEY. GOING
FORWARD. LOOKING AT THE QUALITY
OUTCOMES WHICH ARE IN THIS
BUDGET METRICS OF OUTCOMES AND
PERFORMANCE WHICH- GOD LOVE OUR
DIRECTOR AND EDS NANCY BARGING
HIS SHE IS ABSOLUTELY A GODSEND
FOR THIS COMMUNITY. BUT SHE'S
ONE PERSON. AND THERE'S THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE DO NEED TO
MAKE SURE AS OUR ROLE. AS THE
GUARDIANS FOR THIS POPULATION.
THEY'RE BEING SERVED CORRECTLY
AND APPROPRIATELY. AND I DO
HAVE TO EXPERT WITNESSES MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER WILL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO YOUR
WITNESSES I BELIEVE WE HAVE-
TRACY BUTLER THE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FOR THE STABILITY
AND DEBBIE DAVIS OWNER AND
DIRECTOR SPECIAL CARE SERVICES
MY BELIEVE THEY'RE ON THE PHONE
LINES WITH US. GOOD MOVE ADD TO
THE PHONE LINES. AB MADAM
OPERATOR. THEIR LINES ARE OPEN.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS DEBBIE DAVIS AND I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE IN A SMALL
PROVIDER OF SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHO
ARE ALSO MEDICALLY FRAGILE IN
THEIR HOME I'M ALSO THINKING OF
THE FAMILY MEMBER OF A REGIONAL
CENTER CONSUMER WITH COMPLEX
NEEDS I SUPPORT THIS AUDIT AND
I THINK IT IS CRUCIAL TO
IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE THERE'S
GAPS. AND BARRIERS IN THE
SYSTEM- AS WELL AS DISPARITIES
IN ACCESSING THE SYSTEM AND THE
THIRTY FIVE REGIONAL CENTER AND
GEOGRAPHY SHOULDBE REALLY
INCLUSIVE OF CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THAT IS PART OF
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT-
OBJECTIVE IS TO INCLUDE THEM ON
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL FEEDBACK
ON THE SERVICES AND SERVICE
GAPS. WHAT DID THEY NEED THAT
THEY DIDN'T GET- DUE TO YOUR
LACK OF AUTHORIZATION OR LACK
OF PROVIDERS. IN CERTAIN
SERVICE AREAS. AND I THINK A
LOT WITH THE THOUGHT OF THEIR
WE WILL IMPORT FACTOR TO
CONSIDER IN PLANNING-
ESPECIALLY WITH THE TIMING-
CODE NINETEEN S. HUGELY
AFFECTED THE ENTIRE CD SYSTEM
FOR THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF-
AND AT THIS POINT WE'RE STILL
FAR FROM NORMAL- JUST. DEALING
WITH ALL OF THE FALLOUT OF
THAT. SO I WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT- IF THE AUDIT IS DONE
FAIRLY SOON THAT IT INCLUDED-
THINGS WITH CODE NINETEEN WHAT
WENT WELL WHAT DIDN'T GO WELL
WHERE WERE THE CHALLENGES. WHAT
COULD WE DO BETTER IN A SIMILAR
SITUATION TO IMPROVE. OUR
MAILBOX LOTS OF EMPLOYEES HILL
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND YOU KNOW
STARTING TO RECOVER NOW BUT
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME- ALSO
NUMBER TO THE AUDIT WOULD
EVALUATE THE SYSTEM THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER DID
MENTION THAT. FINANCIAL REPORT
RATE STUDY WAS ALREADY ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION UNDER
FUNDED. BY THE RECENTLY
AUTHORIZED ONE POINT YOU WILL
THEN GET FIVE YEARS. WHAT GET
UP TO TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FUNDING LEVELS AND THE TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN A GOOD START BUT
WE NEED TO DO MORE IN THIS
AREA. AND THEN AFTER THAT IT
OUTLINES. THANK YOU. FOR YOU
FOR COULD MOVE THIS BUT PLACE.
HELLO MY NAME IS TRACY NOT AND
I AM BALK AND I HAVE A AND A
VENDOR- OF THE REGIONAL CENTER
AS WELL AS A FAMILY MEMBER- I
WANT TO- DEFINITELY SUPPORT
THAT AUDIT FOR THE SYSTEM. I
THINK THAT WE'VE BEEN LACKING
FOR MANY YEARS I'M LOOKING AT
WORK OUR PROBLEMS ARE INSTEAD
OF- DEALING WITH THEM BECAUSE
OVERLOOKED- I DO BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO START LOOKING AT
INDIVIDUAL AND FOLLOW THEM AND
NOT START WITH THE RESULT THAT
WAS THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUALS AND
FIND OUT WHERE THEY ARE LACKING
AND WHERE THEY ARE MAKING A
SERVICES- I. YOU KNOW I'M LIKE
IT'S A MUST MAN OF A- AND SHE
DELIVER ME AND I COULD SEE HER
CHAIR PROVIDERS. AND HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR TWENTY. I HAD A HARD
TIME NAVIGATING THE SYSTEM I
WAS SHOCKED TO FIND OUT ALL THE
THINGS THAT SHE WAS- THAT WERE
AVAILABLE TO HER WE'RE NOT EVER
OFFERED IN MEETINGS. SO I HAD
TO BRING THE START UP. AND THEN
WHICH WILL ENSURE YOU CAN HAVE.
THANK YOU. THERE IS SOMETHING
THERE I'M NOT SURE IT'S JUST
THE CASE MANAGEMENT HE'LL-
PARTIAL TO SOME. VENDORS VERSUS
OTHER VENDORS. SO I DO THINK
THAT PACKAGE TO BE LOOKED AT-
RESPONDING IS ALWAYS GOING TO
BE A PROBLEM FOR US. AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP US GET THAT ONE.
THANKS TO. BILLION DOLLARS THAT
LIKE- IT MEANS THAT IT'S JUST
START- I REALLY DO HOPE THAT
THE TO HELP- LOOK AT ISSUE.
WHAT'S REALLY ON WITH THAT OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
TODAY WITH A DENTIST- EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU THINK YOUR
TESTIMONY. AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION. ADAM
MONITOR PLEASE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER
INDICATED THIS WOULD BE AN
AUDIT OF BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
FELT NO SERVICES AND CERTAINLY
GOING TO RATE A SELECTION OF
REGIONAL CENTERS AND LOOKING AT
A VARIETY OF ISSUES ARE REALLY
AROUND THE PROCESS
ACCESSIBILITY TO SERVICES THE
QUALITY OF THOSE SERVICES THE
TIMELINESS OF THOSE SERVICES
BUT I'LL I'LL AT A HIGH LEVEL
BILL THROUGH THE KEY OBJECTIVES
AGAIN LOOKING AT TVS IN THEIR
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES.
WHAT CASELOAD RATIOS HAVE THEY
ESTABLISHED HOW DO THEY MAKE
SURE THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS
ARE ARE COMPLYING WITH THOSE
PARTICULAR RATIOS AND THEN WITH
RESPECT TO SERVICES WHETHER OR
NOT THE S. IS PROVIDING
TRAINING TO REGIONAL CENTERS TO
INCLUDE STEPS TO ASSESS QUALITY
OF SERVICES AND SIMMERS HI
MELINDA SAID THOSE SERVICES-
AND THEN THE EFFORTS DDS AND
THE REGIONAL CENTER TO MAKE THE
EDUCATE PARENTS AND LEGAL
GUARDIANS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE RECEIVING SERVICES THROUGH
THE REGIONAL CENTER WITH A VPN
SERVICE PROVIDERS VIA THE
REGIONAL CENTER. WHETHER OR NOT
DDS AND A SELECTION OF REGIONAL
CENTERS ACTUALLY MONITORS
VENDORS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
SERVICES ARE DEQUATE THAT
THEY'RE COST EFFECTIVE AND THAT
THEY NEED THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE CONSUMER THE NEEDS OF THE
CONSUMER IN ADDITION AT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS- MEMBERS
ASKING US TO SELECT SOME
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLANS OF
FORCING CONSUMERS TO ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT THE GOALS
ESTABLISHED IN THAT I. P. T.
WERE ACTUALLY MAX AS THEIR MAIN
FOLLOW UP- TO DETERMINE WHETHER
CONSUMERS ARE GETTING QUALITY
SERVICES IF CERTAIN SERVICES
ARE NOT AVAILABLE WITHIN THAT
REGION. WHAT EFFORTS DOES THE
REGIONAL CENTER TAKE TO TRY TO
SEEK THOSE SERVICES ELSEWHERE
TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES THAT
CONSUMER ON ASKING US TO LOOK
AT THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS WHAT
RESPONSIBILITIES DID BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AT THE VARIOUS
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE DO THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE THEY
DUPLICATED ABOUT OF DDS
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT WHAT THE BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS ARE DOING- TO THE
EXTENT CONSUMERS DO NOT HAVE
SERVICES. AVAILABLE EVALUATE
THE REASONS WHY FIVE AND AGAIN
LOOKING TO DETERMINE WHETHER
NOT REGIONAL CENTER ARE LOOKING
ELSEWHERE TO BE TO TRY TO GET.
SERVICES THOSE IN. I'M WHETHER
OR NOT- DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT CENTER HAVE DATA COLLECTION.
IN PURSUIT. FOR CUSTOMER
SERVICE METRICS LOOKING AT
THINGS LIKE HOW LONG DID IT
CONSUMER HAVE TO WAIT FOR
ACCESS TO A PARTICULAR SERVICE
ARE CONVENIENT WAS THAT
PARTICULAR SERVICE- WHAT'S THE
QUALITY OF THE SERVICE PROVIDES
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT METRICS.
pPROFESSIONAL QUALIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR STAFF AND
MANAGEMENT AT BOTH
DEVELOPMENTS- DON'T KNOW
SERVICES HERE AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO DIRECT
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED AND
REALLY LOOKING AT HERE THE
QUALIFICATIONS ARE WE ENSURING
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS WE- HIRE
AND EMPLOY. ME AND COMPLY WITH
THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND THEN THE
LAST COUPLE OF OUR OBJECTIVES
WERE RELATED TO IT DDS
DETERMINES THAT- A SERVICE
PROVIDER'S NEGLIGENCE OR IN
VIOLATION OF THE LAW. WHAT
MECHANISM DO THEY USE TO
COMMUNICATE. THAT INFORMATION
TO CONSUMERS. ACTUALLY TO OTHER
CENTRES ETCETERA SO IS THAT
INFORMATION GETTING OUT THERE
SO PEOPLE ARE AWARE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR SERVICE PROVIDER IS
IN VIOLATION OF THE LAW AND
SHOULD NOT BE ONE THAT. PERHAPS
THE STATE OR THE REGIONAL
CENTER SHOULD BE CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE WEST AND THEN THE LAST
OBJECTIVE IS REALLY LOOKING
AGAIN AT SOME METRICS SELECTION
OF REGIONAL CENTERS ASSESSED
CONSISTENCY. TIMELINESS OF
INTAKE. PROVISION OF SERVICES
IF AN INDIVIDUAL OR THEIR LEGAL
GUARDIAN OR PARENT REQUEST A
MODIFICATION OF THOSE SERVICES
IS THAT HAPPENING HOW TIMELY IS
THAT- NOTIFICATION TODAY YES OR
OTHER REGIONAL CENTRES I WAS
SPEAKING A MINUTE AGO. BUT
ACTIONS TAKEN AGAINST OFFENDERS
DID WE DID A REGIONAL CENTER OR
THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TAKEN ACTION AGAINST
OFFENDERS WELL THAT BE
COMMUNICATED. TO THE SERVICE
PROVIDER REGIONAL CENTER
COMMUNITY ESSENTIALLY- WHAT
INFORMATION DOES OUR OTHER DUE
TO REGIONAL CENTRES PROVIDE.
REGARDING HOW TO FILE A
COMPLAINT AGAIN THIS WOULD BE
THROUGH CONSUMERS THEMSELVES
BUT ALSO TO LEGAL GUARDIANS AND
PARENTS- HOW DO THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO FILE A COMPLAINT OR
DISPUTE SERVICES OR THE AMOUNT
OF SERVICES THAT. INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMERS RECEDING THE LAST TWO
ISSUES. DO THE BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS ARE THEY TRANSPARENT
ABOUT THEIR DISCUSSIONS ARE
THERE MEETING MINUTES POSTED
PUBLICLY WHAT KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS OR DISCUSSIONS
ARE THE BOARDS HAVING AND THEN
THE FINAL AREAS COMPLYING WITH
CERTAIN CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE. THERE
ARE LAID OUT CLEARLY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE- SO THEY
STARTED AGAIN IS RELATIVELY
LARGE BECAUSE IT THERE A LOT OF
OBJECTIVES THAT THEY WENT OVER
WE WENT DOWN TO A SELECTION OF
A REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL AS
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES- THIS ONE MAY BE
SIMILAR TO SOME OF THE OTHER
ARTISTS WHERE WE HAVE THE TEAM
GO OUT TOGETHER. BUT THEN SPLIT
THE TEAM UP SO THAT WE CAN
REDUCE THE CHRONOLOGICAL TIME.
IT WOULD TAKE US TO CONDUCT THE
AUDIT. WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'LL TURN IT BACK TO
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU WATER
WATER PRESHEAF THAT LET'S MOVE
TO THE AFFECTED. AGENCIES AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ON THE LINE IN
WITH US- THIS BRIAN WENT. AND
MR. RAMOS NAY. WHO ARE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOP SERVICES-
MADAM OPERATOR FOR COULD TURN
TO THE LINES PLEASE. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE PROCEED.
BRANDON GILL CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THIS. WE APPRECIATE THE
INTEREST IN OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AT
THIS IS A MAJOR FOCUS BOTH FOR
DDS AND FOR REGIONAL CENTERS.
IN FACT THE DEPARTMENT
REORGANIZATION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WAS AIMED AT.
ADDRESSING AREAS OF NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF ARCADIA STAFF
TO OUR COMMUNITY. THERE'S A
STATUTES REGULATIONS REGIONAL
CENTER CONTRACT THAT PROVIDES
FOR EXTENSIVE DDS OVERSIGHT OF
REGIONAL CENTERS IN MANY AREAS
INCLUDING REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS TO INCLUDE FAMILY
RETREATS OF CASE OF RATIOS
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENDITURES
PERSONALITY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
SALARIES. DANIEL REGIONAL
CENTER INDEPENDENT FINANCIAL
AUDIT AND BY ANY OLD PDF FISCAL
AUDIT. CAN BE THE PREVIEWS THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICE POLICIES
AND ASSESSMENT TOOLS. IN THE
AREA REGIONAL CENTER
PERFORMANCE ANGLE OUTCOME BASED
PERFORMANCE CONTRACTOR REQUIRED
BY REGIONAL CENTERS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE NATIONAL
COURT INDICATOR SURVEYS WHERE
WE- REVIEW THAT DATA TO ASSESS
HOW REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS AND REGIONAL
CENTERS USE. THAT DATA WITH THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL. HIS
PERFORMANCE ALSO LOOK AT THE OF
INTAKE AND THAT STUFF AND
IMPROVEMENT THE YOU NEEDED TO.
AS WELL AS THE ANGLE SERVICES
DATA TO SPIN SURE THEY WERE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WITH
REGARDS TO BOARD OF DIRECTORS-
OUR STAFF ATTEND ALL REGIONAL
CENTER BOARD MEETINGS- WE ALSO
REVIEW AND WILL POOR
COMPETITION. AND WE ALSO REVIEW
CONFLICTED INTEREST STATEMENTS
BY BOARD MEMBERS AND FOLLOW UP
WITH CLIPBOARDS ON ISSUES THAT
ARE. OBSERVED IN MEETINGS AND
OTHERWISE. WITH REGARDS TO HELP
YOU TAKE IN SERVICES OUR STAFF
REVIEWS SPECIAL INCIDENT
REPORTS THAT ARE SUBMITTED BY
REGIONAL CENTERS. ON A DAILY
BASIS AND FOLLOW UP AS NEEDED I
WOULD FOLLOW UP AND CONSUMERS
RIGHTS AND WHISTLEBLOWER
COMPLAINT AND REVIEW. FAIR
HEARING REQUESTED DATA. THIRD
FOR AUTO ISN'T TO A REGARDING
THE FOLK AND- ITSELF AND
BROUGHT AND NOT TARGETED WHICH
MAY MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR DDS
AND RETAIL CENTERS. TO BEST
ASSIST AND SUPPORT THE REQUEST
WITHOUT CLARITY. ADDITIONALLY
SOME ELEMENTS ARE NOT MANDATED
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT IN
ALIGNMENT WITH STATUTES
REGULATIONS OUR CONTRACT. FOR
EXAMPLE IT SPEAKS TO REGIONAL
CENTER BOARD COMPENSATE BOARD
MEMBER COMPENSATION WHERE AS
BOARD MEMBERS ARE UNPAID
VOLUNTEERS- THE STAKES OF BOARD
MEMBER CONTACT INFORMATION
WHILE ALL BOARDS HAVE A WAY TO
CONTACT THE BOARD. THROUGH AN
EMAIL ADDRESS OR OTHERWISE. WE
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO HAVE EMAIL ADDRESSES FOR
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS. CONTACT
INFORMATION. AT THE REQUEST
AFTER TVS TRACKS SERVICE
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
FOUND TO BE NEGLIGENT OR
VIOLATION OF LAW. THIS IS NOT A
DDS FUNCTION AND NO DEFINITION
IS GIVEN FOR NEGLIGENT AND
SINCE SERVICE PROVIDERS MUST
COMPLY WITH NUMEROUS LAWS
THERE'S NO FOCUSED. WHICH ON
WHICH. LAWS WOULD BE PERTINENT
TO THE AUDIT. SEVERAL OF THE
OTTER DIED WITH A T. TO BE ON.
IN THE IN PROGRAM PLAN PROCESS
WHERE DECISIONS ARE MADE
REGARDING THE TYPES AND AMOUNTS
OF SERVICES THAT INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVED. PRESS DDS DOES NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO BE
INVOLVED IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE SERVICES BETTER
UNAVAILABLE AND I REGIONAL
CENTER CATCHMENT AREA
DETERMINING WHETHER DDS TOOK
ACTION TO SEEK OUT THE SERVICE
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING TO THE
CONSUMER. I'M ENSURING THAT
BENDER SERVICES ARE ADEQUATE
AND COSTEFFECTIVE WHICH WOULD
BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR DDS TO DO BUT
THAT BEING PART OF THAT PLAN
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS NOT
CONSISTENT STATUTE. AND
DETERMINING WHETHER DDS TAKES
STEPS TO PROMOTE THE
AVAILABILITY OF SERVICES FROM
VENDORS. AGAIN NOT A GOLD EDS-
TAKES. PORTANTINO S. AS IN THE
PREVIOUS OF NOTED TO FIFTY.
THAT THE PARK TWENTY TWENTY TWO
BUDGET BILLS HIRED INITIAL OF
CHANGE AND REPRESENTS
TRANSFORMATION OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM.
EXAMPLES OF THIS REFORM INCLUDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RATE MODELS
TO INCREASE PROVIDER RATE.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR REGIONAL
CENTER OPERATIONS PRIORITIZE
HIS SERVICE COORDINATOR
POSITIONS AND ASSOCIATED
DEVELOPMENT OF PERSON CENTRED
OUTCOMES. EACH OF THESE
INITIATIVES ARE ANCHORED WITH A
NEW INCENTIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM.
ALL THE DANCE FROM A COMPLIANCE
BASED SYSTEM TO ADOPT BASED
SYSTEM. FIGURE PLEASE RAPIDLY.
ITEMS FOR DISCUSS. I SORRY IF
YOU COULD PLEASE RAPPER. WE
APPRECIATE THAT YES GET THE
AUDIT MOVES FORWARD THE SCOPE
WOULD BE WE RECOMMEND THAT THIS
GONNA BE REFINED WITH THE FOCUS
BEING COMPLIANCE WITH STATUTES
REGULATIONS AND CONTRACT AS
WELL AS MEANINGFUL OUTCOMES.
WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER IF THE DISCUSSION WOULD
BE HELPFUL THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT. WAS-
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY. NOT FOR
DDS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT- LET
ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE CHAMBERS.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE LET'S
MOVE TO OUR REMOTE. WE MOVED TO
A REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION DO
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT A
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE LET ME
TURN IT TO THE OPERATOR LET ME
SEE IF THERE'S ANY ONE IN Q. ON
THE PHONES AND F. ONCE YOU
PLACE YOURSELF ON Q. Q. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE OH SEVEN OVERSIGHT
OF REGIONAL CENTERS- WE'D
APPRECIATE KEEPING YOUR
COMMENTS TO. JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION MADAM
OPERATOR OPEN THE LINES PLEASE.
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ONE OH SEVEN THESE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE DO
HAS A COMMENT FROM LINE THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE PROCEED SB ONE MOMENT
HERE OKAY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE SEVENTEEN. MORE O'DONNELL
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY DEGREE PLAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
AND THE NEXT WITNESS HERE BE
JUST A SECOND TO GET NOW LINE
NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN THAT IS ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE
OH SEVEN. AND THE NEXT ONE IS
FROM NINE TO TWENTY NINE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ERICA SHORE
WHEN I'M COMMUNITY MEMBER OF
THE ALABAMA LEE AND A MOTHER
WITH A CHILD WITH DISABILITIES.
WAS WAITED FOR ALMOST OVER A
YEAR TO GET SERVICES TO
REGIONAL CENTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE APPROVED THAT THE
THOUGHT IT HAPPENED I HOPE
YOU'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
TWELVE DIGIT. THANK YOU DAX-
WITNESS PLEASE. AND MISTER
MODERATED BY MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M SORRY I'M WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE THANK YOU. THANK
ABOUT OPERATOR LET ME RETURN IT
THE ITEM BACK TO MEMBERS HERE
IN THE CHAMBER MAY ASK IF THERE
ARE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MUSCLE RELATED PLEASE. I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND I'M AT AND A LOT
OF US WORKED ON THE BUDGET THAT
HAS JUST BEEN ADOPTED AND THAT.
GENEROUS ONE POINT TWO BILLION.
DOLLARS MORRIS WAS REFERENCED
BY ONE OF THE WITNESSES. AND
ALSO. HELP FOR SELF
DETERMINATION PLANTS AND OTHER
THINGS AND- AND IF YOU READ THE
AUDIT THERE SOME THINGS THAT
MIGHT BE ASCRIBED TO NOT HAVING
ENOUGH MONEY. SO HOW DOES IT
MIX WITH HOW YOU PREPARE THE
AUDIT BEFORE WE DID THE BUDGET
AND NOW THAT THERE'S MONEY IN
THE BUDGET FOR A BUNCH OF THESE
THINGS HOW DO YOU THINK. THAT
WILL UNFOLD IF WE WERE TO ADOPT
THE AUDIT THE WAY IT'S
REQUESTED. SHE HAD A QUESTION-
WHICH- IN ALL HONESTY WHEN WE
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS OF
TRYING TO GET TO THIS POINT.
FOR THIS AUDIT WE NEVER THOUGHT
WE'D GET THE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AND YOU KNOW WE
DO THE HARD WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW KUDOS TO
ALL OF YOU FOR DOING SO AS IT
WAS MENTIONED BY ONE OF THE
WITNESSES THE IMPLEMENTATION
ISN'T COMPLETE UNTIL. TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN- YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE OVER A PERIOD OF TIME AND
AS YOU HEARD THE ONE WITNESS
WHO HAS. HASN'T GOT ANY
SERVICES FOR A YEAR AND STILL
WAITING. THERE'S HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN THAT
ROLE. WE NEED JUST A UNBIASED
SMOTHER SET OF EYES WHEN I WAS
A BUILDING CONTRACTOR I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE BUILDING
INSPECTOR TO COME IN BECAUSE I
WAS WALKING OVERSTAFFED HI MY
NOT SEEN ANY SAVE ME TO DO A
BETTER JOB. THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR ANOTHER
SET OF EYES. TO SAY. THAT WE
ARE DOING IT RIGHT. WE CAN USE
IMPROVEMENT OR WE'RE DOING
THINGS. YOU DON'T REALLY DO
NEED TO PROVIDE. BUT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE RECEIVING THE SERVICES
REALLY NEVER HAVE HAD A VOICE.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THE WHOLE
CRUX OF THIS IS. ONE OF I'M
OVER ME JUST ON MY OWN TIME
COMMON APPRECIATE THAT AND I
THINK THAT. THAT PART OF THE
PROBLEM I WAS BUDGET CHAIR IN
THIS CHAMBER FOR A MOD TWO
THOUSAND FORTY EIGHT. AND A LOT
OF THE- INSTITUTIONS WERE
CLOSED DOWN AT THE TIME 80% OF
THE MONEY. WANT 220% OF THE
RECIPIENTS IN THE INSTITUTIONS
AND- ARE 20% OF THE MONEY WENT
280% OF THE RECIPIENTS IN THE
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND YET. WHEN
THE HOSPITALS WERE CLOSED DOWN
THE SAVINGS FROM THE MONEY
DIDN'T SHIFT TO THE LOCAL
PROGRAMS. AND THE SO I THINK
PART OF THIS IS. IT IS THE
RESOURCES AND HOW THEY'VE BEEN
ALLOCATED BUT- I'M ON THE GO
WITH YOUR- SUGGESTION THAT ARE-
WE HAVE THE INDEPENDENT EYES WE
LOOK AT IT AND IF PART OF THE
RECOMMENDATION IS MONEY. THEN
IT WAS WE KNOW THAT THAT SAID
OF PART OF IT IS THAT THE
SERVICES COULD BE DELIVERED
BETTER WITH THE EXISTING MONEY
THEN WE WOULD GET AT THAT SO-
THIS THE- THAT. THERE MIGHT BE
SOME REDUNDANCIES IN HERE I
THINK IT'S WORTH GOING AHEAD
WITH WHAT PRESHEAF HAD ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I HAVE TO ADD
CENTER IS. THE I. D. D.
POPULATION GROWS BY 25% EVERY
DECADE THERE'S NO COLON THAT.
SO WE'LL LOOK INTO IN FIVE
YEARS WILL HAVE A TWELVE AND A
HALF PERCENT. INCREASE IN
POPULATION. BEING PAID THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY. RIGHT THANK
YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
CHAMBER. HEARING AND SAYING
NINE- WE ASK MISS FRAZIER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. INVESTORS
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
STAYING THERE WITH ME. YOU STAY
THERE BELIEVE IN ME. YOUR STAFF
WAS WONDERFUL WORKING. MISTER
LEONARD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSTRAINT CONSIDERATION THIS
IS SOMETHING ABOUT HUMANITY
ABOUT PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE A
VOICE AND ALL WE CARE ABOUT IS
THAT THEY'RE BEING TREATED
FAIRLY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER
AND I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH THE VICE CHAIR AS WELL ON
FOCUSING ON- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THE LATTER.
FREESHEET YOU DOING THAT IN
YOUR STRONG ADVOCATE AND ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE HAVE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS FOR- THE DISABLED
THE DDS COMMUNITY AND SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK
ON THAT AS WELL. AND THAT HAS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION FOR ME
OF THAT AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
WILL BY CENTER LEYVA SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH
THAT A SECURE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE OH SEVEN. DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
OVERSIGHT OF REGIONAL CENTERS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS
I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I HIGHLY.
PATTERSON. RUBIO VOEPEL. VOEPEL
I WOULD. WOOD I SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED I BAKER. BAKER I OR
JUST. BORJAS I GLAZER.
HERTZBERG LEYVA LEYVA AYE
NIELSEN NIELSEN I. THAT MOTION
CARRIES ALL THE ROLE OF IT FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AT THIS TIME I'D ALSO
LIKE TO REMIND MEMBERS THAT YOU
ARE REQUIRED TO WEAR A MASK IN
THE BUILDING AND ON THE
CHAMBERS- PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE A MASSIVE COVERS YOUR
MOUTH AND YOUR NOSE IF YOU ARE
IN THE CHAMBER OR IN THE
BUILDING SO THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED. TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN THIS IS TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE OH NINE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE I SEE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WEBER WITH US
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. ON BEHALF
OF THE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF
THE SAN DIEGO DELEGATION THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO PRESENT
OUR REQUEST TO AUTHORIZE AN
AUDIT OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. SAN DIEGO
COUNTY FACES A CRISIS IN OUR
JAIL SYSTEM. LOCAL ADVOCATES
AND MEDIA HAVE CALLED ATTENTION
TO THE DANGEROUS CONDITIONS AND
LARGENUMBER OF SUICIDES AND
OTHER DEATHS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY JAIL FACILITIES. THERE'S
AN EXTENSIVE PUBLIC RECORD
DOCUMENTING THE TRAGIC LOSS OF
LIVES SYSTEMIC FAILURES AND
INADEQUACIES OF OVERSIGHT.
FAMILIES OF THOSE WHO HAVE DIED
HAVE FILED NUMEROUS LAWSUITS
ALLEGING THAT THE COUNTY AND
JAIL STAFF ACTED WITH
DELIBERATE INDIFFERENCE TO AN
INMATE'S SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
MEDICAL AND RELATED NEEDS.
ACCORDING TO A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN REPORT FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. FROM. TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE SEVENTEEN
INMATE SUICIDE DEATHS IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY FAR OUTPACED OTHER
LARGE CALIFORNIA COUNTY JAIL
SYSTEMS. FOR EXAMPLE. THE
ORANGE COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM HAD
ONE SUICIDE AND THE RIVERSIDE
AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY JAIL
SYSTEM EACH HAD THREE SUICIDES
DURING THE SAME THREE YEAR
PERIOD. EVEN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM WHICH HAS AN
INMATE POPULATION MORE THAN
THREE TIMES LARGER THAN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY JAIL POPULATION.
AND A HISTORY OF SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS RELATED TO INADEQUATE
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT OF PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS HAD EIGHT SUICIDES
DURING THIS THREE YEAR TIME
PERIOD. LESS THAN HALF AS MANY
AS SAN DIEGO COUNTY. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE SAN DIEGO
UNION TRIBUNE INVESTIGATION.
FOUND THAT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND
FORTY PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN
COUNTY CUSTODY. MAKING SAN
DIEGO COUNTY JAIL MORTALITY THE
HIGHEST AMONG LARGE COUNTIES IN
OUR STATE. WE KNOW THAT THIS
CRISIS OF INMATES DYING BEHIND
BARS IS NOT THE WORK OF ANY ONE
INDIVIDUAL. THIS IS A SYSTEMIC
ISSUE THAT REQUIRES AN
INDEPENDENT OBJECTIVE REVIEW SO
THAT WE CAN COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND HOW A JAIL SENTENCE
IT BECAME A DE FACTO DEATH
SENTENCE FOR MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND BASED ON THE
FINDINGS OF THIS AUDIT
IMPLEMENT CORRECTIVE ACTIONS TO
PREVENT THIS FROM CONTINUING TO
OCCUR IN THE FUTURE. WITH ME BY
TELEPHONE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. LIBERTY SANCHEZ
FROM LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
SEIU CALIFORNIA AND PALOMA
SERENA. WHOSE DAUGHTER
UNFORTUNATELY DIED IN CUSTODY
AT THE LOS COLINAS DETENTION
AND RE ENTRY FACILITY AND
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WITH THAT I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THAT
IS ON THE PHONE LINES WITH US
ON THE PHONE LINES MADAM
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN THE
LINES FOR LIBERTY SANCHEZ WHO'S
WITH US YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
HELLO MY SAID ENOUGH WAS A SAN
DIEGO RESIDENT. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS LED
THE SANTAS ON BEHALF OF THAT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING HEALTH CARE
WORKERS IN THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
JAIL. HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUDIT REQUEST REGARDING THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT THE
CONDITIONS IN THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY JAIL OVERSEEN AT THAT
MINISTER BY THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE. UNSAFE
FOR DETAINEES AND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ALIKE. WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
ADEQUATE AND APPROPRIATE
STAFFING LEVELS AND LACK OF
ADHERENCE TO GENERAL PRACTICE
PROTOCOLS. BUT THE DIRECTION OF
HEALTHCARE SERVICE PROVIDERS A
LICENSED MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
RATHER THAN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE CONDITIONS IN THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY JAILS ARE NOT JUST
DANGEROUS AND INHUMANE FOR THE
DETAINEES THEY ARE DANGEROUS
AND INHUMANE FOR THE HEALTHCARE
STAFFING. THE DETAILS ARE
CURRENTLY SO SORT STAFFED THAT
MY MEMBERS ARE SUBJECT TO
MANDATORY OVERTIME WHICH LEAVES
THEM EXHAUSTED AND LEADS TO
UNNECESSARY BURNOUT RELATED
TURNOVER. THIS IS DEEPLY
PERSONAL FOR MY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
THE PROVISION OF HEALTHCARE TO
THE POPULATION MOST OF SOCIETY
CHOOSES TO IGNORE. MY NUMBERS
ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT
DESPITE THEIR BEST OUT OF IT
THEY SIMPLY CANNOT PROVIDE THE
HIGH QUALITY LEVEL OF CARE
DEMANDED BY THE HIGH RISK
PATIENT POPULATION WHEN THEY
ARE BETH OVERWORKED AND
EXHAUSTED DUE TO INADEQUATE
STAFFING. WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
THE COMMITTEE WILL. APPROVE THE
FATHER BUT BY. INSTRUCTIONS ASK
THE ANSWER REGARD THE AND
CONDITION AT THE SAME DIEGO CA
JAIL. WE HOPE THAT THE
PRINCIPLES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL BE TWO IMPORTANT CHANGES
AT THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY JAIL TO
WILL BETTER ENSURE AN ADEQUATE
AND APPROPRIATE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF DETAINEES. AND
HEALTHCARE SERVICE PROVIDERS
ALIKE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE TO- THE
SECOND ONE IS PLEASE. THANK YOU
CARE ABOUT YOUR MEETING. MY
NAME IS ALABAMA THANK TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN MY TWENTY
FOUR YEAR OLD DAUGHTER HE SAID
THERE ARE NONE. I GET THE LAST
WEEK OF JUNE SAN DIEGO. SHE
DIED FROM DEHYDRATION AFTER THE
STAFF IGNORED HER FOR VOMITING
FOR FIVE DAYS. I'M A LITTLE
TODAY. THE STAFF WATCHERS OR
FEATURE- HEAD ON THE WALL COLOR
ONTO THE GROUND HE TURNED
AROUND CLOSE THE DOOR AND LET
THE LEASING OR SELLING DINE.
GIVEN. THE CHARGES HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT. AGAIN ANY OF THE
PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR EACH OF
YEAH. WHAT IS TRULY TRAGIC IS
THAT EVEN DEATH WAS SO
PREVENTABLE SHOULD NEEDED
HYDRATION SHE BEG FOR IT IT
TRIP BUT SHE WAS RECEIVING. SAN
DIEGO THERE HAVE BEEN OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY GET INTO JAIL
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND. NINE
THE HIGHEST RATE IN CALIFORNIA.
LOS CONTINUE BECAUSE WE KNOW IS
HELD A CANDLE. YEAH WE DIDN'T
TRANSPARENCY THROUGH THE STATE
WIDE AUDIT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR THE AVOIDABLE LIVES LOST IN
CUSTODY THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY I
WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO THE STATE AUDITOR
MATTER MONITOR PLEASE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OR- WEBER
INDICATED AND HER COLLEAGUES IN
SAN DIEGO REGION THIS WILL BE
AN AUDIT OF THE SAN DIEGO
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT REALLY
FOCUSING ON. THEIR PRACTICES
AND POLICIES RELATED TO
TRAINING PERSONNEL MAINTAINING
FACILITY AND PROVIDING
HEALTHCARE AND SAFE- ACTION OF
INMATES IN THOSE FACILITIES AND
LOOKING AT THOSE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES IN DETERMINING
WHETHER THEY ALIGN WITH STATE
LAW AND APPLICABLE GUIDANCE.
BUT THEY ALSO ARE ASKING US TO
LOOK AT A FIFTEEN YEAR WINDOW
NOW WILL SELECT A SAMPLE TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN GET INFORMATION I
WILL GO BACK AS FAR AS WE CAN-
TO IDENTIFY THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
RELATED TO PARTICULAR DEATHS
WHETHER THE FACILITY MADE
MODIFICATIONS TO THEIR POLICY
FOR PRACTICES RELATED TO INMATE
SAFETY MAKING SURE INMATES ARE
SAFE IN THOSE FACILITIES AND
THEN WHETHER THE SAN DIEGO
SHERIFF REVIEW THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THOSE DEATHS
AND TOOK ANY CORRECTIVE ACTION
AGAIN TO IMPROVE INMATE SAFETY.
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER IS
ASKING IS EVALUATE DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA FRIDAY IDENTIFY TRENDS
CERTAINLY AS SHE INDICATED IN
HER PRESENTATION- SHE'S
INTERESTED IN HAVING US COMPARE
SOME OF THE INFORMATION WOULD
BE FINE WITH RESPECT TO SAN
DIEGO TO OTHER COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. I WE CERTAINLY WILL
DO THAT IN ADDITION ASKING US
TO LOOK AT ALLEGATIONS FROM
AGAIN GOING BACK AS FAR AS
FIFTEEN YEARS OF THAT LED TO A
WRONG WRONGFUL DEATH SUIT I
DETERMINE THE NUMBER OF THOSE
WORKS THAT WERE SETTLED WHAT
WAS THE AVERAGE SETTLEMENT
AMOUNT. AND PUT AGAIN
POTENTIALLY COMPARE THAT TO
OTHER COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
ALSO WITH WITH RESPECT
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS AND ALSO
GRAND JURY- INVESTIGATIONS THAT
CAME OUT WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
HAVE THOSE BEEN IMPLEMENTED BY
THE SAN DIEGO SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. HAVE THEY REVOKED
OR AMENDED ANY PARTICULAR
POLICIES AGAIN CONSISTENT WITH
OUR CONCERNS THAT CAME OUT OF
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS OR GRAND
JURY RECOMMENDATIONS THE FINAL
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ARE
VERY- OBJECTIVES EXCUSE ME-
RELATE TO THE CITIZENS LAW
ENFORCEMENT REVIEW BOARD WHICH
IS A BOARD THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
IN SAN DIEGO. WAY BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY WHAT THIS BOARD
IS SUPPOSED TO BE WITH REVIEW
AND ASSESS OUR DEATH SITUATIONS
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVEMENT WITHIN TH
FACILITIES. ALSO SHE AND OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE ASKED US TO LOOK.
AT RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE
COME OUT FROM THAT BOARD WELL
OR NOT THEY BEEN IN. BY EXTEND
SHE- AND THEN ALLOW SUBJECT IS
LOOKING AT US. TIME FRAME- THIS
IS TO SEVEN. WHERE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE WERE SOME
ASSERTIONS BY THIS BOARD THIS
REVIEW BOARD. THAT THEY PERHAPS
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH STAFF TO
REVIEW ALL OF THE INMATE.
DEATHS THAT WERE OCCURRING- SO
SHE'S ASKED US TO REEVALUATE
THAT SPECIFIC TIME FRAME TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AND DID AND ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT THE BOARD THIS
THE CITIZENS ENFORCEMENT REVIEW
BOARD HAD SUFFICIENT STAFF TO
REALLY PERFORMANCE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY- THIS ARTICLE
SHOULD BE EIGHT IT'S ABOUT
TWENTY NINE HUNDRED HOURS.
EARLY BECAUSE OF THAT TIME
FRAME WE HAVE TO LOOK AT- AN
AUDIT OF THAT SIZE WILL TAKE US
ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS TO COMPLETE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
OUT OF ORDER LET'S GO AHEAD AND
TURN TO THE AFFECTED AGENCIES
AND I BELIEVE ON THE LINE WE
HAVE WITH US ERICA PEARSON WHO
IS WITH THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. GOOD EVENING
SURE SALAS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERICA
FRIERSON- THE ASSISTANT SHERIFF
ASSIGNED TO OVERSEE. THE
DETENTION SERVICES BUREAU
WITHIN THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. WE
OPERATE A SYSTEM OF SEVEN
FACILITIES WITH AN AVERAGE
DAILY POPULATION OF FIFTY SIX
INDIVIDUALS PRE COATED. THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WILL ALWAYS BE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING THE BEST
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE
POSSIBLE TO THOSE IN OUR
CUSTODY. IF THERE IS
INFORMATION OFFERED THROUGH AN
EXTERNAL AUDIT THAT BRINGS
IMPROVED CARE FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR CUSTODY WE
WELCOME AND- OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WE UNDERSTAND THE
RESPONSIBILITY WE BEAR AND
CARING FOR THE INMATE
POPULATION. AND PRESERVATION OF
LIFE IS ALWAYS OUR GREATEST
MISSION. OUR DEPARTMENT HAS
IMPLEMENTED COMPREHENSIVE
SECURITY MENTAL HEALTH AND
MEDICAL SCREENING PROCEDURES TO
PROVIDE THE HIGHEST QUALITY
CARE TO OUR POPULATION AND TO
REDUCE STAFF IN CUSTODY.
DESPITE THE RIGOROUS REVIEW AN
EXTENSIVE IMPROVEMENTS MADE TO
THE MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITHIN OUR DETENTION.
FACILITIES OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS OUR DEPARTMENT IS
CONSTANTLY SEEKING EXPERT
ADVICE AND EVALUATING OUR
PROCEDURES AND SERVICES TO
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE FOR THE IN
CUSTODY POPULATION. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE TIME TO
SPEAK TODAY AND I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THERE ARE ANY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- WITH THAT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON THE INVITE MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC TO AND I BELIEVE LET
ME CHECK THE CHAMBER HEARING
AND SEEING NONE. WE ASK IF
THERE IS PUBLIC COMMENTS THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE- MADAM
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
THIS FILE ITEM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE OH NINE EITHER IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOU CAN PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO MINUTES
AND STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION. IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT ON TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ONE OH NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF THE THREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS DANNY AT BP- I HEARD ABOUT
THE GAP THE NBA GO DOWNTOWN
DEMOCRATIC CLUB PRESIDENT. AND
I ARE AND BLOWING IN. SUPPORT
OF THIS AUDIT FOR THE COUNTY
JAIL I'M AT ABOUT TIME THAT WE
START LOOKING AT THAT OPTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT- NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT
ONE IS LINE NUMBER THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
THIS IS LAURIE DANIELA SPEAKING
AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
I AM GRATEFUL DR WEBBER THANK
YOU KNOW THAT IT WAS A
RECOMMENDATION I MADE FOR THE
LOCAL REVIEW BOARD IN JANUARY
THE BAKER BURKE TO YOUR AUTO
COMMITTEE. AND I REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU THIS IS NOT THAT
THE MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH BY
THE JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS OF
THE OVER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE HAVE DIED YOU CAN BE
ABLE JAIL SO VERY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT VERY GRATEFUL FOR DR
WEBER TAKING UP THE- MATTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NUMBER TWO SIXTY THREE
FOREHEAD. PLEASE MY NUMBER TWO
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEXT LINE WOULD BE THREE FIFTY
TO. THREE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ROBIN CABLE
I AM CO FOUNDER OF SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE NORTH COUNTY
SAN DIEGO NOW I'M STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF THE BOTTLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE FORTY SIX ONE NUMBER THREE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE PROCEED. THIS IS LISA
VINCENT I'M PRESIDENT OF
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NUMBER THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GET YOURSELF BUT
CERTAIN THERE'D MEMBERS AND
STAFF MY NAME IS JERRY HALL OF
SPECIFIC SCAMS I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES IN OUTRAGE WITH
SCENIC ATTORNEY SURE STOP THE
PRODUCT REQUEST BY SEVENTY
MEMBER DR WEBER YOU OVERSIGHT
WILL ABSOLUTELY SAVE LIVES
THANK YOU ALL AND HAVE A HAPPY
FOURTH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE NUMBER TWO THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND GET
THE PAYMENT THE NUMBER OF
RACIAL JUSTICE COALITION OF SAN
DIEGO AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
DECIDED. THANK YOU MIX WITH
THIS PLEASE. WHAT DO YOU LINE
NUMBER THREE FIFTY LINE NUMBER.
THREE FIFTY. RAMOS JACKSON I
SUPPORT THE FATHER MY SON
MICHAEL WILSON DIED THURSDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IN THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY JAIL. MICHAEL.
SORRY MICHAEL. I HAVE A SERIOUS
HEART. MEDICAL HEART DEFECT IS
LARGELY DEPENDED ON MEDICINE
THAT THEY SAN DIEGO COUNTY JAIL
WITH IT BY OVER TEN DAYS THAT
HE NEEDED. AND IT WAS IGNORED.
MY SON DIED HE- BECAUSE OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S. DID NOT
PROVIDE MEDICAL THREE THIRTY PM
AFTER BEING TOLD. SEVERAL TIMES
I JUST WANT TO SAY NOT ONLY BY
HIS FAMILY BUT- BY MICHAEL
HIMSELF. OKAY ZERO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS ADD NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WHAT WOULD BE THREE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS USE THAT MILLER WITH
THE NORFOLK COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION SAVING LIVES
IN COMPANY PROGRAM A CAMPAIGN
THAT WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING THIS
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY OF AUGUST
EVERY SINCE WE'VE HEARD OF THE
TRAGEDY LOOKS ARE NOW IN CASES
LIKE WILL CONNECT YOU JUST
HEARD IN WHAT OUTSTANDING ANGLE
BUT THERE HAD BEEN NO RESULT
AND NO CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU.
I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE OUT OF- NEXT WITH THIS
PLEASE. WE WILL BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER THREE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HI DAY
MORTICIAN AND POSITION PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME THE NINE
BROWN AND I WORK FOR COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES FOR JUSTIN ONE
GOVERNMENT AND I SUPPORT THAT
BECAUSE IT'S FINE FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THANK YOU AND HAVE A GREAT
EVENING. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE. OKAY
THANK YOU LET ME RETURN THIS
ITEM TO. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHEN WE ASK IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR LEYVA PLEASE- EIGHT ONE
CALLED I JUST WANT TO THANK TO
MOTHERS WHO CALLED IN AND- SAVE
IT I'M INCREDIBLY SORRY AS A
MOTHER MYSELF. YOU SHOULD NOT
LOSE YOUR CHILDREN WHEN THEY
ARE IN CUSTODY REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THEY DID- TO BE PUT IN
PRISON THEY SHOULD NO HAVE
DIED IN CUSTODY. AND I HOPE
THAT THIS AUDIT WILL. SOMEHOW
BRING FORWARD SOME MEASURE OF
JUSTICE FOR SUPPORT THIS AUDIT
AND I WOULD- MOVE IT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
CENTER LEYVA. CENTREBOARD THIS
IF I MAY IMPOSE A QUESTION OR
TWO- THESE TWO TWO THROUGH THE
CHAIR TO THE TO THE AUTHOR-
AFTER CHATTING WITH HER MY
COLLEAGUES IT APPEARS AS IF SAN
DIEGO HAS A MUCH HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF INMATE. DEATHS
THAN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE-
AND I GUESS IT'S GOT WANTED TO
POSE THE QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
NORMALLY IF WE'RE GONNA DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IT WOULD
ALMOST SEEM APPROPRIATE FOR US
TO DO A STATEWIDE. OUR REVIEW
OF THE INMATE DEATH. NUMBERS OF
THE COUNTY BY COUNTY BASIS AS
OPPOSED TO JUST ONE PARTICULAR
COUNTY. DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS OR IDEAS ON. WHY THIS
ONE IS SELECTED. ONLY AND NOT.
WITHIN THE LARGER RUBRIC OF A
STATE WIDE REVIEW. WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION-
THERE IS DATA OUT THERE ALREADY
IN TERMS OF THE SUICIDE AND
DEATH IN OTHER COUNTY THAT'S
WHY WE KNOW THAT SAN DIEGO- HAS
THE HIGHEST OF THE LARGEST
COUNTY SO. WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT WITH THIS AUDIT IS WHY RIGHT
AND SO A PART OF THE AUDIT IS
ALSO GOING TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THE OTHERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE NUMBERS THAT THEY GET.
CORRELATE WITH THE NUMBERS THAT
WE'VE SEEN BEFORE. BUT WE
ALREADY KIND OF ALREADY KNOW
THAT INFORMATION WE'RE JUST
DIGGING DEEPER TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS IT ABOUT OUR SYSTEM.
THAT WE HAVE MORE INMATES THAT
HAVE DIED. SO THAT SERVICE IS
NOT. EXTRAPOLATING OUT- HAVE
SAN DIEGO IS DOING THINGS
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
CALIFORNIA IT IS LIMITED ONLY
TO HELP SAN DIEGO IS DOING
THINGS THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
DESPAIR AT NUMBERS THAT WE'RE
SEEING OUT OF THAT COUNTY
EXACTLY SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
POLICIES PROCEDURES- STAFFING.
LOOKING AT IT FROM OF A
HOLISTIC STANDPOINT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE ISSUE IS YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST ONE THING IT IS A
SYSTEMIC ISSUE THAT WE HAVEN'T
SO LOOKING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS TO THE WE CAN
FIX IT THIS IS CLARIFICATION
THE AUDITOR IS BEING DIRECTED
THROUGH THIS REQUEST. BUT TO
ALSO GIVE A GOOD AMOUNT OF PUT
A GOOD AMOUNT OF EFFORT INTO
HOW SAN DIEGO FITS INTO THE
WHOLE OF THE CALIFORNIA- APPEAL
EXPERIENCE EXACTLY SO WHEN THE
AUDITOR- DISCUSSED IT SHE SAID
THAT SHE BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY ARE GOING TO DO IS TAKE A
LOOK TO SEE WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND COMPARED TO BEST STANDARDS
AND BEST PRACTICES. THANK YOU.
I THANK SEVERAL ASKED THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MR VOEPEL PLEASE. SO
I SUPPORT THIS AUDIT. FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS- WE OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A PROBLEM IN SAN DIEGO AND
I BELIEVE THROUGH MY CONTACTS
WITH THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
THAT THEY WELCOME THE AUDIT.
AND I WORKED WITH THE OTHER
DOCTOR WEBER FOR A YEAR BEFORE
AND YOU CAN CONFIRM IT WITH HER
OR GOOGLE IT. ON THIS
PARTICULAR AUDIT. SO I DO HAVE-
HURT FEELING THOUGH. I HURT
FEELINGS. SO HE SAID THIS WAS
SUPPORTED BY THE DEMOCRATIC SAN
DIEGO. GROUP WHICH I CONSIDER
MYSELF EVEN AS A REPUBLICAN TO
BE PART OF THE SAN DIEGO
DELEGATION. I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR MIGHT OCEANSIDE
COLLEAGUES. AND WE HAVE ANOTHER
REPUBLICAN KINDA UP NORTH SO.
IF YOU COULD IN THE FUTURE AS A
PERSONAL REQUEST JUST. FIGURE
THAT THE SAN DIEGO DELEGATION
WHICH OF MY FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN PRETTY MUCH.
IN A CORD ON MOST THINGS. SO
THAT SAID THANK YOU MR VOEPEL.
AND WITHOUT WILL BE ASKED
THERE'S ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING AND SEEING
NINE LET ME ASK- THIS LEVER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE YES I WOULD
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO ADDRESS
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL AND DON'T MEAN TO HURT
YOUR FEELINGS- AND I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE OVERSIGHT THE
WAY THIS CAME ABOUT WAS- A
RESOLUTION I CAME THROUGH THE
SENATE GO DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
SO THAT'S WHAT WE GOT ALL OF
THE DEMOCRATIC DELEGATES TO
SIGN ON- INCLUDING THE SENATOR
SELL. IN THE FUTURE WE WILL
DEFINITELY MAKE SURE TO REACH
OUT TO YOU AND OUR OTHER
COLLEAGUES- TO SIGN ON TO THIS
BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO PUT YOU IN
IT EVEN THOUGH I KNOW YOU
SUPPORTED IT- BECAUSE YOU YOU
KNOW YOU CAN SIGN A LETTER BUT
IN THE FUTURE WE DEFINITELY
WELL. I'M SO IT IS SAID. THAT A
TRUE MEASURE OF ANY SOCIETY CAN
BE FOUND IN HOW IT TREATS ITS
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS. AND BY
THAT STANDARD IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WE ARE FAILING. A JAIL
SENTENCE SHOULD NOT BE A DE
FACTO DEATH SENTENCE. WE MUST
DO BETTER AND WE CAN DO BETTER.
BUT IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE MUST
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
AND FIX IT. AGAIN THIS IS
CLEARLY A LONGSTANDING SYSTEMIC
ISSUE THAT REQUIRES AN
INDEPENDENT OBJECTIVE REVIEW.
ON BEHALF OF OUR DELEGATION I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US. WHAT WE WILL
HAVE IS A FIFTEEN YEAR
REPRESETATIVE SAMPLE THAT WILL
GIVE US THE DATA THAT WE NEED
TO FIX THE PROBLEM THAT WE
CLEARLY HAVE WITHIN OUR JAIL
SYSTEM. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK REST WEBER WOOD PROCEDURE
BRING THIS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
AND LOOKING AT THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROTOCOLS AND POLICIES FOR
ENSURING SAFETY OF THE INMATES
WE KNOW THAT. SAN DIEGO HAS HAD
AN ISSUE AND IT'S COUNTY JAILS
AND WITH THAT I DO HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND I'M
ASKING I BELIEVE IT WAS MOVED
BY SENATOR LEYVA AND SECONDED
BY MISS BERNARD ABOUT. MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. IN
SALINAS ON. THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE AUDIT REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH NINE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS I
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I HIGHLY.
PATTERSON RUBIO. VOEPEL VOEPEL
I WOULD WOOD I SENATOR LAYERED.
LAYERED I BACKER. GORGEOUS FOR
JUST AYE GLAZER. HERTZBERG
LEYVA LEYVA AYE NIELSEN NIELSEN
HI. THE MOTION CARRIES WALDO
WELL THE ROLE OPENED FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK THANK
YOU MISS WEBER THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE FOURTEEN
STATE AGENCIES MANAGEMENT OF
SURPLUS PROPERTY WHEN YOU'RE
READY TO PROCEED PLEASE PROCEED
TO. ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUICK SILVA.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM HERE TO
PRESENT TO MY AUDIT REQUEST
REGARDING STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES UP FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND IS
COMMITTEE AND- FOR THEIR VERY
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS MATTER.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC OUR STATE
WAS FACING THE WORST HOUSING
SHORTAGE WITH THE GROWING
HOMELESS POPULATION IN THE PAST
YEAR THESE ISSUES. HAVE ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE AS A RESULT OF
MANY CALIFORNIANS LOSING THEIR
JOBS AND BECOMING HOUSING AND
SECURE. WE'VE MADE MANY STEPS
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY TO
ADDRESS THIS WITH A RECENT VOTE
ON A RED MORATORIUM. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED TODAY
IN THIS AUDIT INTERSECT AS WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER'S
AUDIT REQUEST FOR THE I. D. D.
POPULATION. WE ALSO KNOW
LOOKING IN THE FUTURE WITH THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE THAT
POTENTIALLY WILL MOVE FROM
BEING HOUSED TO HOMELESS ARE
TOO MANY TO COUNT. AND SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT STATE PROPERTY STATE
SURPLUS PROPERTY BUT WE HAVE
SEEN AND EVAN FLOW JUST IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN I SAT ON
ACCOUNTABILITY. COMMITTEE WE
ARE ACTUALLY JUST REMOVING PART
PROPERTIES FROM THE ROLES NOW
WE FIND OURSELVES. IN A CRISIS
AND EVERY PIECE OF LAND IS
VALUABLE WE KNOW HOUSING PRICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF HEALTH
CALIFORNIA ARE THE HIGHEST
THEY'VE EVER BEEN. SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT SURPLUS PROPERTY IT'S
OUR DUTY TO NOT ONLY TAKE
INVENTORY BUT TO AUDIT IT TO
FIND OUT WHY WHEN CALIFORNIANS.
THE ONE THING THEY DO AGREE ON.
AND IS VERY CONTESTED PERIOD IS
THAT WERE NOT DOING ENOUGH
REGARDING HOMELESSNESS. THAT WE
ARE NOT. HOUSING PEOPLE THAT WE
ARE NOT BUILDING. AND THAT WE
ARE FAILING WITH SOME OF OUR
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
FORWARD TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS 27% OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS
POPULATION IS CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS. JUST IN MY COUNTY OF
ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE BETWEEN
THIRTY TO FORTY DEATHS A MONTH
OF PEOPLE DYING AND PUBLIC.
SPACES BENCHES BUS STOPS PARKS
THEREFORE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THE STATE IDENTIFY AND SELL
SURPLUS PROPERTIES TO PURSUE
SUSTAINABLE INNOVATIVE AND COST
EFFECTIVE HOUSING PROJECTS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER. IN
WHICH HE ORDERED THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF. HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY TO IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES FOR COST EFFECTIVE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS. THEN CAME
COATED IN THE PANDEMIC. AND AS
YOU MIGHT GUESS WE HAVE SEEN
VERY VERY VERY LITTLE. HOUSING
THAT HAS NOW HAPPENED ON
SURPLUS PROPERTY STATE PROPERTY.
NOW THE STATE ACTUALLY
IDENTIFIED OVER FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PARCELS. NOT ALL OF
THOSE ARE SUITABLE FOR HOUSING.
BUT WE KNOW A MINUTE AMOUNT
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN USED OR ARE
GOING TO BE USED FOR FUTURE
HOUSING IT IS MY HOPE THAT WITH
THIS AUDIT WE WILL BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
DGS ALLOWS WHEN DISPOSING STATE
SURPLUS PROPERTIES. I BELIEVE
IT ALL WHAT ALSO BE HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS FOLLOWED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WHEN
DISPOSING TRANSFERRING AND
SELLING OF STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES. COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
SOME PROPERTIES THAT ARE NOT
ONLY A FEW ACRES BUT HUNDREDS
OF ACRES THAT ARE NOT BEING
USED RIGHT NOW. SOME OF THOSE
PROPERTIES ARE FORMER HOSPITALS
FOR OUR DISABLED. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT WERE CLOSED DOWN
SOME OF THOSE PROPERTIES ARE
SITTING IDLE WITH SOME BUT IN
SOME CASES HUNDREDS OF ROOMS.
THAT USED TO BE SERVE OUR
FORMALLY DISABLED POPULATION.
IN SAN FRANCISCO SACRAMENTO
FRESNO LOS ANGELES ORANGE AND
SAN DIEGO HAVE ALL SEEN GREAT.
INCREASES IN HOMELESSNESS AND
SO IT IS MY **** THAT WE AUDIT
OUR SURPLUS STATE PROPERTIES
AND MAKE THE ENQUIRING TO FIND
OUT WHAT WE CAN ACTUALLY FOR
SEE IN THE FUTURE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HERE TO
SPEAK WITH ME OR WITH YOU- IS
IN THIS AUDIT IS HEATHER
HEATHER STRATMAN THE DIRECTOR
OF HOUSING FOR HEALTH ORANGE
COUNTY. RIGHT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WILL GO AHEAD
AND TURN TO YOUR WITH THIS WE
BELIEVE IS ON THE PHONE LINES
THIS IS MATT MISS HEATHER
STRATMAN DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
FOR HEALTH ORANGE COUNTY. AT
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING
AND THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
MY NAME IS HEATHER STRATMAN
NINETY SERVICE THE DIRECTOR FOR
HOUSING FOR HELP ORANGE COUNTY.
AT A WIDE KNOWN AS A TEACHER C.
H. A THEME WITH FORMED TO
IMPLEMENT AN ONLINE FINDING
SUPPORT ORANGE COUNTY TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED UNIT PLANTS
DELIVER NEW AFFORDABLE AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING TO
OUR REGION. IT OUR CHALLENGE IS
CLEAR WE DO NOT HAVE THE
AVAILABLE LAND OR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT SUPPORT
THE TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED UNIT
PLAN. BUT LAND VALUES AT ALL
HIGH ALL TIME RECORD HIGHS
LIMITED AVAILABILITY OF. REAL
ESTATE. AND A VERY COMPLEX AND
TIME CONSUMING PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THE CAPITAL FACT IT
TO FINANCE AFFORDABLE AND PSH
PROJECT. WE ARE SORELY LACKING
IN BOTH THE SCALING CAPACITY TO
HOW THE THOUSANDS OF
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA COUNTY AND SUPPORT
THE THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS.
AND FAMILIES SEARCHING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND TWENTY
NINETEEN AT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- INDICATED THE STATE
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL THOUSAND
STATE ON SITE THAT WERE DEEMED
SURPLUS PROPERTY. BUT IN FACT
TIENEN WITH CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME AND RESOURCES THERE HAS
NOT BEEN ANY DIRECT ACTION
MOVIE TYPE. FROM BAKING OR
UNDER UTILIZED PROPERTIES TO
BIBLE HOUSING PROJECT. MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES I'VE ENCOUNTERED
INCLUDE THE LACK OF A
PREEMPTIVE ZONING PROCESS AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO ENTITLE AND
CONVEYED PROPERTY TO THE LOCAL
ENTITY. A LACK OF POLITICAL
WILL AT BOTH THE STATE LEVEL
AND LOCALLY TO COMBAT THE NAME
THE EFFORT. AND A DIVERGENT
IDEOLOGY BETWEEN LABOR GROUP IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
BACK IN IN THE FAMILY VERILY
LIMITING THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK BEING BROUGHT TO THE
MARKET. UNDER CURRENT STATE
LAW- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS HAVE A PARTY AFTER
SURPLUS MIGHT. I RECOMMEND YOU
MOVE THE PROPERTY TO THAT LIST
OF THE DAY ARE READY FOR
TRANSACTION. SECOND I RECOMMEND
THAT THEY BE CONVEYED WITH BY
RIGHT DESIGNATION IF THEY ARE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT.
THIS WILL PUT THE PARCEL
INFLATE. AND CIRCUMVENT YOU CAN
BE OBJECTION. IT OF THE OF. YOU
NEEDED STATEWIDE. ANY AVAILABLE
STATE FEDERAL HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS COMING
INTO THE PIPELINE NOW IS THE
TIME TO AT IT IT HAS STARTED
OUT IT IN RELEASED THE SURPLUS
PROPERTY MARKET THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME LEADERSHIP ON THE
SOCIAL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
PRESENTATION MADAM AUDITOR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA INDICATED WAS
REALLY LOOKING AT MANAGEMENT OF
SURPLUS PROPERTIES IN
CALIFORNIA FIRST OF ALL-
WORKING WITH A PARTICULAR
AGENCIES CALTRANS TGS
DEPARTMENT FELDMAN SERVICES OUR
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
ARGUMENT TO IDENTIFY PROCESSES
THEY USED TO IDENTIFYING REPORT
SURPLUS PROPERTIES- WITH
RESPECT TO THE FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND- PARCELS THAT- IS
BURKE SOLD AND I REFERRED TO
YOU- LOOKING AT THE STATUS OF
THOSE HOW MANY OF THOSE HAVE
BEEN DEEMED SUITABLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- WHAT'S THE
PROGRESS AND TIMELINE OF ANY
HOUSING PROJECTS. THAT I HAVE
COMMENCED ON THOSE ON THOSE
PARCELS IF THEY HAVE BEEN
DEEMED NOT SUITABLE FOR HOUSING
WHY IS THAT- TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
YOU KNOW WHICH ONES WITHIN THAT
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND AND THEN
ANOTHER STEP. BEYOND THOSE
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND DETERMINE
WHAT THE STATE OWNS ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL PROPERTIES- THAT IT
IDENTIFIED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT MAY BE SUITABLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH A
SPECIFIC EMPHASIS ON THE
COUNTIES- MISS CORK SILVA. I
POINTED OUT IN HER COMMENTS
THAT WOULD BE FRESNO LA ORANGE
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO AND SAN
FRANCISCO I PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE THOSE COUNTY STEPS HAVE
SEEN IT I'M- PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
ALSO LOOKING AT THE A SELECTION
OF PARCELS THAT WERE DEEMED
SUITABLE FOR HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHAT STEPS NEED TO BE
CARRIED OUT- TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
BUILD COST EFFECTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. ACTUALLY HAPPENS-
SHE'S ASKED US TO LOOK AT
PROCESS ON ONE'S INVOLVEMENT OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN IDENTIFYING
PROPERTIES AND TRANSFERRING OR
GETTING THOSE PROPERTIES IN THE
HANDS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS- IDENTIFY THE
NUMBER OF PROPERTIES THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE ACTIVE. PLANS TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
CONTRARY TO THAT- PROPERTIES DO
NOTHAVE AN PLAN. DETERMINE
WHETHER THE DEPART ARE WORKING
TO OVERCOME ANY OBSTACLES THAT
MAY BE IN A WAY I'M DEEMING
THAT PROPERTY SUITABLE FOR
HOUSING AND GETTING SOME PLANS
ARE IN PLACE. AND THEN THE LAST
OBJECTIVE IS EVALUATING THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE AGENCIES
CALTRANS AGAIN D. A. D. S. I
GENERAL SERVICES AND HEALTHCARE
SERVICE I'M- HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THEIR ENGAGEMENT
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS- WITH RESPECT TO
TRANSPARENCY ENGAGING WITH
THESE LOCALS TO. IDENTIFY AND
WORK WITH THEM TO BE ABLE TO
GET SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILT IN CALIFORNIA- ALSO
IDENTIFYING THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR. WE
SHOULD ENSURING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACTUALLY DO DEVELOP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FROM SURPLUS
PROPERTIES ONE OF THE WITNESSES
TALKED ABOUT NAME BASED SO.
REALLY LOOKING TO SEE AS WE SAW
IN A PREVIOUS SITE WE DID ON A
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA AND-
DECISION MAKING WITH RESPECT TO
OUR BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES. ASKING
US TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT THE
STATE IS DOING TO ENGAGE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO ENSURE THAT THIS
TYPE OF HOUSING IS BUILT- WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED HOURS. NOT
A VERY BIG AUDIT- TAKES ABOUT.
SIX MONTHS TO COMPLETE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BARAMATI WHAT
THAT LET'S AHEAD AND TO- A
PUBLIC COMMENT REMOVED A PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME WE SEE IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE CHAMBER. HEARING AND SEEING
NINE WILL BE MOVED TO THE- I'M
SORRY LET ME MOVE TO. THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES- FROM THE
SAUDADES AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF THEM ON THE PHONE
LINE- WE HAVE MEMBERS FROM DG
YES H. C. D. DDS HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
SO LET ME ASK. OF MADAME
OPERATOR IF WE HAVE MISTER MATT
BENDER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. OR MR JASON
KENNEY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. YES MISTER
CHAIR- MY NAME IS TAKING CAN
YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY YES PLEASE
PROCEED AT. THANK YOU UNDER THE
DIRECTOR FOR REAL ESTATE THAT
APARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES I
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
AND CONTACT ON THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER. ASSEMBLY MEMBERSMAY BE
AWARE I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
TESTIFYING LOCAL PARK BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE NOW ON THE
SUBJECT EXECUTIVE ORDER IN FACT
COUNTING OR LEGISLATIVE
OUTREACH TO MEMBERS ON SITE
YOU'RE ACTIVELY WORKING ON IN
THE DISTRICT- DEJECTED AND
CONTACTED FIFTY Q. LEGISLATIVE
OFFICES COMMITTEES AND CAUCUSES
ACROSS SIXTY NINE INSTANCES. OF
BRIEFINGS MEETING INCREASE
OUTREACH AND HEARING- BY
PREVIOUSLY THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
REQUIRED DGS AND HOW THEN CAN
YOU DEVELOPMENT HCD TRIBUTE THE
ENTIRETY OF STATE OWNED
PROPERTY FOR POTENTIAL HOUSING
SITES. AND IT'S PROBABLY THE
FIRST FACT THAT I SHOULD
CORRECT THE RECORD ON THERE ARE
NOT FORTY FOUR THOUSAND ACCESS
OR SURPLUS PARCELS. FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PARCELS IS THE
ENTIRETY OF STATE OWNED
PROPERTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- CERTAINLY IF WE HAD
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND ACCESS
PROPERTIES I WOULD ABSOLUTELY
SHARE ASSEMBLY WOMAN CONCERNED
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THIS THING
DONE- THE FACT IS TYPICALLY WE
HAVE VERY FEW ACCESS THIS
SURPLUS PROPERTY ON THE GOLD
AND BOARDING TIME- GENERALLY
LESS THAN FIFTEEN OR SO. AND
THAT'S WHY GOVERNOR NEWSOM
CALLED FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF STATE PROPERTY- TO
MAKE SURE THAT NO STONE WAS
LEFT UNTURNED. SO IN TWENTY
NINETEEN NINETEEN ALONG WITH
THE DEPARTMENT HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT REVIEWED
ALL OF THOSE FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH A PROPERTY
WE WERE PRIMARILY LOOKING FOR
PROPERTY THAT EITHER- WAS
POTENTIALLY SUITABLE FOR
HOUSING AND- THAT APPEARED TO
BE UNDER UTILIZED BY STATE
DEPARTMENT. YOU CAN IMAGINE
CALIFORNIA OWNS A LOT OF
PROPERTY THAT IS EITHER CLEARLY
ACTIVELY IN USE BY DEPARTMENT
OR EXPLAIN ME UNSUITABLE FOR
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE NATURAL
RESOURCES BUDGET SPEECHES LAKE
PARK CETERA. FACTORING THOSE
PARCELED OUT AND WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT TO FURTHER SCREEN
OUT PROPERTY THAT WERE
CONTAMINATED THE WORD
HEIRONEOUS LEE AND COUNTY
PROPERTY RECORDS BELONG TO THE
STATE OR THAT HAD REASONABLY
LIKELY FUTURE. STATE USED PLAN
WE'VE. BEEN A FIVE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR PARCELS SUITABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. THAT
INCLUDES A MENTION THAT WERE TO
GET THE A FIVE GOVERNMENTS AND
BY MY- OF LEGISLATURE. WHICH WE
THEN AN STILL ACT ENCOURAGE.
THOSE ONE TWENTY SITE SEVENTY
ACT. AND ARE AVAILABLE FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT- AFTER WE
COMPILED A HUNDRED TWENTY
FOURTH FLIGHT BEGAN
PRIORITIZING THEM FOR
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS AN EDITOR
TO PROCESS. WE USED PUBLISHED
CRITERIA THAT ALIGN WITH ATVS
FINANCING PROGRAMS AND WE
GENERALLY LOOKED AFTER FOCUSED
ON SITE THEY CAN BREAK GROUND
MORE QUICKLY. AND BE MORE
COMPETITIVE FOR FINANCING.
INTERWEAVE ACCOMPLISHED I THINK
WE'VE MADE SOLID PROGRESS GIVEN
THAT WE UNDERTOOK THIS EFFORT
WITH NO ADDITIONAL STAFFING
RESOURCES. EXECUTIVE ORDER HAS
A VERY SPECIFIC DEVELOPMENT
MODEL IN MIND. WHICH IS
PROBABLY ANOTHER PLACE TO
CORRECT THE RECORD ON. THE
STATE DOES NOT SELL OR TRANSFER
PROPERTIES UNDER EXECUTIVE
ORDER WE LEASED THEM TO
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD MAINTAIN
AND OPERATE THE HOUSING IS.
THANK YOU DECEMBER TWENTY SIXTH
IS MISTER BENDER THERE WITH YOU
AS WELL ARE YOU. TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF BOTH OF YOU. I JUST
WANT TO BE ABLE OF US I I'M
ALMOST AT THAT. HELPS NUMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN WE SHOULD GO
FIRST PLEASE- RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
SAY PROGRAM LAST MONTH. I THINK
THAT WE GET RATED ON THE MOST
EFFICIENT APPROACH ITSELF WITH
ANNUAL GLOBAL FORTY TWELVE
EIGHT TO TWELVE BY DEVELOPERS.
AT PRESENT WE HAVE SIXTEEN
PROJECTS IN BOMBAY DEVELOPMENT
TEN ARE FULLY AWARDED IT I
DON'T THINK THAT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED UNITS OF HOUSING THE
OTHER SIX DURING PUBLICATION.
WELCOME BUDGETARY LANGUAGE
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
NOW THAT WE EXPAND OUR ABILITY
TO FELT LIKE TO MAXIMIZE
HOUSING SOME OF OUR LARGER
SITES HAVE BEEN DELAYED UNTIL
WE COULD ADDRESS SHORTCOMINGS
THAT ARE LEASING THE AUTHORITY.
WHICH WILL INCREASE OUR
PIPELINE OVER THE SUMMER-
COMMITTEE AFTER TODAY WOULD
REQUIRE IF YOU CONCERNED
INCLUDING MR KENNEY WE
APPRECIATE WE HAVE. THREE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS OF THE TO TESTIFY
AS WELL. OF COURSE OF COURSE. I
TO BE COMPLETE BY. FOR PURPOSES
YOU GET ME. THE AND ALL THAT
WITH EVERY SINGLE. AND PART OF
THE PROBE MINUTES. AFTER ABLE
TO SEARCH AND MAP- IT OFF THE
LIST EVERY PROJECT WE HAVE IN
THE PIPELINE INCLUDING
APPLICATION. THEY CAN TAKE
THEIR TESTIMONY COMPILED BUT
HEARING THAT THANK YOU AND THE
CRITERIA I MENTIONED EARLIER-
WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. OR CANNELLA
QUICKSILVER INCLUDING UP ANY
MISUNDERSTANDINGS ABOUT. THE
YELLOW FOR OUR EFFORTS TO HELP.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOU WANTING TO
WORK WITH. AN WITH THE ON. ON
THE SIDE LIMIT THIS TIME ONLY
ASK IF THERE'RE INDIVIDUALS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOP ON THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. YES
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS FOR FASTER WITHOUT THE CAR
AGAIN AND I'M UNIT CHIEF IN THE
HOUSING POLICY DIVISION. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FOR EACH
CD. TWENTY NINETEEN I WOULD EAT
CITIES IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
GOVERNOR. EXECUTIVE ORDER. IN A
SEPARATE WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH DEFENSE AND ISCHEMIC TGS
TO BRING EIGHTEENTH MISSION AND
OUR EXPERTISE OF DEVELOPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INTO THIS
WORK. BEFORE HEARING ABOUT EACH
CITIES ROLE IN THIS WORK I WANT
TO MAKE A QUICK DISTINCTION
BETWEEN LOCAL SURPLUS PROPERTY.
AND STATE ACCESS PROPERTY-
BINDING ABILITY TO TYPE THE
PROPERTY IS A COMMON
MISCONCEPTION INCLUDING ON THE
AUDIT REQUEST BEING CONSIDERED.
AS THEY ARE SIMILAR BUT VERY
DISTINCT TYPES OF PROPERTY. THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT APPLIED TO
LOCAL AGENCY OR DISPOSING OF
LOCALLY OWNED. SURPLUS LAND FOR
HOUSING OR OTHER USES. BUT IN
CONTRAST EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
EXCESS SITE CREATED A PATH FOR
DTS AND HCV I MAKE STATE OWNED
EXCEPT LAND AVAILABLE. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
THE ANSWER OF THE IN THE AUDIT
REQUEST LETTER I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS ON EACH EACH FALL AND
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE STATE
EXERCISE EXECUTIVE ORDER. FIRST
AFTER WE IDENTIFY THE STATE
OWNED ACCESS PLAN FOR HOUSING
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE. WE
CONDUCT OUTREACH TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ENGAGING CITIES AND
COUNTIES WERE STATE OWNED LAND
EXISTS. LET'S START BY
IDENTIFYING CONTACT WITH THE
CITY OR COUNTY. WE DON'T HAVE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED CONTACTS
FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS SPENDING
WORK WE REACH OUT. TO LOCAL
HOUSING DEPARTMENT CITY
PLANNING CITY MANAGERS OR
SIMILAR DEPARTMENTS WERE
THINKING ABOUT HOUSING IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITY. FROM THERE WE
SCHEDULE A MEETING TO DISCUSS
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
STATEMENT AVAILABLE IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITY. AND- WE
QUIETLY INQUIRED ABOUT THEIR
LOCAL EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
THEIR VISION FOR THAT AREA AND
THEIR PROGRESS TOWARD MEETING
HOUSING NEED. AND DURING THOSE
MEETINGS IT SHOULD BE AN EASY
ACCESS ANSWER ANY QUESTION FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND
ENCOURAGE THEM TO ENGAGE THEIR
LOCAL PARTNERS WHICH MAY
INCLUDE A PUBLIC HOUSING
AUTHORITY. ALSO MAY BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT. BUT
THROUGH THESE CONVERSATIONS WE
CAN BOTH AFFECT ENCOURAGE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS READINESS TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE. TO
SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT. OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ARCHITECT
PLANT. RIGHT AT WEBER OUR- YES.
NOW PLEASE PRESIDENT AROUND
WHAT. WE APPRECIATE AYE WELL I
AM I WILL BE BRIEF EIGHTY
LEVERAGES OUR KNOWLEDGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ORGANIZATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE REACH A
RANGE OF AND HE FOR INTERESTED
IN EXPERIENCE IN SUPPORTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE BUILT AND
MAINTAINED A LIST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE REACH OUT TO THEM ASIDE
FROM THE GF COAST ON THE
WEBSITE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WITH
TO THE WEARER OF OPPORTUNITIES
AND TO MAKE SURE WE TALKED A
WIDE NET AROUND THE STATE BUT
THROUGHOUT THE WORK I JUST
DESCRIBED MY FINAL POINT OUR
GOAL IS TO UNDERSTAND ANY
BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WE CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE. IN THERE WE
BRING OUR KNOWLEDGE OF FINANCE
DEVELOPMENT POLICY AND PLANNING
ALL AROUND HOUSING TO HELP
REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS TO
DEVELOPMENT AND WE MEET WITH
THE PRINCIPAL STEVEN EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT WE ACT WITH URGENCY
ENCOURAGE INNOVATION TO EXPAND
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES BY
REMOVING ONE OF THE BIGGEST AND
MOST CHALLENGING BARRIERS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH IS THE AVAILABILITY OF
LAND LIKE CASE AND I WOULD
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT WERE
AVAILABLE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DIRECTLY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR WORK ON THE
EXECUTIVE. ORDER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THE YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- OF A- AS WELL WE
APPRECIATE THAT- WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE ON. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE MISS CARLA CASTA NEAR THE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. THANK
YOU- COURTESY OF THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT MIDDLE SERVICES- WE HAVE
NO ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
PROVIDE BOTH ARE HAPPY TO-
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT LET'S MOVE ON
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE MRS KIMBERLY
ERICKSON OR MISTER DANNY YOST
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY ERICKSON CALTRANS
RIGHT OF WAY AND WE OBSERVE A
DIVISION CHIEF. ME ON THE PHONE
AND DANIELLE OUR SYSTEM DEPUTY
DIRECTOR LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS.
AS MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE
THAT EACH YEAR AND EACH CD
CALTRANS IS WORKING TO SUPPORT
THE AGENCIES IN IMPLEMENTING
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN OF SIX
NINETEEN. TO DRAFTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISES IN
CALIFORNIA. IF THE LINE FOR THE
CALTRANS COMMITMENT TO
ADVANCING EQUITY AND LIVABILITY
IN ALL COMMUNITIES. AS OUTLINED
IN. CALTRANS STRATEGIC PLAN.
CALTRANS OFFICE LEGISLATION
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY TO HELP
ADDRESS ARRIERS TO USING
CALTRANS PROPERTY FOR
DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND BUILDING SHELTERS. IF THEY
THOUGHT IT IS APPROVED WE WILL
FULLY COOPERATE WITH THE AUDIT
TEAM THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU PROJECT THAT
TESTIMONY- WITH THAT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. MASK THERE'S ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE CHAMBER
HEARING AND SAYING NONE. WE ASK
IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
TO THE ROOT TESTIMONY STATION.
HEARING AND SAYING NINE- BATUM
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE THE
LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THIS FILE ITEM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE ONE FOUR- EITHER
IN OPPOSITION OR IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ITEM IF YOU COULD PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS- NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITIONAL THE
COMMITTEE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT- MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE THE LINES- IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE ONE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN
THAT IS TWO ZERO TWO ONE DASH
ONE ONE FOUR REPORTER
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND MR
CHERRY DO NOT SHO ANYBODY
GIVING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
LET ME RETURN THIS ITEM BACK TO
MEMBERS HERE IN THE CHAMBER ON
THE COMMITTEE WHEN ASKED IF
THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. RIGHT
HERE AGAIN SAYING NINE LET ME
ASK ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK SILVA
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE- YES
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE BY. THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT. PROVIDE MANY OF THE
SERVICES TO OUR STATE AND I AM
HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN ANY TIME
REGARDING. THEIR INPUT BUT I
STILL BELIEVE AN AUDIT FOR
SOMETHING THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO OUR STATE AND THE ONE AREA
WE FIND AGREEMENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE HAVE TO
DO BETTER RELATED TO NOT ONLY
HOMELESSNESS BUT HOUSING SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING THIS OUT OF FORWARD-
AND TACKLING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ISSUE IT CONTINUES TO
BE AN ISSUE THAT IS RELEVANT IN
THE STATE AND IT CONTINUES TO
BE ONE EVERY SINGLE YEAR WITH
THAT AS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FOR ME BUT LET
ME ASK FIRST IF THERE IS A
MOTION AND A SECOND. MOVED BY.
SENATOR BAKER SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD- WITH
THAT MADAM STRUCTURE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE
AUDIT REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASHONE FOURTEEN STATE
AGENCIES MANAGEMENT OF SURPLUS
PROPERTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS HI SALAS I
BOERNER HORVATH. KILEY.
PATTERSON RUBIO. RUBIO I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I. ONE WOOD I SENATOR
LAYERED. LAYERED I BAKER.
FACTOR I GORGEOUS FOR JUST I
GLAZIER. HERTZBERG LEYVA. LEYVA
AYE NIELSEN. THE MOTION CARRIES
WILL GO AHEAD AND HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
ADAM THANK YOU THIS TIME WE ARE
WAITING FOR A FINAL AUTHOR
WHICH IS SENATOR HERTZBERG ON
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE
FIFTEEN AND WHILE WE WAIT FOR
HIM WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
ITEM THAT WAS REMOVED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH EIGHT OH SIX
LOCAL HIGH RISK ASSESSMENT THE
CITY OF RICHMOND AND WITH THAT
LET ME GO AHEAD AND- TURN IT
OVER TO- THE BETTER MONITOR FOR
HER PRESENTATION ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILL KEEP OUR PRESENTATION
BREAKING I HAVE MISTER CHILDREN
WHOSE AND DEPUTY STATE AUDITOR
IN OUR OFFICE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE LOCAL I. REST PROGRAM I'LL
GIVE YOU SOME THOUGHTS ON WHY
WE FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO CONDUCT MARKET WORK AT THE
CITY RICHMOND. ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME'S MIKE KILLED AND I'M A
DEPUTY STATE AUDITOR- I DO
THINK THAT. SKEWS ME AS I THINK
THE COMMITTEE KNOWS WE HAVE A
LOCAL HIGHER RISK OF PROGRAM IN
PLACE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. AS A PART OF THAT WE
ALSO HAVE. AN INTERACTIVE
DASHBOARD THEY WERE RELEASED
TWO YEARS AGO. AND RECENTLY
THAT PROVIDES A MECHANISM FOR
US TO EVALUATE THE FINANCES. OF
VIRTUALLY EVERY SITTING IN
FINGER CALIFORNIA ACT AND
PUBLISH THAT INFORMATION ON OUR
WEBSITE AND- SINCE WE'VE HAD
THE PROGRAM GOING IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. WE'VE REALLY
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT FINANCES
OUT OF THE CITY OF RICHMOND.
AND SPECIFICALLY- SINCE WE
ESTABLISHED THE DASH FOR THE
CITY OF RICHMOND HAS REALLY
BEEN MOVING UP OUR LIST. OF
CITIES THAT ARE OUR MOST
FISCALLY CHALLENGED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND IN OUR
MOST RECENT UPDATE TO THE
DASHBOARD IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. RICHMOND MOVED UP TO
THE FIFTH MOST FISCALLY
CHALLENGED CITY IN THE STATE.
AND BASICALLY WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO IS THE CITY IS REALLY
LACKING. SUFFICIENT FINANCIAL
RESERVES. AND IT REALLY HAS A
COMPROMISED ABILITY TO PAY ITS
LONG TERM DEBTS. INCLUDING
SIGNIFICANT UNFUNDED.
RETIREMENT OBLIGATIONS. THE
OTHER THING THAT WE FOR TROUBLE
IS. THE CITY IS A HOW TO HARD
TIME BALANCING ITS BUDGET OVER
THE LAST TWO FISCAL YEARS. FOR
EXAMPLE TOWARDS FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SLASH TWENTY
TWO BUDGET. THE CITY HAD TO USE
OUR- FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
STAINLESS MONEY THAT EXPECTS TO
RECEIVE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO REALLY BALANCE
ITS BUDGET WITHOUT THAT THE
CITY HAD A HOLD ITS TWENTY
TWENTY. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. THE OTHER THING IS WE
KNOW THAT THE CITY OF RICHMOND
HAS RECENTLY HIRED MANAGEMENT
CONSULTANTS AMERICAN SOLDIERS
COME UP WITH A TEN YEAR
FINANCIAL FORECAST. AND NOT
FORECAST PROJECTS AT THE CITY'S
GENERAL FUND IS GONNA BE
STARTING TO RUN A DEFICIT IN
JUST A FEW YEARS BY FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. AND
BASICALLY THAT'S HAPPENING
BECAUSE THE CITY IS
EXPENDITURES ARE PROJECTED TO
GROW MORE RAPIDLY THAN ITS
REVENUES. IT PUTS STRESS
FINANCES. AND SO JUST TO WALK
THROUGH THE KEY OBJECTIVES IN
OUR OUR PROPOSAL VERY QUICKLY
IF THE ARTS APPROVED WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TAKE A DEEP
DIVE INTO THE CITY'S FINANCES
PROGRAM ASSESS ITS CURRENT
FINANCIAL CONDITION WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A LOOK AT ITS ABILITY TO
PAY ITS BILLS BOTH IN THE SHORT
TERM AND THE LONG TERM WE'RE
GONNA IDENTIFY REALLY THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES THE CITY OF RICHMOND
HAS BEEN EXPERIENCING. FOR
QUITE SOME TIME WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
CITY'S BUDGETING PRACTICES
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THEIR
FINANCIAL FORECASTS OF AN
ASSESS THE REASONABLENESS OF
THE OF THE PROJECTIONS BOARDS
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES AND
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE CITY'S PROCESS
PROCESSING FEES WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE CITY SETTING PLEASE AN
APPROPRIATE MANNER THAT COVERS
THE COST OF PROVIDING SERVICES.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WILL DO
IS TAKE A LOOK AT ANY OTHER
ARTS HAVE BEEN DONE BY THE
CITY'S EXTERNAL FINANCIAL
AUDITORS WILL ALSO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT THEY'RE MANAGEMENT
CONSULTANT HAS DONE AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DUPLICATE ANY OF
THAT WORK BUT WE WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT IT AND WE'RE GONNA
FOLLOW UP TO SEE WHAT WITHIN
CITY HAS ACTUALLY MOVED FORWARD
WITH IMPLEMENTING. ANY OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. BUT I THINK OF.
IF THE COMMITTEE APPROVED THIS
OP. WHAT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE IS GOING TO PROVIDE. IS
REALLY A COMPREHENSIVE. LISTING
OF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAN
PROVIDE A BLUE PRINT. FOR THE
CITY OF RICHMOND TO REALLY TURN
AROUND ITS FINANCES ITS
OPERATIONS AND ITS MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES WE ALSO HAVE A VERY
ROBUST PROCESS IN PLACE THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO MONITOR THE
CITY'S EFFORTS. TO IMPLEMENT A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN IN AS A
PART OF THAT WE SEE THIS IS A
LONGER TERM RELATIONSHIP WHERE
WE CAN BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND WILL BE THERE TO
PROVIDE ADVICE TO THE CITY. AND
TO SUPPORT ITS EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT A CORRECTIVE CTION
PLAN THAT WOULD ADDRESS ITS
FINANCIAL AND OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES AT THE END OF THE
DAY RESULT IN THE PROVISION OF
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
SERVICES FOR ITS RESIDENTS. IN
TERMS OF BUDGET WE THINK THIS
THING WILL TAKE ABOUT TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED HOURS AND ADEQUATE
TO ABOUT A FOUR MONTH AUDIT
EFFORT. BUT I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT WE WOULD NOT BE ON
SITE IN THE CITY OF RICHMOND
PERFORMANCE LIKELY WE'D BE
THERE FOR TWO OR THREE MONTHS
THE REST OF THE TIME WE BE.
PLANNING SUMMARIZING OUR WORK
IN DOING REPORT WRITING SO WE
DON'T SEE THIS AS BEING A
BURDEN TO THE CITY OF RICHMOND
WHO WOULD GET IN THERE GET OUR
WORK DONE AS EFFECTIVELY. AND
EFFICIENTLY AS WE CAN. RIGHT
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
PRESENTATION AT THIS TIME LET'S
MOVE TO THE AFFECTED AGENCIES.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOMEONE ON
THE LINE FROM THE CITY OF
RICHMOND- MADAM OERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE Q. THE CITY OF
RICHMOND. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE PROCEED. I DO NOT SEE
ANY CO HOST ON THE LINE RIGHT
NOW. NOW SEEM TO BE DROPPED OFF.
OKAY HELLO ALLOW NOT
PARTICULARLY USER. GET BACK ON.
ALL RIGHT WELL WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE PHONE LINE LET ME ASK
IF THERE IS- PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ON THIS ITEM THIS IS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH EIGHT OH SIX
WILL BE ASKING PUBLIC TESTIMONY
HERE THE CHAMBER. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE LET ME ASK THERE'S
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT A REMOTE-
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE I WILL
RETURN BACK TO THE PHONE LINES-
BATTERY OPERATED WE HAVE THE
CITY OF RICHMOND BACK ONLINE.
YOU KNOW THE FIRST. NAME OR IS
IT JUST THE CITY. WE DON'T HAVE
A NAME AT THIS TIME JUST THE
CITY OF RICHMOND REPRESENT
AMERICAN CITY RICH. YES I DO
NOT SEE ANYBODY. FROM THE CITY
OF NEW RICHMOND ON ON THE LINE
AS A CO HOST. THE MEMORY I DO
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE TWO NAMES-
WE HAVE THE MAYOR IN THE CITY
MANAGER FROM THE CITY OF
RICHMOND IF WE HAVE EITHER ONE
OF THEM ON- WITH BRIDGET FOR
PROCEDURE TESTIMONY AT THIS
TIME. YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO SEE.
SO WE DON'T HAVE TIME. NUMBER.
OKAY ABOUT MODERATE REPS WE CAN
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND MAYBE THEY MIGHT
BE IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE-
LET'S ASK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS FILE ITEM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH EIGHT OH SIX WHETHER
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION PLEASE. YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ONE
ZERO. AGAIN THAT SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IT'S ONE TEN ZERO TO
GET THE Q. N. SIR TERRY NOT
ANYBODY QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND- RETURN THIS
ITEM BACK TO. MEMBERS HERE IN
THE CHAMBER ON THE COMMITTEE
AND ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. HEARING
AND SEEING NINE CAN I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THIS
ITEM. MOVED BY SENATOR LEYVA
SECOND BY SENATOR GLAZIER-
BETTER STRUCTURE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
EIGHT OH SIX LOCAL HIGH RISK
ASSESSMENT CITY OF RICHMOND BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS
I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I HIGHLY.
PATTERSON RUBIO RUBIO I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD. SENATOR LAYERED.
LAYERED I BAKER. BAKER I
GORGEOUS FOR JUST AYE GLAZER.
GLAZIER I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE LEYVA. LEYVA AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I. K. THAT MOTION
CARRIES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD
ON THAT TAKES US TO OUR FINAL
ITEM FROM CENTER HERTZBERG THIS
IS AGENDA ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE ONE
FIVE SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM
SUTTER HERTZBERG WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE I AM READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR CHAIRMAN-
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF PROP
THIRTEEN AND PART OF THE WHOLE
US SERRANO VERSUS PRIEST CASES
OF THOSE RECALL THE IMPACTS OF
ALLOCATING MONEY AND RESOURCES
PARTICULARLY FOR SCHOOLS AREN'T
THERE HAS BEEN EFFORTS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS WHAT YOU KNOW
SIXTEEN YEARS BEFORE WE CAME TO
AN AGREEMENT OF HOW TO FINANCE
SCHOOLS HOW DO WE DO THAT PROP
THIRTEEN WITH THE LIMITATIONS
THERE WAS LESS MONEY COMING
FROM THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD NEW SCHOOLS
WE HAD FORMALLY DILAPIDATED
SCHOOLS WITH THOSE TIMES WITH
OVERCROWDING PROBLEMS. WHAT DO
WE DO. IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. BROWN THE CLOCK
NEGOTIATIONS WE FINALLY CAME TO
A BREAKTHROUGH IT WAS SB FIFTY.
THE AUTHOR ALTHOUGH HE WAS IN
THE ROOM AS OFTEN HAPPENS WAS.
LEROY GREEN TOOL TO QUIT FOR
THOSE THAT REMEMBER. HE WAS THE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WITH NEGOTIATED THIS
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. AND WE
CAME UP WITH SB FIFTY WHICH
BECAME PROPOSITION ONE A. WHICH
WAS ADOPTED BY THE VOTERS- BY
63% VOTE. THAT STRUCTURE FOR
SCHOOL FINANCE WAS QUITE
BRILLIANT. IN TERMS OF HOW IT
WORKS. EXCEPT IT HAD SOME
ISSUES- THERE WAS A CASE FILED
BY A SERIES OF GROUPS ONE OF
THE PEOPLE TO WITNESS HERE
TODAY BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SAN FRANCISCO CALLED WILLIAMS
VERSUS STATE SUBSEQUENTLY GO TO
AS- CURSES SCHWARZENEGGER IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. THAT
LOOKED AT THE ALLOCATION ON
POPULATION AND THERE WAS A
ISSUE OF SCHOOLS WE ARE
BUILDING NEW SCHOOLS VERSUS
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE HAD
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IT WAS
QUITE IT WAS QUITE DIFFICULT
ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN THE
BILLION DOLLAR SETTLEMENT FROM
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES FUNDING
STATE ALLOCATION BOARD.
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT. I ACTUALLY
CREATED A BE SIXTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO AND TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. WHICH RESULTED
IN BY THE WAY THAT PROP ONE A.
WAS NINE POINT SOMETHING
BILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN I DID
PROP BUT SB SIXTEEN WHICH WAS
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN
PROPOSITION FIFTY FIVE BOTH OF
WHICH PASSED. AUTHORIZING MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
SCHOOL MODERNIZATION SUBSEQUENT
TO THAT SCHWARZEN SCHNITZEL DID
ONE. UP PROPOSITION ONE D.
PASSED AND THEN THERE WAS
ANOTHER ONE PASSED IT YOU KNOW-
SHOULD TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO
FUND THE SCHOOLS. AND SO WHAT'S
HAPPENED HAS BEEN THERE'S BEEN
A QUESTION BROADLY SPEAKING
BROADLY SPEAKING THAT AS A
RESULT THERE HAS BEEN. THE BILL
GROUP ENROLLMENT GROWTH HAS
DRAMATICALLY SLOWED ACROSS THE
STATE THE RECENT YEARS. IT IS
DECLINING IN MANY COMMUNITIES
AND THE EMPHASIS BY THE STATE
FACILITIES PROGRAM HAS SHIFTED
FROM CONSTRUCTION OF NEW
FACILITIES TO MODERNIZATION AND
REHABILITATION OF EXISTING
SCHOOL FACILITIES. A TWENTY
TWENTY. STUDY BY THE PUBLIC
POLICIES CALIFORNIA BORDER
WHICH ARE USED TO SERVE ON
FOUND THAT 38% OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS GO TO SCHOOLS THAT
DON'T MEET THE MINIMUM FACILITY
STANDARDS. THERE WAS ALSO A
STUDY. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
STUDY BY BERKELEY SIMILARLY
DEALING WITH INADEQUATE AND
INEQUITABLE FACILITIES IN A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STUDY BY
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SIMILAR
CONCLUSIONS. AND SO THE
QUESTION BECOMES AS WE EMBARK
ON ON THE NEXT STEP. ALL OF
SCHOOL FACILITIES FINANCING
WHICH WE HAVE TO DO WHICH I
FUNDAMENTALLY SUPPORT. WE NEED
DATA AND I WANT TO I WANT YOU
KNOW MENTION THIS IN MY CLOTHES
ON. TO NARROW THE TERM I WAS
TOLD BY THE AUDITOR WAS
DETERMINES DOWN SCOPE THE AUDIT
JUST TO DEAL WITH MODERNIZATION
NUMBER ONE. AND TWO TO ASK FOR
URGENCY IF THAT'S THE RIGHT
TERM SO THAT WE CAN GET THIS
DONE IN TIME THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S EDUCATED. WHAT
ARE THE STUDIES SHOW. IS THERE
A REAL ISSUE OR NOT IF IT IS
WHAT'S THE SCOPE OF THE ISSUE.
AND THEN INCORPORATE THAT IN
OUR HOUSE AND TWENTY TWO
EFFORTS OR ANY OTHER EFFORTS
BEYOND. SO THAT THE BOTTOM LINE
OF OUR BODIES LEGISLATURE. IS
TO TRY TO IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS TO
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE FACING.
AND THEN THE CONT CONSCIOUSLY
AND COVER AND CONSISTENTLY
COURSE CORRECT TO LEARN TO GROW
TO GET BETTER TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM WORK BETTER TO IMPROVE
WHAT'S GOING ON. THE PATTERNS
OF STUDENTS IS GOING SCHOOLS
CHANGED. THE NUMBER OF NEW
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN PAID
EVAN- BUILT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY. BUT ALL THAT
BEING SAID WE HAVE TO BE ON OUR
TOES WE HAVE TO BE ON TOP OF IT
SO THIS IS NOT AN AUDIT THAT'S
DOING ANYTHING. THAT'S ADVERSE
TO SCHOOLS IT CELEBRATES. AND I
WANT TO FOCUS THAT NEAR THE
FOCUS DOWNSIZED TO JUST. IN THE
IN THE LETTER TO MODERNIZATION
BECAUSE THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
THIS WHAT WE GOTTA DO TO
MODERNIZATION DOES THE
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING THE
CHALLENGE AND TO. ASK FOR
URGENCY PROVISION SO THAT THIS
THING CAN GET DONE QUICKLY AND
WE CAN BE INFORMED AS WE MARCH
FORWARD IN THE IMPORTANT.
PROCESS OF EDUCATING OUR
STUDENTS AND MAKING SURE
THEY'RE IN CLASSROOMS THAT
THEY'RE SAFE. AND WE GET IT
RIGHT AND WE CONTINUE TO DO IT
AND THE NEXT LEGISLATURE AND
THE NEXT LEGISLATURE FIGURE OUT
HOW TO IMPROVE IT. I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR
TWENTY SOME YEARS AND EVERY DAY
I KEEP LEARNING AND THIS IS
JUST ANOTHER STEP FORWARD IN
THAT MARCH I ASK YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE SITE. THANK SENATOR
HERTZBERG NAY DO BELIEVE YOU
HAVE- TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT FOR
MR WHICH I JUST WANT TO SHOW
YOU. I DON'T GET THAT FOR THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE PERFECT EYES.
HERE'S A PICTURE THAT'S IN MY
OFFICE OF THE NEGOTIATING TEAM.
BIPARTISAN NEGOTIATING TEAM
BACK IN NINETY EIGHT. THAT LED
THIS NEGOTIATIONS STARTED THE
PROCESS IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR SHARING A
BIT OF HISTORY WITH US IN THE
PHOTO FREESHEET THAT AT THIS
TIME LET'S MOVE TO MADAM
OPERATOR TO THE PHONE LINES DO
WE HAVE STEVE ENGLISH THE
FOUNDING CO DIRECTOR OF THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT ON THE LINE
TO SPEAK IN. AS A TESTIMONY
WITNESS. I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I GET RIGHT TO
THE POINT NOW SPEAK FAST-
SEVERAL ACADEMIC STUDIES HAVE
FOUND- DISTURBING PATTERNS AS A
MISTER TENDER'S BIGGEST
SUGGESTED OF THE IN IN IN
EQUITY IN THE EXPENDITURES OF
STATE FUNDS- FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROJECTS- GENERALLY-
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROJECTS ARE
FUNDED WITH A COMBINATION OF
STATE DOLLARS AND DOLLARS
RAISED BY A LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND THE STATE MATCHES
THE LOCAL THE LOCALLY RAISED
FUNDS ACCORDING TO A FORMULA
AND THE FORMULA IS DIFFERENT
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
AND MODERNIZATION PROJECT. MY
MAIN FOCUS HERE IS WITH
MODERNIZATION PROJECT THESE ARE
PROJECTS TO UPGRADE EXISTING
FACILITIES FOR EXAMPLE TO
REPLACE A LEAKY ROOF OR FAILING
HVAC SYSTEM. WHEN THE
RESEARCHERS- LOOKED AT THE
AMOUNTS THAT THE STATE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RECEIVED IN
MODERNIZATION FUNDING FROM THE
STATE OVER A TWENTY YEAR PERIOD
THEY FOUND A VERY GREAT
DISPARITY IN WHAT WAS GIVEN TO
THE DISTRICTS BY THE STATE ON A
PER PUPIL BASIS. FOR EXAMPLE
THE BEST A FUNDED DISTRICT THE
TOP 20% OF THE DISTRICTS THAT
RECEIVED THE HIGHEST FUNDING
PER PUPIL- THEY RECEIVED ON
AVERAGE OVER TWENTY YEARS ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND. FIVE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS PER PUPIL
IN STATE MODERNIZATION FUNDING
IN CONTRAST TO THE WORST BONTA
DISTRICT THE 20% TO RECEIVE THE
LEAST STATE FUNDING RECEIVED ON
AVERAGE ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY DOLLARS PER PUPIL IN
THE MODERNIZATION FUNDING FROM
THE STATE. THE RESEARCHERS ALSO
FOUND A STRONG CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE WEALTH OF A
DISTRICT IN TERMS OF THE
PROPERTY VALUES IN THE DISTRICT
AND THE AMOUNT OF MODERNIZATION
FUNDS TO DISTRICTS RECEIVED
FROM THE STATE IN GENERAL THE
WEALTHY DISTRICTS WERE THE ONES
THAT RECEIVED THE MOST STATE
FUNDING PER PUPIL. AND THE
POOREST TO. WERE THE ONES THAT
RECEIVE THE LEAST. STATE
FUNDING PER PUPIL- AS- CENTER
HER FERGUS- ABOUT 4% OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS GO TO
SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT MEET
MINIMUM FACILITY STANDARDS. AND
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
DEFICIENCIES ARE IN THE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE LOWER
PROPERTY VALUES. SO STATE FUNDS
ARE BEING PAID OUT HERE AND IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE ACADEMIC RESEARCH THERE IS
WARRANT. FOR THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE TO BRING IT TO POLICY
EXPERTS PEACE AND ANALYTICAL
SKILLS. TO BEAR HERE TO REVIEW
AND VALIDATE OR DISPEL UPDATE
THESE ACADEMIC FINDINGS ABOUT
THE EXISTENCE AND THE MAGNITUDE
OF ANY WEALTH BASED IN EQUITY
IN THE MODERNIZATION PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER ENGLISH
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO- THE STATE
AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION. OF THE
REQUEST THAT'S WITHIN THE SCOPE
AND RULES OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
MADAM AUDITOR PLEASE PROCEED
THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
AS CENTER HERTZBERG INDICATED
HIT IT APPEARS HIS HE WANTS US
TO FOCUS ON MODERNIZATION
WHICH- WE CAN WE CAN CERTAINLY
DO- BUT LET ME GO THROUGH THE
OBJECTIVES THAT ARE IN THE YARD
ANALYSIS. UP CERTAINLY LOOKING
AT THE PUBLIC SCHOOL CAN NAY
OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION THEIR
ADMINISTRATION OF THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES OUT PROGRAMS FUNDING
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE FUNDING
RELATED TO MODERNIZATION. I'M
ALSO LOOKING AT METHODS BY
WHICH BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FINANCE ARE
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE OF
CRITICAL FACILITIES AND WE CAN
WE CAN PAIR BACK- REVIEW OF
CONSTRUCTION AND REALLY FOCUS
ON MODERNIZATION. BUT I THINK
THE HEART OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT- CENTER HERTZBERG AND HIS
WITNESSES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
OUR CLEARLY OBJECTIVES FOR FIVE
AND SIX- THE FLOOR IS RELATED
TO LOOKING AT SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND LOOKING AT HER
PUPIL VALUE OF ASSESSED
PROPERTY. AND THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THAT AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS AND ASSESS WHETHER
THERE ARE EQUITY GAPS IN
FINANCING- OBJECTIVE FIVE LOOKS
AGAIN AT A SELECTION OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND EVALUATING THOSE
DISTRICTS EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND ADEQUATE PUBLIC SCHOOL
FACILITIES FOR. CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA LOOKING AT THE
SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY CARDS OUR
REPORT CARDS WHICH REPORT ON
CONDITIONS IN SCHOOLS AND
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT
SCHOOLS ARE MEETING MINIMUM
BENCHMARKS ARE THEIR
DEFICIENCIES WERE THE DISTRICTS
DOING TO MITIGATE THOSE
DEFICIENCIES- SS SILVA NEEDS
IDENTIFY OUTCOMES. EVALUATE
METHODS BY WHICH- DISTRICTS ARE
FINANCING WE SAY CONSTRUCTION
AND MAINTENANCE- THAT SOUNDS
LIKE HE WANTS US TO REALLY
FOCUS ON MODERNIZATION- SO WE
WOULD WOULD- PARA BACK OR NOT
REALLY. LOOK AT CONSTRUCTION-
OBJECTIVE SIX AS THE FUTURE
NEED FOR MODERN IS. AND PRESENT
BY OP IF THEY ARE THAT WE COULD
IDENTIFY BASED ON LOOKING AT
RESEARCH AT CETERA- FOR REVENUE
THEN THE LAST OBJECTIVE IS
REALLY TO THE EXTENT WE
POSSIBLY CAN'T AGAIN I BELIEVE
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT THIS WE
THINK WE WOULD NEED TO LOOK AT
RESEARCH WHERE. IT'S TRYING TO
ASSESS THE EFFECT OF DEFERRED
MODERNIZATION DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ON STATEWIDE.
HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES- IF THERE'S DEFERRED
MODERNIZATION DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF SCHOOL
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
CURRENTLY REPORTS TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED HOURS IF WE PARED BACK
I CAN'T GIVE YOU AN EXACT
ESTIMATE OF HOW MUCH THE ON IT
WOULD- THE COST OF THE AUDIT
AND THE TIME IT WOULD TAKE TO
COMPLETE WOULD BE REDUCED BUT
IT. CERTAINLY WOULD BE REDUCED.
THAT'S IT MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OUR
WATER AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION. AS WELL WE
APPRECIATE THAT WITH THAT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES- WITH THIS.
PRODUCT THAT WOULD BE I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ON THE LINE LISA
SILVERMAN. WITH THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
THIS IS OVER AND GET OUT THERE
AND WILL CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND LISA
SILVERMAN EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE OX THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. I KNOW THIS IS
BASICALLY PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF-
OCCASIONAL SERVICES. AFTER
AFTER THE BOARD WE PROCESS THE
PROGRAM GRANT- APPLICATIONS AND
IT MICHAEL DISTRICTS. THE
APPLICATIONS ARE REVIEWED
EVALUATED AND PROFITS IN THE
COURSE OF STATUTES AND
REGULATIONS- AND PRESENT TO THE
BOARD. FOR MONTHLY APPROVAL.
FISCAL FACILITY PROGRAM IS A
MATCH PROGRAM A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE.
AT THIS OKAY THREE IS HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY THAT IS. AT SUPPORT
THE STATE OF- I REVIEW AND-
AGAINST THAT SUGGESTED- YES
THEY OUT OF HER SHOULD LOOK AT
OUTSIDE RESOURCES OKAY IF HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE DATA. SO WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO COOPERATE
WITH THE STATE HONOR AT THIS
TIME AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENTS LET
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN THE CHAMBER HEARING
AND SEEING NINE MASK THERE'S A
PUBLIC COMMENT- REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. HEARING AND
SEEING NINE. BATUM OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE Q. THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASH ONE ONE FIVE. AND WHEN
PEOPLE GET ONLINE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION WE'D
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE PROCEED.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASH ONE ONE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
IT SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH. ONE ONE
FIVE ONE ZERO. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP
RESEARCH HERE THANK YOU MADAM
OPERATOR LET ME RETURN THIS
ITEM TO MEMBERSOF THE
COMMITTEE LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ON THIS FILE ITEM- SENATOR
GLAZER PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU JEFF THANK YOU CARE SALAS I
JUST WANTED TO THANK AND
COMMEND- THE SENATOR FROM THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR HIS-
DEDICATED THAT ENGAGEMENT IN
THIS IMPORTANT SPACE FOR A LONG
LONG TIME AND- HIS PASSION FOR
OUR KIDS. AND OUR SCHOOLS IS-
SECOND TO NONE AND I APPRECIATE
THE NARROWING THAT HE HAS DONE
IN TERMS OF THE FOCUS OF THIS.
AUDIT AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
SENATOR AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
A MEASURE ON THIS AS WELL SO I
BILL TWENTY TWO. CENTREBOARD
JUST PLEASE. BUT IT. ALL RIGHT
SENATOR NELSON PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES AND DELIGHTED TO
STAND UP ON THIS- MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FERNANDO WHO
BLAZED THE TRAIL HERE. I CAN
SAY I SOMEWHAT PRECEDED HIM IN
TERMS OF SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION I
THINK I'M STILL THE THIRD
LONGEST TENURED MEMBER ON THE
STATE ALLOCATION BOARD WHICH IS
THE STATE ENTITY THAT ALLOCATES
THE FUNDING. AND I SERVED WITH
THE LEGENDARY LEROY GREAT NO
ONE WILL EXCEED LEROY'S TENURE
BUT I CAME CLOSE. DURING THOSE
YEARS IN THIS WOULD BE THROUGH
THE LATE SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES.
WE MOSTLY WERE FOCUSED ON
ALLOCATING DOLLARS FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION. BUT WHAT WE SAW
WAS A TREMENDOUS DEMAND AND
NEED ON REHABILITATION WE ALSO
SAW THAT AS A GOOD WAY TO
EXPAND OUR ADVOCACY OUR VALUE
TO THE KIDS TO THE SCHOOLS BY
THE REHABILITATING. AND SAVING
SOME OF THE SCHOOLS THAT WERE
DETERIORATING. NOW WE'VE COME A
LONG WAYS EVEN FURTHER WHEREBY
WITH DECLINING ENROLLMENT. AND
WITH FACILITIES DETERIORATING.
THERE'S A CHANGE IN THE
DYNAMICS. AND THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD ATTEMPT FOR US TO GET MORE
CURRENT AND NOT JUST BE DEALING
WITH SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION. FROM
SUPPOSITION. AND GUESSING THIS
WOULD GIVE US SOMETHING
CONCRETE SO I CERTAINLY ENDORSE
THIS I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA
AND IT WOULD BE A VERY NEEDED
IDEA BASED ON CONTEMPORARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. THANK YOU
SENATOR LET ME ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. LET ME GO AHEAD AND
JUST SAY CENTER HERTZBERG
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD I BELIEVE IT'S
HIGHLY COMMENDABLE I THINK IT'S
MORALLY RIGHT THAT WE LOOK AT
THE EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
BETWEEN WEALTHY AND LOWER
INCOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING. LET
ME ASK FOR CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE WAS A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS THAT MADE A
MOTION THIS IS A MOTION THAT
INCLUDES THE DOWN SCOPING WHICH
IS ALLOWED WITHIN THE RULES AS
SPECIFIED BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
TAKE OUT NEW SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION A LOOK AT THE
MODERNIZATION FUNDING. I
BELIEVE THE INITIAL MOTION WAS
BY SENATOR GLAZER WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION AND I BELIEVE
THERE WAS A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH ON THAT
IN WITH THAT- MADAM SECRETARY
CALLED ROCKET CANNOT CAN I.
PLEASE IF YOU LIKE CLOSER TO
CLOSE IT OUT AND FURTHER
CLARIFICATIONS POSSIBLE IF
THERE'S A WAY TO GO IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE PRIORITIZATION IS
THE WORD I'M TOLD BY THE-
AUDITOR'S OFFICE THAT I SHOULD
REQUEST IN ADDITION TO THE
NARROWING OF THOSE TWO WORDS WE
TOOK OUT OF THE SCOPE AND I
WANT TO JUST A- YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE GREAT. PORTEN ASPECTS OF
THIS BUSINESS IS CHARACTER. AND
CHARACTER MEANS YOU RECOGNIZE
WHEN YOU MADE IN THE STATE. AND
SENATOR GLAZER POINTED OUT TO
ME A MISTAKE THAT I MADE I WANT
TO CLARIFY FOR THE RECORD. AND
CERTAINLY- CENTER NIELSEN KNOWS
THIS. BUT RALPH DILLS WAS TOO
OLD TO QUIT. LEROY GREENE WAS
TOUGH OLD BIRD THAT WAS HIS- IS
DEALS WITH PRIORITIZATION WITH
THAT. I WOULD I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND- YOUR SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE MISTAKE I
MADE- TO SENATOR GRIFFIN SAID
SENATOR DETAILS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET. IF YOU LOOK AT IT
INTO. IT SO WE'RE GOING TO.
SENATOR GLAZER PLEASE. LIKE IT
MAKE SURE I'VE I'VE ADDED THAT
CORRECTLY TO THE MOTION TO ASK
THAT WE PRIORITIZE THANK YOU
OKAY SO THE CLARIFICATION ON
THE MOTION BY SENATOR GLAZIER
IS TO DOWN SCOPE. THE ODD
REQUEST AND TO ADD THE
PRIORITIZATION- TO THE THOUGHT
OF REQUEST AS WELL- LET ME ASK
FOR A SECOND. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BOERNER HORVATH AND MISTER
WOULD BOTH- WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION LET'S GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE AUDIT REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE FIFTEEN
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS I
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I KILEY KILEY I PATTERSON.
RUBIO RUBIO I VOEPEL. VOEPEL I
WOULD. WOOD I SENATOR LAYERED.
LAYERED I BACKER. BACKER I FOR
JUST. FOR JUST SUPPLY BLASIER.
GLAZER AYE HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE LEYVA. LEYVA AYE NIELSEN
NIELSEN I. K. THAT MOTION
CARRIES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THIS
TIME MEMBERS WE DO HAVE ONE
ITEM THAT IS STILL ON CALL- BUT
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND- CALL ALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND A MEMBER
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE SHOULD REPORT TO THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME TO ADD ON.
LET US FIRST BEGIN WITH THE
MOTION THAT IS ON CALL THIS IS
MISTER NAZARIAN SYSTEMS. AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH FIVE
PEACE OFFICERS HE GROUP%
AFFILIATIONS. MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR
AUDIT REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASH ONE OF FIVE PEACE OFFICERS
HATE GROUP AFFILIATIONS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON.
RUBIO RUBIO I SENATOR BARGES
THANK YOU TO. BORJAS NONVOTING
GLAZIER. GLAZIER I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE NIELSEN ALL RIGHT.
NIELSEN I TO KNOW. K. THAT
MOTION CARRIES AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK THROUGH
THE- AGENDA CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MADAM SECRETARY. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BEGIN THE CONCERN.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA FIRST
BEGIN ON THE INITIAL MOTION TO
SUSPEND. JOINT RULES THIRTEEN
AND FIFTEEN WE WILL OR NOT.
THREE SYSTEM AGAINST THE- SEVEN
BILLION THIRTEEN AND.
FIFTEEN
RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ON THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
WAVING- DURING A ROLL THIRTEEN
AND FIFTY. FOR SUSPENDING JAIL
ACROSS THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY. WELL AS
FOR THE KIDS I CAN WONDER. NOW
SO YOU HAVE TO SUSPEND THE
RULES KILEY I. PATTERSON.
SENATOR BARGES FOR JUST I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I. AND
SINCE. THE CONCERT CALENDAR
PASSES LET'S MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MADAM
SECRETARY CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FOUR ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE A ONE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
K. THROUGH TWELVE STRONG WORK
FIRST PROGRAM BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE OH TWO INDIAN
GAMING SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION
FUND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
GARCIA TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE OH EIGHT FAR FAR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER C. GARCIA TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHAT. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASH ONE TWELVE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CHILD
ABUSE CENTRAL INDEX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASH ONE THIRTEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BATTERER
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ELECTRICAL SYSTEM
SAFETY OVERSIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE EIGHTEEN
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD SAFE DRINKING WATER BY
SOMEONE NUMBER SALAS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DASH ONE TWENTY
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IN HOME RESPITE
PROGRAM BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE TWENTY THREE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. HOSPICE
LICENSURE AND OVERSIGHT BY
SENATOR ALAN. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASH EIGHT OH TWO LOCAL HIGH
RISK ASSESSMENT CITY OF COMPTON
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH EIGHT OH
FIVE LOCAL HIGH RISK ASSESSMENT
CITY OF CALEXICO BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY. KILEY I
PATTERSON. SENATOR BORJAS FOR
JUST I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I
THE MOTION CARRIES WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OUR REGULAR CALENDAR
CALENDAR THE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE OH FOUR METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR ALL THE REQUESTS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OF
FOUR METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON.
RUBIO RUBIO I SENATOR BAKER
BACKER I GORGEOUS. FOR JUST AYE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I. THE
MOTION CARRIES REMOVED TO
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OF
SEVEN DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
OVERSIGHT OF REGIONAL CENTERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER MADAM
SECRETARY CALL. FOR AUTOCRATS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OF
SEVEN DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
OVERSIGHT OF REGIONAL CENTERS
BY FAMILY MEMBER FRAZIER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY KILEY II
PATTERSON. RUBIO RUBIO I
SENATOR GLAZIER. GLAZER AYE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I. THAT
MOTION CARRIES REMOVED TO
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE OH
NINE SAN DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
MATTERS ACTUALLY CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR AUDIT
REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE OH NINE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE BY SIMPLY
MEMBER WEBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY. KILEY I PATTERSON. RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SENATOR BAKER. BACKER
I GLAZIER GLAZER AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I. THAT MOTION
CARRIES REMOVED TO AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DASH ONE ONE FOR STATE
AGENCIES MANAGEMENT OF SURPLUS
PROPERTY BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK
SILVA BETTER SURGERY CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR ALL THE
REQUESTS TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH
ONE FOURTEEN STATE AGENCIES
MANAGEMENT OF SURPLUS PROPERTY
BY SOME REMEMBER QUICK SILVA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I HIGHLY KILEY
I PATTERSON. SENATOR GLAZIER.
BLASIER II HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE NIELSEN NIELSEN I. THAT
MOTION CARRIES WERE REMOVED-
CHEN ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE ONE
FIVE SCHOOL FACILITIES BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR ALL THE REQUESTS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH ONE
FIFTEEN SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON. THAT
MOTION CARRIES AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MORE
MINUTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO
MAKE THEIR WAY DOWN IF NOT WE
WILL CONCLUDE THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
WE
ARE WITH THE BEEN HERE LATER
WELL. FOR THE FOR AUDIT REQUEST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DASH EIGHT OH
SIX LOCAL HIGH RISK ASSESSMENT
CITY OF RICHMOND. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD I. THE NEW YORKER.
RIGHT OKAY. NOT A LOT OF YOUR
CURRENT ONE OKAY I HAVE RICHARD
ON ORDER. I THINK YOUR HONOR
BUT ALSO ALL THE- GOVERNOR.
SOME THANKS. OKAY AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
CONCLUDE THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE THE TIME IS
SEVEN OH THREE THANK YOU.